ALL. WE PROCEED WHEN READY.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH. IF
IT'S OKAY WITH YOU, WE'LL START
WITH AB 2085. NO PROBLEM. THANK
YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON. MR. OR GOOD
MORNING. I FEEL LIKE IT'S
AFTERNOON BECAUSE I WAS JUST IN
THIS HEARING ROOM LESS THAN 12
HOURS AGO, GOOD MORNING, MR.
CHAIR. AND SENATORS, I WANT TO
START BY THANKING THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR THEIR HARD WORK ON
THIS BILL. AND ACCEPTING
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS. Þ, DID YOU.
IS EVERYTHING OKAY? OH OUR VICE
CHAIR WOULD PREFER IF YOU
STARTED WITH 1042. IS THAT OKAY?
IS THERE A PARTICULAR REASON,
NO, I THINK IS THAT OKAY? OKAY
YEAH. BECAUSE I HAVE TWO
COMMITTEES GOING AND I HAVE
OTHER BILLS. HE'S A NO SEED GUY.
THIS IS ABOUT SEED. I KNEW
SOMETHING WAS WRONG UP THERE.
YEAH WELL, AS YOU WILL TELL YOU,
HE WORKS IN THIS INDUSTRY, SO I
SERVED WITH HIM BEFORE HE CAME
TO YOUR HOUSE. I KNOW WE SAT ON,
ESTARÁ TOGETHER. RIGHT, OKAY, SO
CHANGE OF PLANS. AB 1042, AT THE
DISCRETION OF THE VICE CHAIR.
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE, I WANT TO START BY
ACCEPTING THESE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS, AND THANK THE STAFF
FOR THEIR HARD WORK ON THIS
BILL. I KNOW THAT THERE'S BEEN
INCREDIBLE WORK TO TRY TO GET
THIS TO A GOOD PLACE. AND I WANT
TO THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR THAT,
I'M PROUD TODAY TO PRESENT AB
1042. IT'S A SIMPLE BILL THAT
REQUIRES TREATED SEED LABELS TO
INCLUDE THE AMOUNT OF EACH
TREATMENT USED CURRENTLY IN THE
STATE. TREATED SEED LABELS MUST
IDENTIFY THE TREATMENTS USED.
HOWEVER, THEY DON'T INCLUDE THE
CONCENTRATION AMOUNT OF THOSE
TREATMENTS. WITH INCREASING
LEVEL OF TREATMENTS ON SEEDS,
IT'S IMPORTANT TO UNDERSTAND THE
IMPACT OF THE PESTICIDES. AND I
WANT TO BE CLEAR, THIS BILL. NOR
DO I THINK WE SHOULDN'T BE
TREATING SEEDS. I UNDERSTAND THE
IMPORT OF TREATED SEEDS AS
OPPOSED TO SPRAY PESTICIDES, BUT
THIS INFORMATION IS CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT. THE TREATMENTS USED
ON SEEDS ARE OFTEN SYSTEMIC,
MEANING THEY STAY IN THE PLANTS
THROUGH THEIR LIFE CYCLE.
RESEARCH HAS SHOWN THAT WHEN
APPLIED DIRECTLY TO A SEED, 95%
OR MORE OF THE ACTIVE
INGREDIENTS TYPICALLY STAY IN
THE SOIL, AFFECTING OUR WATER
SUPPLY AND OUR FOOD SOURCE.
EXPOSURE FROM PESTICIDES AND
SEEDS HAS BEEN LINKED TO BEE
POPULATION DECLINE AND NEGATIVE
HEALTH IMPACT FOR HUMANS. LET ME
BE CLEAR CERTAIN PESTICIDES, NOT
ALL MAKING THE CONCENTRATION
INFORMATION OF SEED TREATMENTS
MORE TRANSPARENT WILL MAKE
PROGRESS TOWARDS PROTECTING
POLLINATORS, WATER AND HUMAN
HEALTH, AS WELL AS EMPOWER OUR
FARMERS TO COMPARE THE EFFICACY
OF DIFFERENT TREATMENT OPTIONS
AND HELP THEM MAKE INFORMED
DECISIONS. WHEN CHOOSING
TREATMENTS. THE BILL IS NOT A
PROHIBITION OF TREATED SEEDS. IT
SIMPLY PROVIDES THAT ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION TO FARMERS AND
RESEARCHERS TO ASSESS THE
UTILITY AND IMPACT OF DIFFERENT
SEED TREATMENTS ON THE
ENVIRONMENT. WE HAVE WORKED ON
SIGNIFICANT AMENDMENTS TO
ADDRESS THE CONCERNS OF THE
OPPOSITION. YOU'LL HEAR WE'RE
NOT 100% THERE YET, SO BUT WE
HAVE DONE A LOT TO TRY TO MAKE
SURE WE'RE ADDRESSING THEIR
CONCERNS, AND WE'LL CONTINUE TO
DO SO HERE WITH ME TODAY TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS, DARRYL
LITTLE FROM NRDC AND STEVE
BLACKLEDGE, SENIOR DIRECTOR OF
CONSERVATION AMERICA CAMPAIGN
ENVIRONMENT AMERICA MAY PROCEED.
GOOD MORNING, MISTER CHAIR,
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE, I'M
STEVE BLACKLEDGE. I'M THE SENIOR
DIRECTOR OF CONSERVATION FOR
ENVIRONMENT CALIFORNIA. WE'RE
PLEASED TO SPONSOR AB 1042,
WHICH IS A BILL ABOUT
PESTICIDES, A BILL ABOUT
TRANSPARENCY, AND A BILL THAT'S
IMPORTANT FOR POLLINATORS AND
WILDLIFE IN CALIFORNIA, AS I
THINK YOU KNOW, CALIFORNIA, A
COUPLE OF YEARS AGO PASSED
LEGISLATION TO RESTRICT THE SALE
OF PESTICIDES TO ORDINARY
CONSUMERS, THOSE WITHOUT A
LICENSE TO APPLY PESTICIDES. THE
INTENT OF THIS BILL, THEN, IS TO
START TO GATHER, START TO
PROVIDE TRANSPARENCY FOR ANOTHER
WAY IN WHICH PESTICIDES AND IN
SOME VERY HARMFUL BEE KILLING
PESTICIDES ARE GETTING INTO THE
ENVIRONMENT. SO THE TREATED OR
COATED SEEDS OR THE TREATMENT OF
SEEDS, THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL
DOES, IT'S IMPORTANT BECAUSE
WE'VE SEEN MAJOR BEE DIE OFFS OF
OUR NATIVE BEES IN CALIFORNIA
AND ACROSS THE COUNTRY. AS THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS SAYS,
PESTICIDES DON'T STAY PUT. THEY
DON'T STAY ON THE SEED. THEY GET
INTO THE ENVIRONMENT, INTO THE
SOIL, INTO THE WATER. AND THIS
IS AN IDEA THAT CENTERED ON THE
IDEA THAT FARMERS ARE THE
ORIGINAL CONSERVATIONISTS.
FARMERS CAN USE THIS
INFORMATION, THIS PROVIDES THE
AMOUNT OF PESTICIDES THAT ARE ON
THE SEEDS, HELPFUL FOR FARMING,
FARMING AND FARMERS AS WELL. AND
WE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE. GOOD MORNING, CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. I'M DARRYL LITTLE
JUNIOR WITH THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL. WE
ARE PROUD SUPPORTERS, OUR
SPONSORS OF AB 1042, WHICH WILL
PROVIDE GREATER CLARITY TO
GROWERS REGARDING THE PESTICIDES
USED TO COAT CROP SEEDS OR SEED
TREATMENTS. CURRENTLY, LABELS
FOR A TREAT SEEDED TREATED SEEDS
ARE REQUIRED TO IDENTIFY THE
PESTICIDES USED IN THE SEED
TREATMENTS, BUT NOT THE AMOUNTS.
AB 1042 WOULD SIMPLY REQUIRE THE
AMOUNTS TO BE LISTED AS WELL.
THIS IS IMPORTANT BECAUSE THE
USE OF SEED TREATMENTS IS
WIDESPREAD IN CALIFORNIA, WITH
ACCURATE, EASILY ACCESSIBLE
QUANTITY INFORMATION FOR SEED
TREATMENTS, FARMERS WILL BE ABLE
TO COMPARE SEED TREATMENT
PRODUCTS AND REDUCE USE OF
UNNECESSARY, HARMFUL AND OFF THE
OFTEN COSTLY CHEMICAL INPUTS.
SEED TREATMENT QUANTITY
INFORMATION IS PARTICULARLY
IMPORTANT FOR SEEDS TREATED WITH
NEONIC PESTICIDES. NEONICS ARE
EXTREMELY TOXIC TO POLLINATORS,
AND RESEARCH LINKS NEONICS TO
NEUROLOGICAL, DEVELOPMENTAL, AND
REPRODUCTIVE HARMS IN HUMANS
WITH THE TRANSPARENCY AROUND
SEED TREATMENT QUANTITIES THAT
AB 1042 WILL OFFER, IT WILL BE
EASIER FOR FARMERS TO TRACK
THEIR NEEDS, COSTS AND THE
ACTUAL VALUE THEY RECEIVE, AS
WELL AS TAKE NECESSARY SAFETY
PRECAUTIONS WHEN HANDLING AND
USING THESE DANGEROUS CHEMICALS.
AB 1042 IS A LIGHT LIFT THAT WAS
SIGNIFICANTLY IMPROVED
TRANSPARENCY IN CALIFORNIA AND
PROTECT PUBLIC HEALTH AND THE
ENVIRONMENT. WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT, FOLKS, YOU
WANT TO COME TO THE MIC AND
EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR THE BILL? AB
1042. GOOD MORNING, REBECCA
MARCUS REPRESENTING CALPIRG IN
SUPPORT. GOOD MORNING, ABIGAIL
SMIT ON BEHALF OF MIDPENINSULA
REGIONAL OPEN SPACE DISTRICT AND
SUPPORT. GREAT DENIS, SUPPORT.
YOU WANT TO SUPPORT IT? NO. COME
ON, SUPPORT IT. COME ON. WE DO
SUPPORT. ALL RIGHT, ALL RIGHT,
ALL RIGHT. COME ON UP YOUR
PRESSURE. I WORKED ON THIS FOR
QUITE A WHILE. I KNOW, I KNOW,
ALL RIGHT. WE'RE LOOKING FOR
DENNIS ALBIANI HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE, CALIFORNIA SEED
ASSOCIATION, WANT TO THANK YOU.
THANK THE COMMITTEE STAFF HAVE
BEEN OUTSTANDING. THIS BILL, BUT
WAS A WAS CAME LATE IN THE
PROCESS, AND SO WE HAD TO ALL
KIND OF WORK CDFA. THE SENATE
COMMITTEES, BOTH COMMITTEES AND
THAT AND WE'RE GETTING THERE ON
THE AMENDMENT. SO WE APPRECIATE
THAT. I DO WANT TO START WITH A
VERY QUICK LITTLE STORY. WHEN I
FIRST, WELL, WHEN SENATOR DOLLY,
WHO HAPPENS TO BE IN THE SEED
BUSINESS, CAME UP HIS VERY FIRST
YEAR, I BROUGHT HIM A BILL.
SIMPLE BILL ON SEEDS. JUST GOING
TO CHANGE FIVE WORDS. IT'S ALL
WE WERE GOING TO CHANGE. FIVE
WORDS. PUT IT IN. EVERYTHING WAS
GREAT. FIRST COMMITTEE, THE FARM
BUREAU OPPOSED. SO OUR RESIDENT
FARMER GETS OPPOSED BY THE OAN
OAN. THE, FARM BUREAU. WE WORK
IT OUT. THE FIVE WORDS TURNED
INTO 15. MAYBE 20 WORDS. WE GET
THROUGH CLARITY. BUT WHY DO I
TELL YOU THE STORY? NOT ONLY TO
HONOR MR. DOLLY, WHO THIS MAY BE
YOUR LAST EC COMMITTEE HEARING,
BUT THAT THIS IS VERY, VERY
COMPLEX STUFF. WHEN YOU START
TALKING ABOUT WHAT GOES ON IN
THE LABEL, WHAT WHAT'S IN HOW WE
HANDLE TREATED SEEDS, THIS IS
SUBJECT OF A LAWSUIT THAT IS
CURRENTLY ACTUALLY PENDING
NEGOTIATIONS. RIGHT NOW AND WILL
LIKELY BE SETTLED, BEFORE YOU
ALL COME BACK, OR IT'S SUPPOSED
TO BE BY AUGUST 7TH. I BELIEVE
IS THE DATE THAT THAT WILL BE
THE NEXT HEARING. SO THERE IS A
LOT OF ACTIVITY IN THIS. SO IT'S
VERY SENSITIVE SEED. SEED LABELS
ARE LEGAL DOCUMENTS. THEY'RE
OBVIOUSLY INFORMATIVE AND
INTENDED TO INFORM AND THE
REFERENCE DOCUMENTS. SO WE NEED
TO GET IT RIGHT. AND THAT'S ONE
OF THE CHALLENGES THAT THAT
WE'RE WORKING THROUGH, AND THEN
ADDITIONAL UNNECESSARY LANGUAGE
CAN CLUTTER CONFUSE AND ACTUALLY
EVEN CONTRADICT ONE EACH OTHER.
WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT, YOU KNOW,
WHAT'S REQUIRED FOR DIFFERENT
APPLICATIONS. SO THE AMENDMENTS,
WE APPRECIATE THE AMENDMENTS
THAT WORK THROUGH THEM. ALTHOUGH
AND WE HAVE PROVIDED SOME
CLARITY ON THE AMENDMENTS AND
THAT BUT IT WAS AFTER THE, THE,
THE PUBLISHING OF THE ANALYSIS.
SO A COUPLE OF THINGS WE JUST
NEED TO BRING THROUGH. THE EASY
ONES ARE WE NEED TO SELL
THROUGH, FOR PRODUCT THAT IS,
YOU KNOW, PACKAGED AND, AND
STORED BEFORE THE ENACTMENT
DATE, TRANS SHIPMENT. WELL,
TRANS SHIPMENT IS AN ISSUE. THAT
CALIFORNIA WERE OBVIOUSLY A VERY
LARGE AGRICULTURAL STATE, BUT WE
ALSO SHIP AND SERVE OTHER
COUNTRIES, OTHER STATES. SO THE
SEEDS GO THROUGH THE WAY IT WAS
WRITTEN IS IT BASICALLY APPLIES
THIS TO EVERYTHING WE NEED, THE
EXACT OPPOSITE. WE NEED TO APPLY
IT TO SEEDS PLANTED IN
CALIFORNIA. AND SO THAT'S AN
ISSUE WE NEED TO FURTHER REFINE
THE FOCUS ON PESTICIDES. AND
THEN JUST HOW THE APPLICATION
RATE LANGUAGES IS STRUCTURED. SO
WE'VE PROVIDED THE AUTHOR AND
COMMITTEE WITH AMENDED LANGUAGE
AND LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
THESE AS THEY GO THROUGH THE
NEXT COMMITTEES. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, I WANT YOU TO STAY UP
FOR OUR OKAY. SURE. YEAH, OTHER
FOLKS DO WANT TO WEIGH IN IN
OPPOSITION OR VOICE CONCERNS,
TAYLOR. MOTION ON BEHALF OF A
VARIETY OF AGRICULTURAL
ASSOCIATIONS, WE THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR THE AMENDMENTS THUS
FAR AND LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
MORE. THANKS MR. CHAIR. SENATORS
DEAN GARFIELD WITH CAPITOL
ADVOCACY HERE ON BEHALF OF BIO,
ALIGNED WITH THE TESTIMONY, MR.
OBIANO, IN OPPOSITION, THANK
YOU. ON BEHALF OF WHO? SORRY
HALF OF BIO BIO. OKAY. ALL
RIGHT. CAN I ASK THE AUTHOR WHY?
WHY, SUCH A LATE GOTTEN AMEND ON
THIS TOPIC? TO BE CLEAR, IT
WASN'T A GUT AND AMEND. IT WAS A
BILL THAT WAS A TWO YEAR BILL ON
SEEDS FOCUSED ON WHETHER OR NOT,
THE DEPARTMENT HAD THE AUTHORITY
TO REGULATE SEEDS. THAT WAS
OPPOSED BY THE FOLKS THAT ARE
SITTING AT THE TABLE AND THIS
WAS ACTUALLY A NARROWING OF THAT
TO SAY, FINE, WE'RE NOT GOING TO
SAY THEY CAN REGULATE SEEDS.
WE'RE GOING TO LABEL IT. SO I
THINK GUT AND AMEND IS A LITTLE
BIT OF A STRETCH, BECAUSE WE
TRIED TO FIND A COMPROMISE ON A
SEED BILL, AND IT TOOK A
DIFFERENT FORM TO LANGUAGE. IT'S
BRAND NEW LANGUAGE, RIGHT.
BECAUSE WE WERE TRYING TO FIND
SOMETHING THAT EVERYBODY COULD
GET AROUND, AND WE THOUGHT THIS
WAS THE DIRECTION I THINK TO BE
FAIR. AND MISTER ALBIANI CAN
DISAGREE WITH ME. THIS IS MUCH
MORE AMENABLE THAN THE PRIOR
LANGUAGE TO THEM. OKAY YEAH.
OKAY. OKAY. SO AND OKAY, SO IT'S
A MATTER. YOU'RE ALL RIGHT. I
KNOW SENATOR DALY IS GOING TO
WANT TO ASK SOME QUESTIONS.
WELL, FIRST, I WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR WORKING TO GET TO A
POINT WHERE, I THINK WE'RE
REALLY CLOSE. I THINK WE'RE NOT
THAT FAR OFF, SO I WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR THAT. I JUST WANT TO.
FOR THE RECORD, JUST TO KNOW I'M
AN ORGANIC FARMER. I DON'T HAVE
ANY I DON'T USE HE'S A REAL
HIPPIE, ACTUALLY, AT THIS POINT.
I MEAN, I HAVE IN THE PAST, BUT
THE BUT THE ISSUE HERE IS I MAY
HAVE TO IF I HAVE, THE FUNGUS IS
ACTUALLY IN THE FIELD, NOT ON
THE SEED THAT I'M TRYING TO
PREVENT GETTING ON MY SEED. SO I
JUST WANT TO, FOR THE RECORD, TO
KNOW THAT IN THE FUTURE, I MAY
NEED THAT IF I HAVE A FUNGUS
THAT IT COMES IN THROUGH SPORES
OR OTHER THINGS. ANYWAY SO I
JUST WANTED FOR THE AUTHOR, I'M
GOING TO LAY OFF THE BILL
BECAUSE I KNOW THERE'S WE'RE
CLOSE AND I ARE WE CAN WE GET
THERE AS THE POINT? I HAVE TO
LABEL, THOUGH, AND WHAT I PUT ON
MY LABEL IS, IT'S A HUGE
LIABILITY FOR ME. SO IF IT'S NOT
WHAT I SAY IS IN THERE AND SO I
GET TESTED, THEN I'M, I'M ON THE
HOOK FOR SOMEBODY TO COME AFTER
ME. THAT'S THAT'S THE TRICK
HERE. THAT'S WHAT I THINK. I'LL
JUST SAY IT OUT LOUD. I DON'T
WANT TO GET SUED BECAUSE I'M OFF
BY, YOU KNOW, WE HAVE, WE HAVE
TO HAVE THE WE HAVE TO HAVE WHAT
WE SAY IS IF IT'S WHEAT, IT HAS
TO BE WHEAT. IT CAN'T BE OATS.
AND THERE CAN BE VERY. AND SO
WHAT'S ON THAT LABEL IS WHAT I'M
LIABLE FOR. AND SO THAT'S WHAT
I'M CONCERNED ABOUT IS IF
THERE'S, TREATMENT, WHICH IS IF
IT'S TREATED, IT'S LABELED AS
TREATED. IT'S, IT'S GOT THE, YOU
KNOW, CROSSBONES AND ALL THE
THINGS THAT YOU GOT TO HAVE TO
LET PEOPLE KNOW THAT THERE'S
SOMETHING IN HERE THAT COULD
HARM YOU. PROP 65, ALL THOSE
THINGS. ANYWAY. SO I JUST WANT
TO MAKE SURE WE'RE GETTING WE'RE
ON THE RIGHT PATH. I THINK WE'RE
THERE. I THINK WE'RE REALLY
CLOSE. IF I HAVE SOMETHING IN
STORAGE ALREADY, I WANT TO
OPPORTUNITY TO GET THAT THROUGH.
I THINK THE OPPOSITION BROUGHT
THAT UP AND THEN THE LABELING
STUFF. SO FOR THERE, FOR SO
HOPEFULLY BETWEEN NOW AND
APPROPRIATIONS, THOSE FEW 3 OR 4
ITEMS CAN BE WORKED OUT AND WE
CAN GET THERE. AND I THINK THIS
WILL BE A BILL I CAN SUPPORT ON
THE FLOOR AND MAYBE WOULD LIKE
TO PRESENT IT FOR YOU IF WE CAN
GET THERE. SO. WELL, I LOOK
FORWARD. I HAD MR. MATHIS SAY
THAT EARLY IN THE YEAR, AND HE'S
NOW A COAUTHOR ON MY BILL. SO I
WOULD LIKE TO GET THERE AS WELL.
AND I YOU KNOW, I THANK YOU AND
I WANT TO THANK MR. ALBIANI FOR,
YOU KNOW, HIS FEEDBACK. AND LIKE
I SAID,
EFFORT TO TRY TO GET TO A PLACE
WHERE WE COULD HAVE BOTH FARMERS
AS CONSUMERS. RIGHT? BECAUSE YOU
GROW SEEDS, BUT THEY'RE ALSO
FARMERS THAT BUY THESE THINGS.
AND ONE OF THE THINGS THAT I
THINK THIS ALSO, HELPS WITH IS
CONSUMER PROTECTION. IF YOU'RE
BUYING A SEED BECAUSE YOU DO
NEED IT TO BE TREATED TO DEAL
WITH THE FUNGUS, YOU ALSO DON'T
WANT IT TO BE DE MINIMIS, RIGHT?
YOU WANT TO KNOW YOU'RE GETTING
SOMETHING THAT ACTUALLY WILL
DEAL WITH THE PROBLEM AT HAND.
RIGHT? SO I THINK THERE ARE
PROTECTIONS FOR FARMERS IN HERE
AS WELL. AND SO I'M GLAD WE'RE
ALMOST THERE. WE THOUGHT 2027
WOULD ALLOW FOR THE SELL
THROUGH. IT SOUNDS LIKE IT'S NOT
THERE. BUT YOU SEE THAT WE DID
THAT IN ORDER TO ADDRESS THE
CONCERNS. SO WE'LL CONTINUE TO
HAVE THAT CONVERSATION. THIS IS
ONE LAST COMMENT I WANT TO SAY
THAT THIS IS AN ACTUAL SEED THAT
HAS A CODE ON IT PLANTED IN. I
MEAN, FOR THE ABILITY FOR THE
MOVEMENT OF THAT PESTICIDE IS,
IS, I THINK, A STRETCH IN MY, IN
MY MIND, I MEAN, I WHEN I GO OUT
TO MY FIELD AND LOOK AT, YOU
KNOW, IT'S VERY MINUTE AMOUNT
FOR REALLY TO GET IN THE WATER
SYSTEM. I MEAN, I THINK THERE'S
A LOT OF OTHER AREAS THAT WE
COULD FOCUS ON A LOT BETTER
WHERE WE'RE PUTTING WHERE
THERE'S PEOPLE PUTTING, YOU
KNOW, SPRAYING CHEMICALS ON THAT
ARE COVERING THE WHOLE
LANDSCAPE. THIS IS A SEED WITH A
VERY SMALL FILM ON IT THAT GETS
PLANTED IN SMALL, VERY SMALL
AMOUNTS. I COMMEND YOU ON YOUR
WORK, I KNOW YOU'LL BE ENGAGING
WITH THEM, AS WELL. OVER THE
COURSE OF THE SUMMER. WE DON'T
HAVE A QUORUM YET, BUT IF YOU
WANT TO CLOSE AND GIVE. YEAH,
YEAH. THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. AND
I'LL JUST SAY IN RESPONSE TO THE
WATER QUESTION, WHAT STARTED
THIS WAS ACTUALLY THE BEE
DECLINE, WHICH IS A PROBLEM FOR
CALIFORNIA'S FARMERS. WITHOUT
BEES, OUR OUR FOOD DOESN'T GET
POLLINATED. AND SO THEY'RE
TRUCKING IN BEES RIGHT NOW WHERE
THEY'RE LOSING BEES, WHICH IS
COSTLY. IT IS CAUSING RISE IN
FOOD COSTS. AND SO ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT REALLY IS A CONCERN
TO BE FRANK, MORE THAN THE
WATER, IS THE NEONICOTINOIDS.
AND THE GET INTO THE FLOWERS Dð
ARE IN THE PLANTS. STUDIES HAVE
SHOWN WHEN THEY'RE ON THE SEEDS
THAT IT CAN AFFECT THE BEES. AND
SO AGAIN, FARMERS, TO BE CLEAR,
ARE THE CALIFORNIANS THAT HAVE
BEEN MOST RESPONSIBLE ABOUT
NEONICOTINOIDS. I WANT TO BE
CLEAR ABOUT THAT BECAUSE THEY
UNDERSTAND THAT IF THEY LOSE
THEIR BEES, THEY LOSE THEIR
LIVELIHOOD. BUT THEY NEED THIS
TO BE RESPONSIBLE. SO I JUST
WANTED TO CLARIFY, THAT WAS ONE
OF THE CONCERNS THAT LED TO
THIS, SO WITH THAT, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE.
OKAY. WE'LL TAKE THAT UP WHEN WE
HAVE A QUORUM. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU, DENNIS. THANK YOU, ALL
RIGHT, NOW, NOW WE'LL. OKAY.
WELL, NOW WE HAD ANOTHER PERSON
WHO ASKED FOR A DIFFERENT ONE TO
GO NEXT. SO DO YOU MIND IF WE
TAKE UP 2214? SURE AS LONG AS NO
OBJECTION FROM THE NØ. OF
COURSE. THANK YOU. MR. THANK
YOU, SENATOR. YOU WERE GOING TO
DO 2085 FIRST. YES. NOW AND
THEN. MISS FEARING NEEDED TO GO
TO ANOTHER HEARING. ALL RIGHT.
WELL, I'M HERE, ALL RIGHT. VERY
COLORFUL BUTTERFLIES. WHAT. OH.
OH THERE YOU GO. OKAY. ON BRAND
TODAY. THAT'S RIGHT. OKAY, SO
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. AND
SENATORS, PROUD TO PRESENT AB
2214. THIS IS A JOINT EFFORT
WITH MY COLLEAGUE, ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MCKENNA, FOLLOWING THE
BILLS HEARING IN PREVIOUS
COMMITTEE. WE MADE AMENDMENTS TO
ADDRESS THE MAIN CONCERNS OF THE
STAKEHOLDERS, AND WE APPRECIATE
THEIR ENGAGEMENT ON THE ISSUE.
THIS BILL FOCUSES ON THE URGENT
AND PERVASIVE THREAT TO BOTH OUR
ENVIRONMENT AND OUR HEALTH. THAT
IS COMING IN THE WAY OF
MICROPLASTICS, THE TINY
PARTICLES STUBBORNLY RESIST
DECOMPENSATION HAVE BEEN FOUND
IN OUR NATURAL ENVIRONMENT AND
IN OUR BODIES. THEY'VE BEEN
DETECTED IN EVERYTHING FROM
BREAST MILK AND BABY FECES TO
RECENTLY, THE ARTICLES ON HUMAN
TESTICLES, A GLOBAL STUDY BY WWF
INTERNATIONAL FOUND THAT ON
AVERAGE, PEOPLE COULD BE
INGESTING THE EQUIVALENT OF A
CREDIT CARD, EVERY WEEK.
RECOGNIZING THE SEVERITY OF THE
SITUATION, THE OCEAN PROTECTION
COUNCIL DEVELOPED A STATE
MICROPLASTIC STRATEGY. THE
COMPREHENSIVE PLAN, PUBLISHED IN
EARLY 2022, OUTLINES 22
RECOMMENDATIONS AIMED AT
REDUCING AND MANAGING
MICROPLASTIC POLLUTIONS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA. THIS BILL BUILDS ON
THE INITIATIVE BY MANDATING THE
OPC TO LEAD AN INTER-AGENCY
COORDINATION GROUP TO IDENTIFY
AND RECOMMEND NECESSARY
STATUTORY CHANGES TO IMPLEMENT
THE RECOMMENDATIONS BY 2025. AND
THIS BILL REALLY STARTED BECAUSE
I DECIDED TO TAKE ON A PIECE OF
THE MICROPLASTICS PROBLEM LAST
YEAR. AND WHAT BECAME CLEAR TO
ME IN THAT EFFORT WAS THAT
BECAUSE MICROPLASTICS ARE IN SO
MANY DIFFERENT PRODUCTS AND SO
MANY DIFFERENT PLACES, THERE ARE
SO MANY AGENCIES THAT HAVE A
LITTLE PIECE OF THIS PUZZLE THAT
NOBODY IS ACTUALLY CHARGED WITH
SOLVING THIS PROBLEM. AND SO
THIS BILL REALLY IS TRYING TO
GET AT THAT PROBLEM OF
GOVERNMENT NOT BEING FOCUSED IN
THE RIGHT PLACE AND COORDINATING
IN THE WAY THAT THEY SHOULD BE.
AND SO THIS IS REALLY A GOOD
GOVERNMENT EFFORT. AND WITH ME
IN SUPPORT IS JENNIFER FEARING
WITH THE OCEAN CONSERVANCY AND
MONTEREY BAY AQUARIUM. GOOD
MORNING, MR. CHAIRMAN. MEMBERS.
INDEED, I AM JENNIFER FEARING ON
BEHALF OF THE OCEAN CONSERVANCY
AND MONTEREY BAY AQUARIUM, BUT
WE'RE PLEASED TO BE AMONG NEARLY
TWO DOZEN OTHER ORGANIZATIONS
URGING YOU TO VOTE AYE TO
LEVERAGE THE DIVERSE EXPERTISE
OF STATE AGENCY STAFF TO
COLLABORATIVELY ADDRESS THE
URGENT ISSUE OF MICROPLASTIC
POLLUTION. ABSENT URGENT
INTERVENTIONS, MICROPLASTICS
WILL CONTINUE TO POSE A THREAT
TO OUR ENVIRONMENT, WILDLIFE AND
PUBLIC HEALTH. MANY OF YOU
SUPPORTED WELL MANY OF YOU
SUPPORTED ASSEMBLYWOMAN
MCKENNA'S BILL LAST YEAR TO
IMPLEMENT A Kò MICROPLASTICS
PREVENTION RECOMMENDATION THAT
WAS INCLUDED IN THE
ADMINISTRATION'S STATEWIDE
MICROPLASTIC STRATEGY. AB 1628
WOULD HAVE REQUIRED WASHING
MACHINE MANUFACTURERS TO INCLUDE
FILTERS TO REDUCE UP TO 90% OF
THE MICROFIBRES RELEASED INTO
WASTEWATER AND THEN TO THE
ENVIRONMENT. UNFORTUNATELY,
GOVERNOR NEWSOM VETOED THAT
BILL, NOTING ONGOING WATER BOARD
ASSESSMENTS AND ASKING THE
AUTHOR TO DEVELOP INCENTIVES. WE
SUPPORT AB 2214 AS A WAY TO
ENROLL THE STATE'S AGENCY'S
EXPERTS IN THE DEVELOPMENT OF
WORKABLE AND PRACTICAL OPTIONS
TO ADDRESS THE CROSS-SECTORAL
ISSUE OF MICROPLASTIC POLLUTION
COMPREHENSIVELY. WE NEED
TEAMWORK. MICROPLASTIC POLLUTION
POSES A MULTIFACETED CHALLENGE
THAT DEMANDS COORDINATED ACTION
ACROSS SECTORS AND
JURISDICTIONS. BY BRINGING THE
STATE GOVERNMENT EXPERTS
TOGETHER TO IDENTIFY EXPLICIT
WAYS TO ADDRESS THE
PROLIFERATION OF MICROPLASTICS
IN OUR ENVIRONMENT, AB 2214
ENSURES CALIFORNIA'S LEADERSHIP
AT A GLOBAL LEVEL IN EFFECTIVELY
MANAGING AND MITIGATING THE
ADVERSE IMPACTS OF MICROPLASTIC
POLLUTION. WE URGE YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. SO OTHERS
WANT TO VOICE SUPPORT FOR THE
BILL? THIS IS AB 21 2214.
ISABELLA GONZALEZ, POTTER WITH
THE NATURE CONSERVANCY AND
SUPPORT CHRISTINE MARTINEZ WITH
CALIFORNIA AGAINST WASTE IN
SUPPORT. PRISCILLA IS HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA PRODUCT
STEWARDSHIP COUNCIL IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT, OPPOSITION
FOLKS WANT TO RAISE CONCERNS
ABOUT THE BILL. ANYONE HERE? ALL
RIGHT. SEEING NONE. WE'LL BRING
IT TO THE COMMITTEE. ANY
QUESTIONS FROM THE MEMBERS? I'M
A BIG FAN OF THIS BILL, WE WILL
MAKE SURE IF EITHER. YEAH, WE
DON'T HAVE A QUORUM YET, SO WE
CAN'T ENTERTAIN A VOTE, BUT
WE'LL CERTAINLY TAKE IT UP FOR A
MOTION AND I'LL BE ENCOURAGING,
ENTHUSIASTICALLY ENCOURAGING
FOLKS TO, TO PASS IT OUT. I'M
SURE WE'LL BE GOOD. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT. WE'LL MOVE
ON TO. LET'S GO ON TO, ITEM
NUMBER TWO. ANTICLIMACTIC. WHEN
YOU CAN'T TAKE A MOTION, I KNOW.
OKAY, WELL, YOU SHOULD HAVE
FOUND A WAY TO GET MICROPLASTIC
SEEDS IN THERE, AND WE WOULD
HAVE GOTTEN MORE QUESTIONS,
OKAY, WE'LL TAKE UP AB 2236, IF
THAT'S OKAY. SO MISS KAREN CAN
TAKE OFF. YOU JUST YOU LOVE.
YOU'RE ALL OUT OF ORDER, I LOVE
IT, I JUST KEEPING YOU ON YOUR
TOES, MISTER CHAIR. ALL RIGHT,
ALL RIGHT, ALL RIGHT. GOOD.
WE'RE ON ITEM FOUR NOW, THIS IS
ITEM 2236. GOOD AFTERNOON, GOOD
AFTERNOON. GOOD MORNING, MISTER
CHAIR AND SENATORS, AGAIN, I
WANT TO START BY THANKING THE
COMMITTEE STAFF ON THIS
THOUGHTFUL AND THOROUGH ANALYSIS
AND ACCEPTING COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS. WITH THAT, I'M PROUD
TO PRESENT AB 2236, A BILL IN
CONJUNCTION WITH SENATOR BLAKE
SPEARS, SB 1053, A DECADE AGO,
WE TRIED TO AND PROMISED
CALIFORNIANS WE WOULD ELIMINATE
PLASTIC BAGS, AND WE FAILED, WE
KNOW THAT BECAUSE WE SHOW UP
EVERY DAY TO GROCERY STORES
WHERE THICKER PLASTIC BAGS THAT
ARE MARKETED AS REUSABLE AND
RECYCLABLE ARE GIVEN TO
CALIFORNIANS. AND WE KNOW THAT
ISN'T HAPPENING. YOU KNOW, MY 14
YEAR OLD, WHEN HE HAD HIS BAR
MITZVAH, ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
HAPPENS IS YOU PICK A MITZVAH
PROJECT, YOU PICK SOMETHING
YOU'RE GOING TO DO TO CHANGE THE
WORLD FOR THE BETTER. AND OUR
SAFEWAY HAPPENS TO BE ON A
CREEK. AND HE HAD NOTICED IN HIS
NATURE EXPLORATION OF OUR
COMMUNITY THAT OUR CREEKS WERE
FULL OF PLASTIC BAGS BECAUSE
PEOPLE WOULD LEAVE THE GROCERY
STORE, THE BAGS WOULD END UP IN
THE CREEK BY THE GROCERY STORE
AND MOVE DOWN THE CREEK. AND HE
DID A CREEK CLEANUP FOR HIS
MITZVAH PROJECT TO REMOVE THOSE
PLASTIC BAGS. AND HE CONTINUES
TO DO THAT WORK TODAY. BUT WE
DECIDED TO TAKE IT A STEP
FURTHER AND THAT'S WHAT THIS
BILL IS, BECAUSE OUR KIDS SEE
IT, OUR KIDS NEED US TO DO
BETTER. PLASTIC IS PROLIFERATING
IN OUR ENVIRONMENT. IT IS
CAUSING THE MICROPLASTIC
PROBLEM. WE JUST TALKED ABOUT,
AND IT IS POLLUTING OUR
LANDFILLS AND CALIFORNIANS ARE
READY TO JUST TAKE PAPER, WHICH
IS WHAT THIS BILL DOES. IT
REMOVES THE PLASTIC BAGS AT THE
POINT OF SALE AND SAYS PAPER
ONLY PEOPLE WILL HAVE ACCESS TO
BAGS. THEY CAN BRING THEIR OWN
REUSABLE BAG, WHICH FOR ANYONE
WATCHING IS OBVIOUSLY PRIMARY
AND MOST IMPORTANT THING WE
SHOULD DO. BUT IF NOT, THEY HAVE
ACCESS TO THE PAPER BAGS JUST
LIKE THEY DO AT TRADER JOE'S
TODAY, AND IT WILL MAKE AN
INCREDIBLE DIFFERENCE FOR OUR
CLIMATE, OUR ENVIRONMENT AND
WITH ME TODAY IS JENNIFER
FEARING REPRESENTING THE OCEAN
CONSERVATORY, OCEANA AND
MONTEREY BAY AQUARIUM, AND LOUIS
BROWN WITH THE CALIFORNIA
GROCERS. GOOD MORNING, MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS, JENNIFER
FEARING FOR OCEAN CONSERVANCY,
OCEANA AND MONTEREY BAY
AQUARIUM. AND WE ARE AMONG OVER
75 ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION
ORGANIZATIONS AND DOZENS OF
LOCAL GOVERNMENT LEADERS ACROSS
THE STATE URGING YOU TO VOTE AYE
ON. AB 2236, THANK YOU TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR THE PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS THAT MAKE THE BILL
STRONGER AND THE INTENT, EVEN
CLEARER. WE MUST GET RID OF
SINGLE USE PLASTIC BAGS. OUR
FIGHT AGAINST SINGLE USE PLASTIC
CARRYOUT BAGS AT GROCERY AND
CONVENIENCE STORES IS NOW MORE
THAN TEN YEARS OLD. SB 272 HAS
ALLOWED THICKER PLASTIC BAG
FILMS TO BE USED UNDER THE GUISE
THAT THEY WERE REUSABLE. THIS
BILL CLEARLY ENDS THIS RUSE, AND
MAKES CLEAR THAT ONLY PAPER BAGS
MAY BE OFFERED BY GROCERS AT THE
POINT OF SALE. THE THICKER,
PROBLEMATIC PLASTIC BAGS
RESULTED FROM A RACE TO THE
BOTTOM. BASED ON THE REUSABLE
BAG STANDARD INCLUDED IN SB 270.
HAVING NOW MADE CLEAR THAT PAPER
IS THE ONLY AUTHORIZED BAG, THE
BILL'S PROVISIONS SETTING
STANDARDS FOR REUSABLE BAG NOW
RISK MUDDYING THE PRIMARY INTENT
OF THE BILL, AND EXPAND THE
SCOPE TO START DEFINING WHAT CAN
AND CAN'T BE SOLD AS A REUSABLE
BAG ANYWHERE IN THE STORE. SB
270 HAS ALWAYS BEEN ABOUT WHAT
BAGS ARE ALLOWED AT POINT OF
SALE, AND WE'RE PLEASED THE BILL
NOW DEFINES POINT OF SALE TO
COVER ALL TRANSACTIONS WHERE
PURCHASE GOODS MAY BE
TRANSFERRED TO A CUSTOMER, WHICH
IS WHY WE'RE SUPPORTIVE OF THE
PROPOSED COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS TO
REMOVE THE REUSABLE BAG
STANDARD. THANKS TO ALL OF YOU
WHO VOTED FOR SENATOR BLAKE
SPEERS, SB 1053 EARLIER THIS
YEAR, THAT COMPANION BILL PASSED
THE ASSEMBLY NATURAL RESOURCES
COMMITTEE ON MONDAY IN THE SAME
FORM PROPOSED HERE. WE WOULD
URGE YOUR SUPPORT FOR THIS
STRENGTHENED VERSION OF AB 2236.
THANK YOU, MR. BROWN. MR.
CHAIRMAN, MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE, LOUIS BROWN, HERE
TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA GROCERS ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL, ACTUALLY,
THIS EFFORT WITH PLASTIC BAGS
STARTED MORE THAN A DECADE AGO.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LLOYD LEVINE
ACTUALLY PASSED THE FIRST BILL
DEALING WITH PLASTIC BAGS. AND
AT THAT POINT, WHAT THAT BILL
CREATED WAS AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
THE MANUFACTURERS OF THE PLASTIC
BAGS TO PARTNER WITH THE GROCERY
INDUSTRY AND PROVIDE IN-STORE
TAKEBACK. THEY WERE TO PAY FOR
THE ADVERTISING THEY WERE TO PAY
FOR THE RECEPTACLES. THEY WERE
TO CREATE A SYSTEM WHERE GROCERY
GROCERS WOULD TAKE THOSE BAGS
BACK, AND THEN THEY WOULD BE PUT
BACK INTO THE RECYCLING SYSTEM.
THAT LAW SUNSETTED, FRANKLY,
BECAUSE IT WAS NEVER USED, THE
MANUFACTURERS NEVER CAME THROUGH
WITH THEIR COMMITMENT TO MAKE
THAT HAPPEN. AND SO WHEN SB 270
CAME AROUND, WE THEN JUMPED ON
TO SB 270 BECAUSE THAT STARTED
TO CLARIFY THE ISSUE. AND SO
HERE WE ARE TODAY. WE'RE HERE
TODAY SUPPORTING THE BILL THAT'S
NOW GOING TO TRANSITION TO TAKE
THE NEXT STEP TO JUST PAPER AT
THE POINT OF SALE. ONE OF THE
REASONS WE'RE HERE TODAY IS
WE'RE BEING SUED FOR THESE BAGS.
WE'VE GOT GROCERS THROUGHOUT
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA THAT ARE
FACING LAWSUITS BECAUSE THEY ARE
PROVIDING BAGS THAT STATE BRING
BACK TO YOUR STORE, STATE THAT
THEY ARE RECYCLABLE. AND IN
FACT, THE MANUFACTURERS CANNOT
PROVE THEY ARE RECYCLABLE. SO WE
ARE TAKING THE BRUNT OF THAT.
AND SO WHILE THIS IS GOING TO
MAKE A SIGNIFICANT CHANGE IN OUR
STORES, LIKELY INCREASE OUR
COSTS, WE ALSO SEE THAT THE
PUBLIC PERCEPTION, THE COST OF
LITIGATION AND EVERYTHING ELSE
COMBINED WOULD BE SIGNIFICANTLY
MORE THAN US MAKING THIS CHANGE.
SO WHO CONTINUES TO BENEFIT THE
CUSTOMERS ON WILK AND SNAP
CONTINUE TO BENEFIT. THEY'RE
GOING TO CONTINUE TO GET THESE
BAGS FOR FREE. AND OF THE
CUSTOMERS THAT COME THROUGH OUR
STORES STATEWIDE AVERAGE, 30% OF
OUR CUSTOMERS ARE ON WILK AND
SNAP. SO THE MANUFACTURERS ARE
GOING TO TELL YOU THAT THE
CHANGES IN THIS BILL ARE GOING
TO DRASTICALLY INCREASE PLASTIC.
I THINK THAT'S ILLOGICAL. AND
THEY OBVIOUSLY DON'T UNDERSTAND
THE GROCERY BUSINESS. PROBABLY
10% OF OUR OUR CUSTOMERS COME
THROUGH THE STORE PROBABLY LIKE
YOU, SENATOR ALLEN, WITH YOUR
REUSABLE BAG READY TO GO, 30% OF
OUR CUSTOMERS GET THEIR BAGS FOR
FREE, SO THEY'RE NOT EVEN
THINKING ABOUT BRINGING REUSABLE
BAGS IN THE REMAINDER. FORGET
THEIR BAGS IN THEIR TRUNK. DON'T
BRING THEM IN, AND DON'T EVEN
THINK ABOUT A BAG UNTIL THEY GET
TO THE CHECKOUT. WHEN THEY GET
TO THE CHECKOUT WITH THIS BILL,
THE ONLY THING THAT WILL BE
AVAILABLE WILL BE PAPER. SO WHAT
WE'LL SEE IS AN INCREASE IN THE
PAPER CONSUMPTION OR THE
CONSUMPTION OF PAPER BAGS. THEY
WILL NOT HAVE THE CHOICE TO USE
PLASTIC. SO WITH NO PLASTIC AS A
CHOICE, HOW IS THE PLASTIC USE
GOING TO GO UP? WE HAVE STORES
RIGHT NOW THAT PROVIDE ONLY
PLASTIC. THEY'RE GOING TO
TRANSITION TO PAPER. MOST OF OUR
STORES HAVE SIGNIFICANT MAJORITY
OF THEIR BAGS ARE PLASTIC. GOING
TO TRANSITION TO PAPER. SO THE
ARGUMENT THAT WE'RE GOING TO SEE
PLASTIC CONSUMPTION RESULT, OR
INCREASE AS A RESULT OF US
PROVIDING ONLY PAPER AT THE
CHECKOUT STAND, MAKES NO SENSE
AT ALL. WITH THAT, WE ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT.
OTHER FOLKS WHO WANT TO VOICE
THEIR SUPPORT FOR THE BILL. JUST
COME TO THE MICROPHONE AND STATE
YOUR NAME AND AFFILIATION. STEVE
BLACKLEDGE, ENVIRONMENT
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. GOOD
MORNING. DYLAN STAPLETON, ON
BEHALF OF LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR
ELENI KOUNALAKIS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING, ALYSSA
SALEHI, ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
CARLSBAD IN SUPPORT. THANKS GOOD
MORNING, LINDSEY GOLDWATER. THE
CAPITOL ADVOCACY ON BEHALF OF
THE RESOURCE RECOVERY COALITION
OF CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. GOOD
MORNING, KAYLA ROBINSON, ON
BEHALF OF BREAST CANCER
PREVENTION PARTNERS AND SUPPORT.
THANKS FOR SALE. KUDOS HERE ON
BEHALF OF SEVERAL CLIENTS, STOP
WASTE CALIFORNIA PRODUCT
STEWARDSHIP COUNCIL, RESTAURANT
BLAKESPEAR WASTE MANAGEMENT
AUTHORITY, SOLID WASTE
ASSOCIATION OF NORTH AMERICA,
AMERICAN LEGISLATIVE TASK FORCE,
THE CITIES OF SANTA MONICA,
BEVERLY HILLS, AND GOLETA IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU, GAVIN MCCUE
ON BEHALF OF INTERNATIONAL
PAPER, WE ARE IN SUPPORT. GOOD
MORNING, CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
ROMAN VOGELSANG WITH THE PREY
AND COMPANY ON BEHALF OF
REPUBLIC SERVICES AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON OR
GOOD MORNING, MISTER CHAIR AND
SENATORS ROSANNA CARVACHO ELLIOT
HERE, ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
ALAMEDA IN SUPPORT. GOOD
MORNING. JACOB EVANS WITH SIERRA
CLUB CALIFORNIA, IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. REBECCA MARCUS,
REPRESENTING CALPIRG IN SUPPORT.
SHERRIE PEMBERTON REPRESENTING
THE CALIFORNIA STATE LANDS
COMMISSION AND SUPPORT MARK èC
ON BEHALF OF THE COUNTY OF LOS
ANGELES. AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
OKAY, FOLKS WHO WANT TO RAISE
CONCERNS ABOUT THE BILL, OUR
OPPOSITION. I'LL GIVE YOU MY
CHAIR. HERE WE GO. DENNIS, FIX
THE MIC. THE BOLIVIAN PHENOM
ALBERTO TORRICO. AND I WILL SAY
BOLIVIA DID ITS PART IN THE
COPA. TOLD YOU. I TOLD YOU IT
WAS FULL HEARTED TO DEPEND ON
BOLIVIA'S SOCCER TEAM. WELL,
MISTER CHAIRMAN, BUT THANK YOU
NONETHELESS. GOOD MORNING,
ALBERTO TORRICO, I'M BESIDE. ON
BEHALF OF THE UNITED FOOD AND
COMMERCIAL WORKERS, WESTERN
STATES COUNCIL, WANT TO BEGIN BY
SAYING THAT UFCW C¯, SHARES THE
LAUDABLE OBJECTIVES OF THE BILL,
AS YOU DO, SENATOR ALAN, TO
REDUCE THE AMOUNT OF PLASTIC IN
THE ENVIRONMENT OF COURSE, LAST
YEAR, SENATOR ALAN, YOU CARRIED
SB 777, WHICH YOU SPONSORED
BECAUSE WE BELIEVED THEN AND
BELIEVE NOW THAT THERE ARE SOME
SIGNIFICANT PROBLEMS WITH THE
WAY THE STATUTE IS CONSTITUTED
AND IMPLEMENTED AND ENFORCED,
AND THOSE PROBLEMS ARE BEING
BROUGHT OVER TO THIS BILL, I
THINK THAT THIS BILL, BEGINS TO
DEAL WITH THE CHALLENGES, BUT WE
THINK A HOLISTIC APPROACH IS
NECESSARY. AND SO, REGRETTABLY,
WE OPPOSE THE CURRENT STATUTE
HAS THREE DIFFERENT ALLOWED
PURPOSES FOR THE MONEY THAT'S
REQUIRED TO THE USE TO THE
SELLING OF PAPER, OF PLASTIC
BAGS AT THE REGISTER. COMPLIANCE
WITH THE STATUTE TO COVER THE
COSTS OF THE BAGS THEMSELVES AND
TO EDUCATE THE PUBLIC ON THE
NEED AND THE ABILITY AND THE
AVAILABILITY OF RECYCLING. WE
DON'T THINK THOSE THINGS ARE
HAPPENING, AND WE DON'T THINK
THOSE THINGS ARE GOING TO HAPPEN
WHEN WE TRANSITION OVER TO PAPER
BAGS. THE OTHER THING THAT WE'RE
CONCERNED ABOUT, AND THE REASON
WE BROUGHT THE BILL LAST YEAR,
WAS WE'VE HAD AN ONGOING DISPUTE
WITH THE GROCERS REGARDING THE
PROFITABILITY OF THE PLASTIC
BAGS. WE THINK THERE'S A LOT OF
MONEY THAT'S BEING MADE. WE
THINK THE BAGS ARE BEING SOLD TO
THEM FOR 2 OR $0.03, AND THEN
THEY'RE BEING SOLD AT A MINIMUM
OF $0.10. SOME JURISDICTIONS
$0.25. SO BECAUSE OF THOSE
THINGS, WE INTRODUCED THE BILL
TO BRING TRANSPARENCY AND TO
ACCOUNTABILITY AND REPORTING OF
THE NUMBER OF BAGS PURCHASED BY
THE STORES AND THE NUMBER OF
BAGS SOLD, WE FOUND A SUBSEQUENT
TO YOUR BILL. WE FOUND A STUDY
IN NEW JERSEY THAT ONE SINGLE
STORE IN NEW JERSEY CAN PROFIT
UP TO $200,000 A YEAR, AND THAT
THE ENTIRE INDUSTRY IS GETTING
$42 MILLION JUST FROM THE SALE
OF BAGS. SO WE HAVE URGED THE
AUTHORS TO INCLUDE SOME OF THE
PROVISIONS FROM YOUR BILL. AND
WE'VE ALSO IF THOSE WERE NOT
ACCEPTABLE, WE THINK THAT LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS HAVE THE ABILITY
TO COLLECT THIS INFORMATION AND
TRACK IT. THEY'RE PREEMPTED FROM
DOING THAT NOW BECAUSE THOSE ARE
THE PROVISIONS THAT ARE BEING
BROUGHT OVER. THE LAST THING
THAT I WILL SAY IS THAT THE
$0.10 IS A MINIMUM. WE THINK
IT'S INEVITABLE THAT THE PRICE
OF BAGS WILL GO UP, THAT PEOPLE
WILL PAY MORE THAN $0.10 PER BAG
FOR PAPER BAGS, AND THAT THAT
THAT HAS A REALLY DISPARATE
IMPACT ON PEOPLE FROM
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES. YOU
KNOW, FOR THOSE OF US THAT ARE
OLD ENOUGH, WE REMEMBER WE USED
TO MAYBE WE WORKED IN THE
GROCERY STORE. WE BAGGED OR WE
BAGGED. WE CARRIED GROCERIES FOR
OUR PARENTS. A LOT OF TIMES YOU
NEED DOUBLE BAGS. AND BECAUSE
WHEN IT'S PAPER, SO THERE'S AN
INCREASED COST, WE THINK THAT'S
THAT'S UNFAIR TO HAVE THAT
POPULATION BEAR THAT BURDEN. AND
THE LAST THING I WILL SAY, AS
MENTIONED EARLIER BY MR. BROWN,
WHICH IS THE WITH CUSTOMERS
UNDER THE CURRENT STATUTE, THE
CASHIER IS NOT ALLOWED TO ASK IF
A PERSON IS PAYING WITH WILK. SO
YOU CAN GET THROUGH THE WHOLE
TRANSACTION AND THEY CAN BILL,
THEY CAN BE BILLED FOR THE PAPER
BAGS. MAYBE THE STATE'S PAYING
FOR THAT THROUGH THE WICK CARDS.
THE CUSTOMER OFTENTIMES IS
RETICENT TO SAY THEY'RE A WICK
CUSTOMER. SO THERE'S ALL I THINK
THERE'S ALL SORTS. SO THERE ARE
THERE ARE THINGS THAT NEED TO BE
IMPROVED UPON. AND WE WISH WE
WOULD HOPE THAT THEY WOULD BE
DONE IN THIS BILL. SO WITH THAT,
WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A NO
VOTE, SIR. THANK YOU. OKAY. WITH
YOUR INDULGENCE, I'D JUST LIKE
TO ESTABLISH A QUORUM.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATORS ALLEN HERE. ALLEN HERE.
DALLY HERE. DALLY HERE.
GONZALEZ. HURTADO HERE. HURTADO,
HERE. MENGIBAR. NGUYEN NGUYEN.
HERE. SKINNER SHE'S BEEN HERE.
YEAH. THANK YOU. I APPRECIATE
YOUR PATIENCE. YEAH. NO PROBLEM.
SIR, CHAIR AND ESTEEMED MEMBERS
OF ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY
COMMITTEE, THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TO YOU
TODAY. MY NAME IS PHIL ROSINSKI,
AND I'M A MEMBER. I'M
REPRESENTING A MEMBER COMPANY OF
THE AMERICAN RECYCLABLE PLASTIC
BAG ALLIANCE, AND WE ARE HERE
TODAY REGARDING ASSEMBLY BILL
2236. THE RPA REPRESENTS
MANUFACTURERS AND RECYCLERS OF
PLASTIC RETAIL BAGS, INCLUDING
MEMBERS WITH OPERATIONS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. WE SHARE THE BILL'S
STATED GOAL OF PROTECTING THE
ENVIRONMENT. BUT THIS BILL WILL
NOT REDUCE PLASTIC. I KNOW IT'S
BEEN SAID THAT I WOULD SAY THAT,
BUT THE REALITY IS WE'VE SEEN
THIS DEVELOPED IN OTHER STATES
AND ACTUALLY TENDS TO CREATE
INCREASED USE OF PLASTIC. THE
CURRENT LAW REQUIRES PLASTIC
BAGS USED TO REUSABLE BAGS USED
TODAY TO CONTAIN 40% CERTIFIED
POST-CONSUMER RECYCLED CONTENT.
THIS BILL ENCOURAGES OTHER TYPES
OF PLASTIC REUSABLE BAGS THAT
DON'T HAVE RECYCLED CONTENT AND
ARE NOT RECYCLABLE. IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. WITH THAT, AS
THESE BAGS HAVE BECOME MORE
PROLIFIC, THEY'VE DROPPED IN
PRICE. SO WE SEE THEM SOLD
CHEAPER AND CHEAPER AND MORE
FREQUENTLY, AND USE LESS AND
LESS AND THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
SEEING IN STUDIES ACROSS THE
COUNTRY AND JURISDICTIONS THAT
HAVE DONE THIS IN CANADA, NEW
YORK, NEW JERSEY, DELAWARE. THIS
BAG BASICALLY SUBSTITUTES ONE
PLASTIC WITH ANOTHER THAT ISN'T
RECYCLABLE. I UNDERSTAND THE
RECENT RECENT AMENDMENTS SOUGHT
TO MITIGATE THAT BY MOVING THE
BAGS AWAY FROM THE CHECKOUT
COUNTER AND SAYING THAT ONLY
PAPER CAN BE OFFERED. BUT WHEN
YOU READ THE BILL, THEY JUST
CAN'T BE AT THE CHECKOUT
COUNTER. BASICALLY, IF THESE
DESKS WERE CHECKOUT COUNTERS,
YOU WOULD NO LONGER HAVE THEM ON
THE BACK SIDE. YOU WOULD MOVE
THEM TWO FEET AWAY TO THE OTHER
SO THEY CAN STILL SELL THEM. IT
JUST RESTRICTS THEM FROM
CONTAINING THEM AT THE AT THE
CHECKOUT COUNTER. IT DOESN'T
MANDATE THE STORAGE. USE PAPER
BAGS. IT'S AN OPTION. AND SO BY
NOT OFFERING PAPER WHICH MOST
STORES DO, THEY'LL FORCE PEOPLE
TO BUY THESE BAGS WHICH ARE NOT
RECYCLABLE. ACCORDING TO MEDIA
REPORTS, IN 2010, MANY REUSABLE
BAGS USED TO HAVE HIGH LEVELS OF
TOXIC HEAVY METALS IN THEM. THIS
LED CALIFORNIA TO INCLUDE
PROVISIONS THAT REQUIRE THE
TESTING AND REGISTRATION UNDER
THE CURRENT LAW, AND THAT IS
BEING DELETED. WE WOULD ASK AND
ASK WHY INSTEAD ARE WE JUST
ASKING FOR THEM TO HAVE AN HONOR
SYSTEM FOR THESE OTHER BAGS,
WHICH ARE MADE OVERSEAS,
PRIMARILY IN CHINA, AND HAVE A
HISTORY OF A BAD TRACK RECORD
WITH TOXINS? WHY IS THAT
PROVISION BEING REMOVED FROM THE
BILL? IF THERE WERE NO PLASTIC
BAGS, WHY IS IT BEING OUR
PLASTIC BAGS? WHY WOULD YOU EVEN
NEED TO REMOVE IT EVERY
LEGISLATURA? MAKE NO MISTAKE,
THE BILL WILL STILL ALLOW FOR
THE USE OF PLASTIC BAGS. THEY
WILL BE CHEAPER AND THEY WILL
INCREASE IN SALES AND THEY WILL
DECREASE IN REUSE. THIS
AMENDMENTS LED ITS AUTHORS AND
THE GROCERS AND OTHER PROPONENTS
TO SAY IT BANNED THE USE OF
PLASTIC BAGS AT THE POINT OF
SALE, BUT IN REALITY, IT SIMPLY
MOVES THEM TWO FEET AWAY, MAKES
THEM OF A DIFFERENT MATERIAL,
AND SACRIFICES CONSUMER SAFETY
IN THE PROCESS. WE ARE OPPOSED
TO THIS BILL. WE WOULD LIKE TO
SEE OTHER SOLUTIONS. WE DO
UNDERSTAND. PRODUCER
RESPONSIBILITY IS A GREAT
OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO IMPROVE
RECYCLABILITY AND BUILD A
SYSTEM. WE'D LIKE TO SEE OTHER
ALTERNATIVES TO SOLVE THESE
PROBLEMS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT.
OTHER FOLKS WHO WANT TO RAISE
CONCERNS ABOUT THE BILL OR
EXPRESS OPPOSITION CAN COME TO
THE MIC. HI, RYAN. ELAINE, ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
RETAILERS ASSOCIATION, WE'RE
OFFICIALLY OPPOSED ON THE
ANALYSIS, BUT WITH THE RECENT
AMENDS, WE'RE ENCOURAGED AND
WE'RE GOING TO RECONSIDER OUR
POSITION. THANK YOU. I LIKE THAT
NEW THAT'S A NEW THING
ENCOURAGED. ENCOURAGED AS
AMENDED. ALL RIGHT. DYLAN
FINLEY, ON BEHALF OF THE WESTERN
PLASTICS ASSOCIATION, THE
ASSOCIATION OF PLASTIC RECYCLERS
AND THE RECYCLING PARTNERSHIP,
OPPOSED, UNLESS AMENDED, TO
PLACE THE BAGS UNDER THE
REGULATIONS OF SB 54. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING, JOHN MOFFATT, ON
BEHALF OF METTLER PACKAGING WITH
THE. WE HAVE AN OPPOSING, LESS
AMENDED POSITION WITH THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS GOING INTO
THE BILL, WE'LL BE REMOVING OUR
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. MY NAME
IS MIKE POLSKY. I'M PRESIDENT OF
PRO CORE PRODUCTS INTERNATIONAL.
I AM AN IMPORTER AND SELLER OF
ALL BAGS, COTTON, POLYPROPYLENE,
PAPER, PLASTIC. I SUPPORTED THE
BILL. I AM NOW OPPOSED UNLESS
AMENDED, AND I GUESS IF ONE
WOULD ASK WHY AM I CHANGING MY
POSITION? THE ANSWER IS GUILT. I
WON'T MAKE A LOT. I SELL MORE
PAPER THAN ANY OTHER PRODUCT. I
MAKE MORE MONEY ON PAPER. BUT WE
TALK ABOUT OUR CHILDREN. WE ARE
MOVING AWAY FROM REDUCE, REUSE,
RECYCLE. WHEN I GO SHOPPING, MY
EIGHT BAGS ARE ON MY BODY. NOW
I'M GOING TO HAVE TO CARRY EIGHT
BAGS IF I CHOOSE TO DO THAT. SO
I ALSO OPEN THE FIRST
POST-CONSUMER PLASTIC RECYCLING
COMPANY. THIS IS LIKE A I OKAY,
I UNDERSTAND IT. I'M AVAILABLE
IF. THANK YOU I APPRECIATE IT.
SOMETIMES IT'S A CHALLENGE ON
THE OPPOSITION SIDE BECAUSE YOU
HAVE A LOT OF DIFFERENT VOICES.
SO I APPRECIATE YOUR PERSPECTIVE
AND THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
OKAY. LET'S BRING IT TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS AND
COMMENTS. BUT BEFORE WE DO THAT,
I WANTED TO JUST I, WE DID WANT
TO, HAVE YOU VERBALLY ASSERT
THAT YOU'RE ACCEPTING THE Ó.
YES, MISTER CHAIR. GREAT, VICE
CHAIR. DALI SO I I'M SO GLAD I
GOT TO GET TO THIS BILL. YEAH.
WHO'S STILL HERE IN SPITE OF
THE. AND I'M THE SEED. BILL. AND
WICKS IS ON HER FIRST BILL OVER
THERE. AND I GOT TO HER SECOND
BILL. THIS IS AWESOME BECAUSE I
DID WANT TO COMMENT ON THIS
BILL. SO I'M GOING TO GIVE YOU
MY PERSPECTIVE OF THE HISTORY OF
THE BAG SINCE I'VE BEEN HERE,
YOU KNOW, THEY TRIED TO BAN IT.
THEY TOOK IT TO THEY GATHERED
SIGNATURES. THE WHOLE STORY OF
THE BAGS HAS BEEN GOING ON FOR
THE 12 YEARS I'VE BEEN HERE, BUT
I. BUT THE LAST ITERATION OF THE
BAG WAS, WE'RE GOING TO CHARGE
FOR THE BAG. AND SO IF WE CHARGE
FOR THE BAG AT THE POINT OF AT
THE POINT OF SALE, IT WAS REALLY
FRUSTRATING TO ME THAT THE
ENVIRONMENTAL COMMUNITY STOOD UP
AND SAID, YEAH, IT DIDN'T DO
ANYTHING TO REDUCE THE USE OF
THE BAG, WHICH WE TALK ABOUT ALL
IT DID WAS CHARGE THE CUSTOMER
OF THE BAG AND WHO PROFITED WAS
THE RETAILER GOT TO KEEP THE
$0.10. THE BAGS ARE $0.02, THEY
GOT THE $0.08. AND WHO WHO PAID
FOR IT? WE DIDN'T. WE DIDN'T. WE
DIDN'T TAKE THAT MONEY AND DO
ANYTHING FOR THE ENVIRONMENT. WE
DIDN'T CLEAN ANY BAGS UP. AND SO
THAT WAS REALLY FRUSTRATING. SO
I VOTED AGAINST THAT BILL
BECAUSE I ACTUALLY IF WE'RE
GOING TO DO SOMETHING, WE'RE
GOING TO CHARGE AND WE'RE GOING
TO FIX THE ENVIRONMENT. WE NEED
TO GET THE BAGS OFF THE STREET,
WHICH WE ALL CARE ABOUT. SO FAST
FORWARD TO WHERE WE ARE TODAY,
AND HERE WE ARE ONCE AGAIN.
WE'RE GOING TO SAY WE'RE GOING
TO DO AWAY WITH THE WITH THE
PLASTIC BAG AT THE POINT OF SALE.
AND WE'RE GOING TO EXACTLY WHAT
THE OPPOSITION SAID. THEY'RE
GOING TO MOVE IT. IT'S STILL
GOING TO BE CHEAPER. IT MAY BE
CHEAPER THAN THE PAPER BAG. AND
I, I SHOP AT TRADER JOE'S. IT'S
THREE BLOCKS FROM MY HOUSE AND I
ONLY HAVE THE OPTION OF PAPER
THERE, WHICH IS GREAT, BUT I GO
HOME WITH FOUR BAGS IF I GET TWO
TWO BAGS FULL BECAUSE THEY
DOUBLE LINE EVERY ONE OF THEM AT
TRADER JOE'S. AT LEAST THEY DID
YESTERDAY WHEN I WAS THERE. SO
WHAT ARE WE REALLY DOING AT THE
END OF THE DAY? I JUST WANT TO
SAY WE'RE JUST MOVING IT AROUND
AND WE'RE REALLY NOT GOING TO
SOLVE OUR PROBLEM BECAUSE THE
CUSTOMER THAT IS THE LOW INCOME
PERSON THAT CAN'T AFFORD IS
GOING TO TRY TO TAKE THE CHEAPER
OPTION. THAT'S WHAT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN. THEY'RE GOING TO THEY'RE
GOING TO USE THE PLASTIC BAG IN
FRONT IF IT'S CHEAPER. AND
THAT'S THAT'S RIGHT. SO FOR ME
IT'S LIKE, WHAT ARE WE DOING
HERE? ARE WE REALLY SAVING THE
ENVIRONMENT OR ARE WE JUST
PLAYING GAMES WITH THE
MANUFACTURERS OF TWO DIFFERENT
PRODUCTS? I LOVE PAPER, I HAVE A
FOREST FULL OF WOOD I NEED TO
GET RID OF BECAUSE IT'S BURNING
DOWN EVERY DAY. I LOVE PAPER, I
ALWAYS CHOOSE PAPER WHEN I CAN,
BUT OCCASIONALLY I USE THE
PLASTIC ONE BECAUSE I USE THOSE
TO LINE THE LITTLE CANS THAT ARE
IN MY BATHROOM. SO I JUST CAN
WAD THAT STUFF UP AND THROW IT
IN THE RECYCLE BIN. SO FOR ME,
I'M GOING TO BE OPPOSED TO YOUR
BILL. I JUST WANT TO LAY THAT
OUT. I HAVE TO GO TO ANOTHER
COMMITTEE. AND SO I WOULD LOVE
TO HEAR YOUR RESPONSE TO SOME OF
MY QUESTIONS. IF I HAVE TIME
HERE OR MY COMMENTS. FIRST OF
ALL, YOU WANT YOUR CANS WITH
PLASTIC BAGS. YEAH, I LIKE SO
THE LITTLE PLASTIC BAG THAT YOU
GET IN THE STORE, I PUT IT
INSIDE OF THE YOU LINE THE TRASH
CAN IN THE BATHROOM. YEAH. OKAY.
YEAH OKAY. AND I THROW IT IN
THERE AND THEN I DON'T HAVE TO,
LIKE, CLEAN MY CAN I DO THAT
TOO? OKAY. ALL RIGHT, LET'S,
LET'S, THEN I RECYCLE IT. ALL
RIGHT. GOOD, GOOD GOOD GOOD.
WELL, I FOR CHRISTMAS AND
HANUKKAH, RESPECTIVELY. I WILL
GET YOU BOTH COMPOSTABLE.
BATHROOM BAGS, WHICH IS WHAT I
USE, BUT, NO, I APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMENTS, MR. SENATOR JOLLY AND
I DON'T FEIGN TO KNOW IF I
ALWAYS HAVE THE ANSWERS. YOU'VE
KNOWN ME FOR MANY YEARS, AND I'M
THE FIRST TO ADMIT THAT I DON'T
KNOW IF I'M GETTING IT RIGHT,
BUT I'M DOING MY BEST. AND I DO
KNOW THAT RIGHT NOW, WHEN I SHOW
UP AT. NOT TRADER JOE'S, BUT THE
OTHER MARKET, I SHOP AT, OFTEN
THERE ISN'T PAPER AT THE POINT
OF SALE. YOU PROBABLY HAVE THAT
EXPERIENCE TOO. THERE'S SOME
GROCERY STORES WHERE THE ONLY
OPTION IS PLASTIC RIGHT NOW, AND
FOR ME, I DO BRING IN MY
RECYCLED BAGS, BUT. OR MY
REUSABLE BAGS. BUT I NOTICE THAT
AND I THINK THAT, YOU KNOW,
WE'VE INCREASED THE RECYCLED
CONTENT IN THIS TO MAKE THOSE
MORE RECYCLABLE, NOT 100. SO
YOUR TREES WILL STILL BE
UTILIZED, BUT, YOU KNOW, I DO
THINK WE'RE TRYING OUR BEST TO
GET THIS RIGHT. AND IF YOU HAVE
BETTER SOLUTIONS TO TRY TO
REDUCE THE AMOUNT OF PLASTIC IN
OUR WATERWAYS, I INVITE THAT.
AND I WOULD HAPPILY SUPPORT IT.
AND I JUST WILL POINT OUT THAT I
DON'T THINK THE PEOPLE WHO MAKE
THE PLASTIC BAGS WOULD BE HERE
IN OPPOSITION IF THIS WERE GOING
TO CREATE MORE PLASTIC. ANY MORE
OTHER QUESTIONS? OKAY, ANY
QUESTIONS? YEAH. YOU SURE THE
OTHER CHINA, THOSE CHINESE
MANUFACTURERS, THE ALTERNATE
BAGS ARE NOT HERE. WE ARE
REPRESENTING THE BAGS. THAT
WOULD BE REPLACED AND ARE MADE
HERE IN CALIFORNIA. AMERICA. SO
I JUST WOULD LIKE A POINT OF
ORDER ABOUT CHARACTERIZATION OF
WHAT WE REPRESENT. OKAY, I
APPRECIATE THAT. THANK YOU.
OKAY. WELL, OBVIOUSLY WE HEARD
WE HEARD THIS BILL IN THE, THE
BLAKESBERG FORM, EARLIER AND I
THINK YOU CAME AND TESTIFIED
THERE TOO AT THE. OKAY. ALL
RIGHT, YOU KNOW, ANYHOW, ANY
INTEREST IN EMOTION FROM. YEAH.
OKAY. SO WE'VE GOT A MOTION FROM
SENATOR HURTADO, LOOKING FORWARD
TO FURTHER DISCUSSIONS. I KNOW
THAT YOU'LL BE DISCUSSING THE
ISSUES THAT HAVE BEEN RAISED
DURING THE RECESS. OBVIOUSLY WE
TRIED, YOU KNOW, LAST YEAR WITH
WITH OUR BILL AND
UNSUCCESSFULLY. BUT BUT A LOT
THERE'S MUCH IN THIS BILL WHICH
RELATES TO THE ISSUES WE'RE
TRYING TO ADDRESS THERE, THOUGH
NOT ALL LOVE TO GIVE THE AUTHOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO CLOSE. I JUST
WANT TO CLOSE REALLY BY THANKING
THE CHAIR FOR HIS LEADERSHIP IN
THIS SPACE. I THINK A LOT OF HIS
WORK HAS BEEN HIGHLIGHTED TODAY,
WHETHER IT WAS, YOU KNOW, HIS
COMPREHENSIVE LOOK AT PLASTICS
OR THE BILL THAT, UFC BROUGHT
FORWARD. AND I THINK THAT THAT
WORK HAS REALLY LAID THE
GROUNDWORK FOR CONTINUING TO
MOVE FORWARD. AND I DON'T KNOW
IF THIS WILL BE THE PERFECT
SOLUTION. AND I TRUST THAT THE
PEOPLE WHO COME AFTER US MAY
HAVE TO CONTINUE THIS EFFORT.
BUT WITH THAT, I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT, SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. SENATOR Ó, THE
MOTION ON THIS BILL IS DO PASS,
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
SENATORS ALLEN, I. ALLEN I DALI.
NO. DALI. NO GONZALEZ. HURTADO
HURTADO I MENGIBAR. NGUYEN.
SKINNER ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU.
WE'LL KEEP THAT ROLL UP AND
THANK YOU. AND THANK YOU,
EVERYONE FOR PARTICIPATING ON
BOTH SIDES. AND, LOOKING FORWARD
TO FURTHER DISCUSSIONS. ALL
RIGHT. FINALLY SAVING THE BEST.
YEAH. OKAY. NOW WE'RE GOING TO
GO TO AB 2085 BY SENATOR, YOU
SURE YOU DON'T WANT TO STAY FOR
THIS ONE, BRIAN? OH, MAYBE I
SHOULD. NO. OKAY. MAYBE I SHOULD
SAY GOOD AFTERNOON. IS IT
AFTERNOON YET. GOOD AFTERNOON.
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. AND
SENATORS, ALL AGAIN EXCEPT THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS ON AB 2085.
AND THIS IS A REALLY SIMPLE
BILL. ABOUT A YEAR AGO, I WAS
SITTING WITH ONE OF THE FOLKS
THAT WORKS AT OUR PLANNED
PARENTHOOD'S, LISTENING TO WHAT
SHE DID EVERY DAY AND LISTENING
TO THE FIGHTS SHE WAS WAGING
ACROSS CALIFORNIA TO TRY TO OPEN
HEALTH CLINICS IN COMMUNITIES
THAT WERE HOSTILE TO ABORTION
ACCESS. AND ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT, YOU KNOW, WE ALL KNOW IN
THIS ROOM IS WHEN A PLANNED
PARENTHOOD OPENS IN COMMUNITIES
WHERE THERE IS NOT ENOUGH HEALTH
CARE, THEY PROVIDE CRITICAL
FRONT LINE HEALTH CARE TO THOSE
COMMUNITIES IN THE FORM OF
PRENATAL CARE AND STD
TREATMENTS. AND OTHER CRITICAL,
CRITICAL HEALTH CARE NEEDS IN IN
ADDITION TO ABORTION CARE, WHICH
IS AN IMPORTANT ASPECT OF WHAT
OUR CLINICS DO ACROSS
CALIFORNIA. AND SO WE STARTED TO
REALIZE THAT REALLY THE NEXT
THING WE NEEDED TO DO AS A STATE
THAT GUARANTEES ACCESS TO
COMPREHENSIVE HEALTH CARE,
INCLUDING ABORTION, WAS MAKE
SURE THAT LOCAL COMMUNITIES WERE
NOT BLOCKING THIS ACCESS TO
HEALTH CARE. AND THAT'S WHAT
THIS BILL DOES. IT IS A SIMPLE
STREAMLINING BILL THAT WILL
ENSURE THAT WHERE CITIES AND
COUNTIES HAVE ZONED
APPROPRIATELY FOR HEALTH CARE,
CLINICS, THAT THEY CANNOT BLOCK
THE CONSTRUCTION OF THE CLINICS
THROUGH BAD FAITH REQUIREMENTS
AND UNNECESSARY REGULATORY
HURDLES. IT REQUIRES MINISTERIAL
APPROVAL OF CLINICS THAT MEET
ALL OF THE LOCALITY STANDARDS.
ENDING THESE ARBITRARY
OBSTRUCTIONS OF LIFE SAVING
CARE. WITH ME TODAY IS MOLLY
ROBINSON FROM PLANNED PARENTHOOD
OF CALIFORNIA. MUCH ANTICIPATED
NØ. THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING.
MOLLY ROBSON, VICE PRESIDENT OF
GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS WITH PLANNED
PARENTHOOD AFFILIATES OF
CALIFORNIA, WHERE WE REPRESENT
THE SEVEN AFFILIATES IN THE
STATE WHO OPERATE OVER 110
HEALTH CENTERS AND PROVIDE
SEXUAL AND REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH
CARE TO ALMOST A MILLION
PATIENTS ANNUALLY. SINCE THE
DOBBS DECISION TWO YEARS AGO,
WE'VE SEEN ATTACKS ON ABORTION
AND REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE AND
GENDER AFFIRMING CARE ALL
INTENSIFY, TURNING ACCESS TO
HEALTH CARE INTO POLITICAL
BATTLEGROUNDS, WHICH HAS
DANGEROUS CONSEQUENCES. SOME OF
WHAT WE'VE SEEN PLAY OUT IN THE
KIND OF POLITICAL BATTLE IS
USING LAND USE, AND PLANNING
TOOLS AS A WAY TO WEAPONIZE
ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE FOR
EXAMPLE, IN THE CITY OF FONTANA,
THE LOCAL PLANNED PARENTHOOD
RECEIVED VERBAL APPROVAL TO
CONSTRUCT A NEW CLINIC ON A
VACANT SITE ALREADY ZONED FOR
HEALTH CARE. AFTER FOLLOWING
STANDARD PROCEDURE, ABIDING BY
LOCAL GUIDELINES, AND ADJUSTING
AS NEEDED TO ENSURE COMPLIANCE.
IT WAS A SURPRISE WHEN THERE WAS
A MORATORIUM PLACED ON ANY NEW
BUILDINGS IN THE AREA WHERE THE
PROSPECTIVE HEALTH CENTER WAS
PLANNED FOR THAT MORATORIUM HAS
BEEN DETERMINED TO ONLY IMPACT
THIS HEALTH CENTER IN A
POST-DOBBS ERA, WHEN MILLIONS
HAVE LOST ACCESS TO ABORTION AND
OTHER REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE
IN THEIR HOME STATES, IT'S
CRITICAL THAT CALIFORNIA ACCESS
IS NOT IMPEDED. THE FONTANA
HEALTH CENTER, FOR EXAMPLE,
WOULD HAVE PROVIDED AN ESTIMATED
2000 MEDICAL VISITS PER MONTH
AND POSITIVELY IMPACTED THE
COMMUNITY. AB 2085 ENSURES THAT
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS CAN'T
UNJUSTLY INTERFERE WITH THE
CONSTRUCTION DELIVERY OF HEALTH
CARE, AND DELIVERS ON
CALIFORNIA'S COMMITMENT AS A
REPRODUCTIVE FREEDOM STATE. I
RESPECTFULLY URGE YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANKS. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT.
OTHER FOLKS WHO WANT TO VOICE
SUPPORT FOR THE BILL COME TO THE
MIC. GOOD MORNING. CHAIR.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS, JONATHAN
CLAY, ON BEHALF OF THE COUNTY OF
SAN DIEGO IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING. DYLAN STAPLETON,
ON BEHALF OF LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR
ELENI KOUNALAKIS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU, MARTIN
RADOSEVICH, ON BEHALF OF
REPRODUCTIVE FREEDOM FOR ALL.
CALIFORNIA PROUD CO-SPONSOR AS
WELL AS ACOG DISTRICT NINE AS A
SUPPORT FOR THE BILL. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING, MR. CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. DENNIS CUEVAS ROMERO
WITH THE CALIFORNIA PRIMARY CARE
ASSOCIATION, ADVOCATES IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH, ELLEN BRITTINGHAM, ON
BEHALF OF BOTH THE NORTHERN AND
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA CHAPTERS OF
THE INTERNATIONAL INTERIOR
DESIGN ASSOCIATION, IN SUPPORT.
OKAY, FOLKS, YOU WANT TO SO WE
HAVE OPPOSITION HERE. GREAT. YOU
MAY PROCEED WHEN READY. THANK
YOU. HONORABLE CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. MY
NAME IS CECILIA IGLESIAS, FORMER
SCHOOL BOARD MEMBER AND COUNCIL
MEMBER IN SANTA ANA AND
CURRENTLY DIRECTOR OF THE
COALITION DE PASTORES LATINOS,
REPRESENTING OVER 120 BIPARTISAN
LATINO PASTORS AND FAITH LEADERS
FROM THE CENTRAL VALLEY AND
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. WE STAND
UNITED IN DEFENDING LIFE,
FAMILY, AND LIBERTY UNDER THE
FIRST AMENDMENT. TODAY, I SPEAK
IN STRONG OPPOSITION TO AB 2085.
AB 2085 MANDATES THAT CITIES
MUST PERMIT COMMUNITY CLINICS,
SPECIFICALLY ABORTION
FACILITIES, AND ALLOWS LAWSUITS
AGAINST MUNICIPALITIES THAT DO
NOT COMPLY. CITIES SHOULD HAVE
THE AUTONOMY TO REGULATE
BUSINESSES BASED ON THEIR
COMMUNITIES VALUES AND NEEDS,
JUST AS THEY DO WITH CASINOS,
TOBACCOS, AND LIQUOR STORES. OUR
COALITION IS COMMITTED TO
PROTECTING ALL LIFE AND
UPHOLDING THE PRINCIPLE OF LOCAL
GOVERNANCE. ABORTION IS NOT JUST
ANOTHER HEALTH CARE SERVICE, IT
IS A PROFOUND MORAL ISSUE
REQUIRING LOCAL DISCRETION,
FORCING MUNICIPALITIES TO ACCEPT
ABORTION FACILITIES IMPOSES A
SPECIFIC MORAL VIEW AND
DISCRIMINATES AGAINST OTHER
FORMS OF REPRODUCTIVE CARE THAT
ARE CRITICALLY NEEDED IN
CALIFORNIA, 1 IN 4 WOMEN
RECEIVES INADEQUATE PRENATAL
CARE. 46 MATERNITY WARDS HAVE
CLOSED SINCE 2012, AND MATERNAL
MORTALITY RATES HAVE DOUBLED. IT
IS INCONCEIVABLE TO PRIORITIZE
EXPANDING ABORTION FACILITIES
WHILE NEGLECTING ESSENTIAL
MATERNITY AND PRENATAL CARE
SERVICES. AB 2085 COULD BE SEEN
AS REPRODUCTIVE COERCION,
ESPECIALLY IN LATINO
COMMUNITIES, WHERE ACCESS TO
QUALITY MATERNAL CARE IS ALREADY
A CHALLENGE. ABORTION IS WIDELY
ACCESSIBLE IN CALIFORNIA, WITH
OVER 400 FACILITIES AVAILABILITY,
AVAILABILITY ON COLLEGE CAMPUSES
AND THROUGH TELEHEALTH. INSTEAD
OF EXPANDING ABORTION ACCESS, WE
URGE YOU TO FOCUS ON ENSURING
COMPREHENSIVE PRENATAL AND
POSTNATAL CARE FOR ALL WOMEN,
ESPECIALLY LATINO WOMEN. AB 2085
UNDERMINES LOCAL CONTROL,
DISCRIMINATES AGAINST
COMPREHENSIVE REPRODUCTIVE CARE,
INFRINGES UPON RELIGIOUS
LIBERTY, AND PROMOTES A HARMFUL
AGENDA. I URGE YOU TO REJECT
THIS BILL AND WORK WITH US TO
SUPPORT ALL ASPECTS OF WOMEN'S
HEALTH, PARTICULARLY THOSE
RELATED TO PREGNANCY AND
MOTHERHOOD. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME AND CONSIDERATION. YOU
HONOR. HONORABLES MIEMBROS DEL
COMITÉ. BUENOS DIAS. MY NAME IS
ALEJANDRO SPECIALE REPRESENTA
UNA SOLA VOZ Y A LA COALITION DE
PASTORES LATINOS, UNA DE MAS DE
PASTORES LEADERS DE FE IN THE
CALIFORNIA USTEDES PARA EXPRESAR
MY FIRM OPPOSITION AL PROYECTO
DE LEY AB DE CINCO DEMANDAS
CONTRA CIUDADES C¯ NO CUMPLEN
CON EL MANDATO DE ABRIL CLINICAS
COMO PLANNED PARENTHOOD.
HONORABLE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE ALEJANDRO REPRESENTS A
VIVA LA VOZ ALTA AND THE
COALITION THAT PASTORS LATINOS,
A NETWORK OF MORE THAN 100
PASTORS AND LEADERS OF FAITH IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. SHE FIRMLY
OPPOSES TO AB 2085, WHICH ALLOWS
LAWSUITS AGAINST CITIES THAT DO
NOT COMPLY WITH THE MANDATE TO
OPEN CLINICS SUCH AS PLANNED
PARENTHOOD IN OUR COMMUNITIES.
SO MADRE MUJER Y DEFENSA DE LA
VIDA, LA FAMILIA, LA EDUCACION Y
LOS DERECHOS HUMANOS, ESTOY
PROFUNDAMENTE PREOCUPADA POR
ESTAR PHYSICAL, EMOTIONAL AND
SPIRITUAL DE LOS INDIVIDUALS EN
COMUNIDADES. AUNQUE PLANNED
PARENTHOOD BRING ATTENTION
PRENATALLY THE MATERNIDAD EN
NOMBRE DE LA SALUD REPRODUCTIVE
INTEGRAL SU EMPHASIS EN EL
ABORTO, EL CUAL ES UN ACTO DE
VIOLENCIA DISCRIMINATION CONTRA
EL DESARROLLO DE LA VIDA A
CUALQUIER ESFUERZO POSITIVO, QUÊ
PUEDEN REALIZAR. SHE'S A MOTHER,
A WOMAN AND A DEFENDER OF LIFE,
FAMILY, EDUCATION AND HUMAN
RIGHTS. DEEPLY CONCERNED ABOUT
THE PHYSICAL, EMOTIONAL AND
SPIRITUAL WILL WELL-BEING OF
INDIVIDUALS IN OUR COMMUNITIES.
ALTHOUGH PLANNED PARENTHOOD
PROVIDES PRENATAL AND MATERNITY
CARE IN THE NAME OF
COMPREHENSIVE REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH, ITS EMPHASIS AND FOCUS
ON ABORTION, WHICH IS AN ACT OF
VIOLENCE AND DISCRIMINATION
AGAINST THE DEVELOPMENT OF LIFE,
NULLIFIES ANY POSITIVE EFFORT
THEY CAN MAKE. APOYO LEGISLACIÓN
PROMUEVE CLINICAS DEDICADAS A LA
INTEGRAL DE LA VIDA DESDE LA
CONCEPCION HASTA CUALQUIER ETAPA
DE SER HUMANO. SHE SUPPORTS
LEGISLATION THAT PROMOTES
CLINICS TRULY DEDICATED TO THE
INTEGRAL WELL-BEING OF LIFE FROM
CONCEPTION TO ANY STAGE OF THE
HUMAN BEING. NUESTRA ES APOYAR
CENTROS DE VALORES Y PROTEGEN LA
VIDA Y LA DIGNIDAD DE CADA UNO
INCLUYENDO EL CONOCIDO COMO
MUJER DE MI MADRE. ME PONGO A
ESTE TIPO DE CLINICAS EN
NUESTRAS COMUNIDADES. THE FOCUS
SHOULD BE IN SUPPORTING CENTERS
THAT REALLY VALUE AND PROTECT
THE LIFE AND DIGNITY OF EVERY
HUMAN BEING, INCLUDING THE
UNBORN. AS A WOMAN OF FAITH AND
MOTHER, I OPPOSE THIS TYPE OF
CLINICS IN OUR COMMUNITIES. UNA
VERDAD, BIBLICA AND SOMOS 22
EXISTS. TODO ME SER TANTO ME
SENTIMIENTOS COMO ME CUERPO
DESDE QUÊ ME TOMAR FORMA DE ME
PADRE DE ME DE MI MADRE S¼ MUY
TUS OBRAS SON MARAVILHOSAS
TUVISTE ME QUESOS CRECER
MIENTRAS ME CUERPO S¼ FORMA EN
EL TUVISTE FORMA APARTE DE ME
CUERPO COMO INDIVIDUOS FORMATOS
MARAVILLOSOS TENEMOS EL DERECHO
A VIVIR. VIVA LA VIDA EN EL
VIENTRE. NO A PLAN PARA NUESTRAS
COMUNIDADES Y CIUDADES GRACIAS
POR SU ATTENTION. DIOS LOS
BENDIGA. LET ME QUOTE FROM THE
BIBLE IN PSALMS 139 YOU MADE MY
WHOLE BEING MY FEELINGS LIKE MY
BODY. YOU MADE ME TAKE SHAPE IN
MY MOTHER'S WOMB. I KNOW VERY
WELL THAT YOUR WORKS ARE
WONDERFUL. YOU SAW MY BONES GROW
WHILE MY BODY FORMED IN MY
MOTHER'S WOMB. YOU SAW FORMING
EVERY PART OF MY BODY AS
WONDERFULLY FORMED INDIVIDUALS.
WE HAVE THE RIGHT TO LIVE LONG,
LIVE LIFE IN THE BELLY. NO TO
PLANNED PARENTHOOD IN OUR
COMMUNITIES AND CITIES. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. GOD BLESS YOU
ALL. THANK YOU. THANK YOU, MR.
GRACIA. LET'S LET'S HAVE FOLKS
WHO WANT TO RAISE CONCERNS ABOUT
THE BILL COME TO THE MICROPHONE,
EXPRESS YOUR OPPOSITION, GREG
BURT, VICE PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA FAMILY COUNCIL, IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU, THANK
YOU. OKAY ANYONE ELSE WANTS TO
RAISE CONCERNS? YES.
BUENOS DIAS. ME NOMBRE ES
CLARIBEL RODRIGUEZ Y ME PONGO LA
LA GENTE CINCO. OKAY. THANK YOU.
GRACIAS. ALL RIGHT, BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE, QUESTIONS? COMMENTS,
THOUGHTS, MOTION FOR THE BILL,
DO YOU WANT TO DO EITHER OF YOU
WANT TO RESPOND TO SOME OF THE
CONCERNS THAT WERE RAISED BY THE
OPPOSITION? I CAN THANK YOU. MR.
CHAIR, I JUST WANT TO SAY, I
MEAN, I AGREE WHOLEHEARTEDLY
WITH THE OPPOSITION THAT WE HAVE
COMMUNITIES ACROSS CALIFORNIA
AND MANY ARE COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR, LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES
WHO DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO
PRENATAL CARE. AND IT'S PART OF
THE MISSION OF THIS BILL. THIS
BILL DOES NOT DICTATE THAT A
CLINIC HAS TO PROVIDE
COMPREHENSIVE REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH CARE. IT MERELY HAS TO
PROVIDE REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE
TO BE ALLOWED IN. AND I'LL BE
HONEST, ONE OF THE SUPPORTERS IN
MY LOCAL COMMUNITY WAS SOMEONE
WHO ASKED US TO EXPAND OUT THE
BILL BECAUSE WE COULDN'T GET A,
A FACILITY BUILT THAT WOULD HAVE
DEALT WITH ADDICTION CARE
BECAUSE THERE WERE PEOPLE WHO
JUST THOUGHT THAT SHOULDN'T BE
IN THEIR COMMUNITY. AND SO
THERE'S A LOT OF REASONS WHY
PEOPLE DENY FACILITIES THAT OUR
COMMUNITIES NEED FOR THEIR
HEALTH AND WELL-BEING. AND WE'RE
SEEING THAT IN THE REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH CARE SPACE. AND SO IT IS
CRITICAL THAT WE ALLOW THESE
FACILITIES TO BE BUILT. I HAVE
TWO PLANNED PARENTHOOD'S IN MY
COMMUNITY. ONE DOESN'T PROVIDE
ABORTION CARE, ONE DOES, BUT
BOTH ARE EQUALLY IMPORTANT IN
PROVIDING COMPREHENSIVE CARE TO
MY COMMUNITY. SO I REALLY THINK
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT STEP IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION IN PROVIDING
SOME OF WHAT WE HEARD FROM THE
OPPOSITION, WHICH IS THAT
PRENATAL CARE. THAT'S SO
CRITICAL. THANK YOU. AND IT IS I
MEAN, THE CENTRAL PREMISE HERE
IS THAT, YOU KNOW, THAT THERE
THERE ARE THE POLITICS END UP
GETTING SO INTENSE THAT, THAT
THE NORMAL, DISCRETIONARY,
PERMITTING PROCESSES SHOULD,
OUGHT TO BE BYPASSED. YES. I
MEAN, THE DECISIONS THAT ARE
BEING MADE IN CERTAIN PARTS OF
THE STATE ARE THAT ARE
DISCRIMINATORY AGAINST
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE. AGAIN,
AS I MENTIONED, THOSE CAN BE ON
THE BASIS OF THE POLITICS AROUND
ABORTION CARE. THEY CAN BE BASED
ON OTHER REASONS, YOU KNOW, I'M
SURE ALL OF US HAVE PEOPLE IN
OUR COMMUNITIES WHO DON'T WANT
BUSINESSES IN THEIR COMMUNITY
FOR LOTS OF REASONS. I'LL BE
HONEST. WE HEAR THAT EVERY DAY
UP HERE, ON THE HOUSING FIGHTS
AND THINGS LIKE THAT. SO I THINK
THAT THE THING IS, CALIFORNIA
HAS SAID THAT THIS AREA IS A
PRIORITY FOR US, AND WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE THAT THERE ARE NOT
ARTIFICIAL BARRIERS PUT UP TO
PROVIDING REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH
CARE TO CALIFORNIANS. OKAY ALL
RIGHT. WE'LL TAKE THAT AS YOU'RE
CLOSED. YES. THANK YOU. MR.
CHAIR. THIS DISCUSSION IS GOING
TO CONTINUE, SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL AB 2085. THE
MOTION IS DUE. PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS. SENATORS ALAN
A ALLEN. I TALLY GONZALEZ.
HURTADO. HURTADO I MENGIBAR
NGUYEN. SKINNER. ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. EVERYBODY
OKAY. THANK YOU. OKAY. WE HAVE
SOME OTHER MEMBERS HERE. I
THINK, SOME MEMBER GRAYSON'S
NEXT. OH, NO. OH, OKAY. OH, IN
THE SECOND ROW. WHAT ARE YOU
DOING HIDING BACK THERE? ALL
RIGHT, COME ON UP. SO MEMBER
BAINES. EXCELLENT ALL RIGHT.
HARBOR CRAFT LESS CONTROVERSIAL
THAN SURE. HOPE SO. REPRODUCTIVE
POLITICS. ALL RIGHT. YEAH, A
LITTLE BIT. YEAH. WHAT DO YOU
THINK, ERIC? OKAY, ALL RIGHT,
HERE WE GO, THOUGH. NOT WITHOUT
CONTROVERSY. LET'S BE HONEST.
OKAY YOU MAY PROCEED WHEN READY.
AWESOME. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
CHAIRMAN. FIRST, LET ME THANK
THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR
WORK ON THE BILL, THERE ARE A
LOT OF STAKEHOLDERS WHO CARE
DEEPLY ABOUT OUR PORTS, OUR
MARINE ENVIRONMENT, AND THE
SAFETY OF OUR MARITIME WORK
FORCE. THE PROPOSED COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS THAT I'M ACCEPTING
STRIKE AN IMPORTANT BALANCE IN
PROTECTING THE SAFETY AND INCOME
OF WORKERS WHILE PUTTING IN
PLACE IMPORTANT GUARDRAILS THAT
ENSURE BAD ACTORS CANNOT ABUSE
THE SYSTEM. CALIFORNIA LEADS THE
NATION IN ENVIRONMENTAL
PROGRESS, AND OUR PORTS ARE A
VITAL PART OF OUR ECONOMY. BUT
WE MUST ENSURE THAT OUR PROGRESS
DOES NOT COME AT THE EXPENSE OF
SAFETY OR THE WELL-BEING OF OUR
MARITIME WORKFORCE. NEW CARB
REGULATIONS WILL REDUCE AIR
POLLUTION AT OUR PORTS BY
REQUIRING REQUIRING MORE
EFFICIENT AND CLEANER ENGINE
TECHNOLOGIES ON COMMERCIAL
HARBOR CRAFT LIKE TUGBOATS,
IMPROVING OUR AIR QUALITY IN
FRONT LINE PORT COMMUNITIES IS
AN IMPORTANT GOAL THAT I DO
SUPPORT. A LOT OF PEOPLE DO NOT
REALIZE THAT CLEANING UP THE AIR
OF THE PORTS OF LA AND LONG
BEACH WILL ALSO IMPROVE THE AIR
QUALITY IN MY DISTRICT OF KERN
COUNTY, BECAUSE SO MUCH OF THAT
POLLUTION BLOWS OVER THE
GRAPEVINE AND SETTLES IN THE
SOUTHERN SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY AS A
FAMILY PHYSICIAN, I SEE FAR TOO
MANY KIDS AND SENIORS WITH
ASTHMA AND OTHER POTENTIALLY
LIFE THREATENING RESPIRATORY
CONDITIONS. SO THIS IS IMPORTANT
WORK THAT I WANT TO SEE COME TO
FRUITION. ONE OF THE CHALLENGES
IN ACHIEVING THESE AIR QUALITY
IMPROVEMENTS IS THAT THE ENGINE
TECHNOLOGY TO MEET CARB'S
REQUIREMENTS SIMPLY DOES NOT
EXIST, AND IT WILL REQUIRE THE
USE OF SPECIAL FILTERS THAT
REACH TEMPERATURES OF OVER 1500
DEGREES. THESE HIGH TEMPERATURES
AND UNPROVEN TECHNOLOGIES POSE
UNIQUE DANGERS ON BOATS, WHERE A
FIRE OR A LOSS OF PROPULSION IS
DEADLY AND POTENTIALLY
DISASTROUS. AS WE SAW JUST THIS
YEAR IN BALTIMORE, WHERE LIVES
WERE LOST AND REPAIRS ARE
ESTIMATED AT MORE THAN 4
BILLION. IN RECOGNITION OF THESE
CONCERNS, THE US COAST GUARD,
THE MARITIME INDUSTRY AND THE
UNIONS REPRESENTING VESSEL
WORKERS HAD ASKED THAT CARB'S
REGULATIONS INCLUDE A BYPASS
SYSTEM THAT WOULD ALLOW THE
CAPTAIN TO MAINTAIN FULL POWER
IN THE EVENT OF AN EMERGENCY.
CARB REJECTED THESE REQUESTS,
AND THE REGULATIONS DISALLOW ANY
BYPASS SYSTEM TO BE USED EVEN IN
THE EVENT OF AN EMERGENCY. AB
1122 WILL ENSURE THAT THESE
SAFETY CONCERNS ARE NOT IGNORED.
BY PERMITTING A BYPASS SYSTEM TO
BE USED DURING AN EMERGENCY TO
ENSURE THESE SYSTEMS ARE NOT
ABUSED, THE BILL REQUIRES ROBUST
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS THAT
DETAIL WHEN, WHY AND HOW THEY
ARE USED. WHILE CARB HAS SEEN
HAS SINCE REVISITED ITS POSITION
AND HAS NOW INDICATED TO THE
COAST GUARD THAT THEY WILL ISSUE
AN EXECUTIVE ORDER TO OVERRIDE
THE BAN ON BYPASS SYSTEMS, THEY
HAVEN'T DONE SO YET SINCE
EXECUTIVE ORDERS ARE ISSUED
OUTSIDE THE PUBLIC PROCESS AND
CAN BE UNILATERALLY RESCINDED.
AB 1122 PROVIDES THE CERTAINTY
THAT SHOULD HAVE BEEN INCLUDED
IN THE ORIGINAL REGULATIONS. IN
ADDITION, THE BILL INCLUDES A
PROVISION THAT WILL MINIMIZE
LOST INCOME FOR WORKERS WHEN
THEIR VESSEL IS IN DRY DOCK,
BEING UPDATED WITH CLEANER
ENGINE COMPONENTS WHILE VESSELS
ARE IN DRY DOCK. CREWS ARE NOT
PAID IN. THE UNIONS HAVE
ESTIMATED THAT THEIR MEMBERS
COULD LOSE ANYWHERE FROM 25 TO
30% OF THEIR INCOME FOR VESSELS
TO COMPLY WITH THE NEW CARB
RULES, AB 1122 ADDRESSES THIS
PROBLEM BY ALLOWING VESSELS TO
ALIGN THEIR COAST GUARD
INSPECTION SCHEDULE WITH THE
REQUIREMENT TO INSTALL NEW
ENGINES. SINCE CREWS ALREADY
OPERATE AROUND THESE
INSPECTIONS, ALIGNMENT WILL
SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCE THE IMPACT
ON WORKER INCOMES. COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS TAKEN TODAY BOTH
CLARIFY AND CAP THESE ALIGNMENT
EXTENSIONS SO THAT THEY TRULY
ARE FOR THE BENEFIT OF THE
WORKERS AND NOT SIMPLY AN EXCUSE
TO EXTEND NONCOMPLIANCE. WE HAVE
DRAFTED AB 1122 WITH THE INTENT
TO BE NARROW AND TAILORED IN
ADDRESSING THE LEGITIMATE SAFETY
AND ECONOMIC CONCERNS RAISED BY
STAKEHOLDERS. THIS BILL IS
SUPPORTED BY THE UNIONS
REPRESENTING WORKERS, INCLUDING
THE CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION,
AMONG MANY OTHERS. AND WITH ME
TODAY, I HAVE TWO KEY WITNESSES.
WHO ARE THESE TWO KEY WITNESSES?
MY NAME IS KYLE BURLESON WITH
THE AMERICAN WATERWAYS OPERATORS.
CAPTAIN SLY HUNTER, REGIONAL
REPRESENTATIVE FOR MASTERS,
MATES AND PILOTS. OKAY, GREAT.
YOU MAY PROCEED. GOOD MORNING.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. MY NAME IS
KYLE BURLESON. I'M THE DIRECTOR
OF STATE ADVOCACY FOR THE
AMERICAN WATERWAYS OPERATORS,
WHICH IS THE ADVOCATE RESOURCE
AND UNITED VOICE FOR THE TUGBOAT
TOWBOAT AND BARGE INDUSTRY. OUR
INDUSTRY APPRECIATES CHAIR ALLEN
FOR HEARING THIS BILL AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BAINES FOR
CHAMPIONING WORKPLACE SAFETY FOR
MARINERS. AS I SHARED AT SHARED
ASSEMBLY CHAIR MIKE GIBSON'S
HEARING AT THE PORT OF SAN
FRANCISCO IN NOVEMBER, THE BARGE
AND TOWING INDUSTRY IS THE MOST
SUSTAINABLE MODE OF
TRANSPORTATION, WITH RAIL
PRODUCING 43% MORE GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS THAN BARGE
TRANSPORTATION AND TRUCKS
PRODUCING OVER 800% MORE.
CALIFORNIA SHOULD BE VERY PROUD
OF ITS MARITIME IMPORTANCE,
RANKING THIRD ACROSS THE COUNTRY
IN WATERBORNE COMMERCE BY TON
239 MILLION TONS OF FREIGHT
MOVED BY VESSELS IN CALIFORNIA
EACH YEAR, CREATING MORE THAN
$12 BILLION IN ECONOMIC ACTIVITY.
OUR MEMBERS FOOTPRINT IN
CALIFORNIA STRETCHES FROM SAN
DIEGO TO NORTHERN CALIFORNIA IN
THE INLAND PORT SYSTEM AS WELL.
LIKE HERE IN SACRAMENTO. SO WITH
THIS BACKDROP, WE ASK YOU TO
PASS AB 1122, IN THE NAME OF
WORKPLACE SAFETY. WITH THE
RECENT CHANGES TO THE COMMERCIAL
HARBOR CRAFT RULE, OUR INDUSTRY
HAS SPOKEN UP ALL ALONG THE WAY
THAT THERE IS AN ODD AND
POTENTIALLY DANGEROUS PROVISION
THAT NEEDS CORRECTING.
UNFORTUNATELY, CARB HAS IGNORED
OUR PLEAS, SO WE'RE TURNING OUR
VOICE TO YOU. WE'RE ALSO JOINED
BY THE THREE MOST PROMINENT
LABOR UNIONS TO WORK WITHIN THE
TOWING INDUSTRY, INCLUDING THE
MASTERS, MATES AND PILOTS,
MARINE ENGINEERS, BENEFICIAL
ASSOCIATION IN THE INLAND
BOATMEN'S UNION OF THE PACIFIC.
IT ALSO BEARS MENTIONING THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION HAS
PLEDGED ITS SUPPORT TO THIS BILL.
WE'RE ASKING THAT BEFORE DIESEL
PARTICULATE FILTERS ARE REQUIRED
TO BE INSTALLED, THE STANDARD
SAFETY PROCESS IS FOLLOWED
WHENEVER NEW EQUIPMENT IS
INSTALLED ON A VESSEL. A THIRD
PARTY AUDITOR, KNOWN AS A VESSEL
CLASS SOCIETY, VETS THE PRODUCT
TO ENSURE THAT IT'S SAFE AND IT
WILL NOT CATCH FIRE UNDER
DURESS. FOR WHATEVER REASON,
CARB HAS BYPASSED THESE SAFETY
EXPERTS, WHICH ALSO INCLUDE THE
UNITED STATES COAST GUARD. IF
DPF SOUND FAMILIAR TO YOU, IT'S
BECAUSE OF THE FIRES THEY'VE
STARTED ON SCHOOL BUSSES AND
SEMI TRUCKS. THESE DPFS NEED
CAREFUL CONSIDERATION BECAUSE OF
THEIR INFAMOUS HISTORY AND THE
SIZE AND STABILITY CONCERNS THEY
CREATE ON TOWING VESSELS. IF YOU
IMAGINE TRYING TO PUT TWO VW
BUGS ON A TUGBOAT, THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT AND PUTTING
THEM UP RELATIVELY HIGH ABOVE
THE ENGINE. SO THE STABILITY
CONCERNS ARE VERY REAL. IN OUR
80 YEAR HISTORY, OUR TRADE
ASSOCIATION HAS NEVER HAD TO ASK
A LEGISLATURE TO INTERVENE TO
PROTECT LIVES ON BOARD A VESSEL.
BUT THAT'S WHAT'S NEEDED HERE
BECAUSE CARB DID NOT ACT BEFORE.
WE DO NOT EXPECT THEM TO
PRIORITIZE MARINER AND WORKPLACE
SAFETY IN THE FUTURE. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME. I'D BE HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. GOOD
MORNING, CHAIR ALLEN AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS
CAPTAIN SLY HUNTER. I'M A 30
YEAR SAN FRANCISCO BAY CAPTAIN,
RETIRED AND CURRENTLY THE
REGIONAL REPRESENTATIVE FOR
MASTER MATES AND PILOTS, AS A
REGIONAL REPRESENTATIVE, I
REPRESENT THE MEN AND WOMEN IN
THE ENTIRE STATE, FROM THE
GOLDEN GATE TO THE VINCENT
THOMAS BRIDGE. I PERSONALLY
OVERSEE ALL OF ALL OF OUR
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
AGREEMENTS. I NEGOTIATE ALL OUR
CONTRACTS AND DEAL WITH ALL OUR
MEMBER ISSUES, AS A REGIONAL
REP, I CAN TELL YOU THAT BEFORE
WE DO ANYTHING IN A COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING AGREEMENT IN REGARDS
TO ECONOMICS OR ANYTHING ELSE,
THE FIRST ITEM ON THE AGENDA IS
SAFETY, YOU CAN HAVE THE BEST
CONTRACT IN THE WORLD IF YOU'RE
MEN AND WOMEN AREN'T COMING HOME
SAFELY, THEN THAT CONTRACT IS
USELESS, JUST TO GIVE YOU A
LITTLE TIDBIT ABOUT WHO WE ARE,
IF YOU EVER SAW THE MOVIE
CAPTAIN PHILLIPS, THAT'S A NOT
TOM OR, THE ACTOR, BUT THE
ACTUAL RICHARD PHILLIPS IS A
MEMBER OF MASTERS, MATES AND
PILOTS. AND SO THAT'S PART OF
OUR BLUE WATER, THAT THE MOVIE
THE PIRATES TAKE OVER THE SHIP?
YES. DOES THAT EVER HAPPENED IN
SANTA FE? IT'S HAPPENING NOW.
YES. OUR SHIPS ARE UNDER FIRE
CURRENTLY. NOW. NOT IN SAN
FRANCISCO. NO, NO, BUT I'M
SAYING. YEAH, THAT MOVIE WAS
ABOUT HIM BEING TAKEN HOSTAGE.
YES. TOM HANKS, TOM HANKS IS NOT
A MEMBER. ALTHOUGH WE WOULD WE
WOULD WELCOME HIM, YEAH. SO
YEAH, THAT'S ACTUALLY ONE OF OUR
GUYS. BUT I DEAL WITH THE INLAND
SIDE AND WE ACTUALLY HAVE
CONTRACTS HERE IN SACRAMENTO AND
IN STOCKTON, SO I HAVE MEN AND
WOMEN WHO WORK ON THE BOATS,
WATER HERE, AS I WAS SAYING, I
OVERSEE ALL THE CONTRACTS, AND
OUR FIRST PRIORITY IS SAFETY,
AND, THE PRIORITY IS TO ENSURE
THAT OUR MEMBERS HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK. AND THAT'S
THE OTHER PART OF THE BILL IS IF
THESE BOATS ARE LAID UP, YOU
KNOW, EVERY TWO AND A HALF
YEARS, ANY BOAT THAT'S ON SALT
WATER IS GOING TO GO INTO DRY
DOCK ANYWAY. AND IF THOSE, DRY
DOCKINGS, IF WE HAVE EXTRA DRY
DOCKINGS, THAT'S A 20 OR 30%
REDUCTION IN WORKFORCE. AND
THAT'S EVERYTHING FOR US. THAT'S
HUGE. AND SO THIS IS WHY WE ARE
PARTNERED WITH MEBA AND THE EBU
IN SUPPORT OF THIS, NONE OF OUR
UNIONS WERE CREW OF VESSEL
UNLESS THE COMPANIES ENSURE THAT
EVERYTHING ON BOARD IS
CONDUCTED. ACCORDING TO THE
UNITED STATES COAST GUARD
STANDARDS AND INDEPENDENTLY
INSPECTED, IT IS ONLY THEN WE
CAN HAVE SOME PEACE OF MIND THAT
OUR MEMBERS WILL RETURN HOME
SAFE FROM ONE OF THE MOST
DANGEROUS PROFESSIONS THERE IS.
I WON'T GO INTO A LOT. I DID A
GUT AND AMEND. I BORROWED THAT
TERM, ON MY STATEMENT BECAUSE OF
EVERYTHING THAT WAS BROUGHT UP.
BUT, IF YOU LOOKED AT THE NEWS
RECENTLY, I THINK WE SEE THE
IMPORTANCE OF THE TUGBOATS AND
THE TUGBOAT INDUSTRY WHERE
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO DECREASE,
THEY'RE GOING TO INCREASE, ON A
VESSEL. ENGINES ARE NOT JUST THE
GAS PEDAL, ENGINES ARE ALSO THE
BRAKES, STEERING. AND SIMPLY
PUT, ANYTHING THAT CAN GET IN
THE WAY OF PROPERLY, AND FULLY
FUNCTIONING ENGINES CREATES A
SERIOUS SAFETY ISSUE THAT
ENDANGERS THE CREW,
INFRASTRUCTURE AND ENVIRONMENT.
AND IF YOU WANT PERSONAL
INFORMATION FROM ME ON, ON SOME
ALLUSIONS THAT I HAVE PERSONALLY
BEEN A PART OF, I CAN TELL YOU,
YOU KNOW, IN DETAIL AFTERWARDS,
THE OTHER PORTION OF THE BILL
ENSURES THERE'S NO UNNECESSARY
DISRUPTIONS. AND OUR MEMBERS
ONLY EARN INCOME WHEN THEY'RE ON
THE VESSEL. AND SO MOST OF OUR
CONTRACTS, THE BOATS ARE
CONSIDERED WITH WHAT WE CALL
DOUBLE CREWED. I DON'T KNOW IF
YOU'RE AWARE OF THAT, WHERE WE
ACTUALLY HAVE A DAY, SIDE AND
NIGHT SIDE CREW. SO THE BOATS
ARE AVAILABLE 24 HOURS. SO WHEN
ONE BOAT GOES OUT OF COMMISSION,
THAT'S JUST NOT ONE CREW. THAT'S
TWO CREWS THAT ARE SITTING ON
THE BEACH NOT EARNING, CHAIR
ALLEN AND MEMBERS, THIS BILL IS
ABOUT SAFETY AND INCOME OF THE
MEN AND WOMEN THAT WORK IN
EXTREME CONDITIONS TO KEEP OUR
INFRASTRUCTURE AND BEAUTIFUL
COAST PROTECTED. MMP, IBU, AND
MEBA APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT OF
OUR MEMBERS. THANK YOU, THANK
YOU. OKAY. OTHER FOLKS WHO WANT
TO WEIGH IN SUPPORT, JUST
EXPRESS YOUR SUPPORT. GOOD
MORNING. MY NAME IS KEVIN
HARTLEY. I'M A GRADUATE OF
CALIFORNIA MARITIME ACADEMY, A
MARITIME PROFESSIONAL. I WORK
FOR CROWLEY MARITIME. WE
ACTUALLY OWN AND OPERATE THE
FIRST ALL ELECTRIC TUGBOAT WITH
THAT BEING SAID, WE ARE HERE IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. GREG AND I WAS ASKED
TO CONVEY SUPPORT ON BEHALF OF
THE DREDGING CONTRACTORS OF
AMERICA, WHO GOT IN THEIR LATE
LETTER OF SUPPORT. GOOD MORNING,
JENNIFER COHEN WITH PMSA IN
SUPPORT. GOOD MORNING, CHAIR
MEMBERS ELMER LAZARD, ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION IN SUPPORT. YEAH,
OKAY. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT,
OPPOSITION. ANYONE WHO WANTS TO
RAISE CONCERNS ABOUT THE BILL,
COME ON UP. YOU CAN COME UP TO
THE FRONT HERE IF YOU WANT. GOOD
MORNING. MY NAME IS THERESA BèC
WITH THE ENVIRONMENTAL NONPROFIT
PACIFIC ENVIRONMENT. WE HAVE A
CONSULTATIVE STATUS WITH THE
INTERNATIONAL MARITIME
ORGANIZATION AND HELP LEAD THE
COALITION IN SUPPORT OF THE
COMMERCIAL HARBOR CRAFT RULE.
BACK IN 2022, WE'RE, YOU KNOW,
REALLY THANKFUL FOR ALL THE WORK
OF, WORKING WITH THE AUTHORS AND
SPONSORS OFFICE. BUT WE
REGRETFULLY MUST OPPOSE THIS
BILL, IN TERMS OF THE DPF
SAFETY, AND WE, CONCUR WITH THE
STAFF'S RECOMMENDATION IN TERMS
OF YOU KNOW, CARB HAS ALREADY
REQUIRED DPF MANUFACTURERS TO
DEMONSTRATE SAFE AND DURABLE,
FUEL PERFORMANCE. CARB HAS
ALREADY CONDUCTED APPROXIMATELY
9000 HOURS OF OPERATION, AND
THEY HAVE NOT FOUND ANY
DOCUMENTED SAFETY. AND THERE'S
ALREADY BEEN BACK AND FORTH WITH
THE US COAST GUARD IN TERMS OF,
COLLABORATION. THEIR HARBOR
CRAFT ARE THE MAJOR DRIVER OF
AIR POLLUTION AT SEAPORTS, AND
TUGBOATS ARE REPRESENT 20% OF
THE EMISSIONS, OUR UNDERSTANDING
IS LIKE, YOU KNOW, WITH DPS, IF
A TUGBOAT WERE TO GO TO ZERO
EMISSION, THEY COULD, YOU KNOW,
BYPASS THE DPF. AND JUST LAST
WEEK WE SAW THE FIRST ALL
ELECTRIC TUGBOAT LAUNCH AT THE
PORT OF SAN DIEGO. SO WE'RE
ALREADY SEEING ZERO EMISSION
TECHNOLOGIES. NOW, WHY ARE WE
GOING TO TIER FOUR, WHICH IS
STILL DIESEL EMISSION? CLEANER,
BUT DIESEL EMISSION WITH THE
DPF. AND THEN ON THE SECOND
PIECE WE SUPPORT STAFF'S
RECOMMENDATION. WE THINK THAT,
THE AMENDMENTS ARE GOES A LONG
WAYS IN TERMS OF ADDRESSING OUR
CONCERNS AND REALLY APPRECIATE
THE, AUTHORS OFFICE FOR WORKING
WITH US ON THAT. OKAY. THANK
YOU, ANYONE ELSE WHO WANTS TO
VOICE CONCERN OR OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL COME TO THE MIC. GOOD
MORNING, SOPHIA KHÓ WITH THE
COALITION FOR CLEAN AIR. WE HAVE
AN OPPOSED POSITION, BUT WE DO
SUPPORT THE AMENDMENTS
RECOMMENDED IN THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
REBECCA MARCUS, REPRESENTING THE
UNION UNION OF CONCERNED
SCIENTISTS, ALIGNING OUR
COMMENTS WITH, PACIFIC
ENVIRONMENT. THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR. MARK FENSTERMAKER FOR
EARTHJUSTICE, OPPOSED FOR THE
REASONS STATED BY PACIFIC
ENVIRONMENT. THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT. WE'RE BRINGING TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR DISCUSSION. YOU
KNOW, I MEAN, I, I, I HEAR AND
I'M SYMPATHETIC TO A LOT OF THE
OPPOSITION CONCERNS. I DO THINK
THAT, YOU KNOW, IN THE END OF
THE DAY, WE'VE CRAFTED SOME
AMENDMENTS THAT I THINK REALLY
GO SUBSTANTIALLY, MOVE US
SUBSTANTIALLY TOWARD SOME OF THE
BROAD ENVIRONMENTAL GOALS. BUT I
KNOW THERE'S GOING TO CONTINUE
TO BE SOME TENSION OVER
PROVIDING MORE FLEXIBILITY,
WHICH I REALLY UNDERSTAND. YOU
KNOW, THESE ARE FOLKS WHO ARE
VERY DEVOTED TO DOING EVERYTHING
WE CAN TO REDUCE, REDUCE
POLLUTION, AND, AND THAT'S WHAT
THIS IS ULTIMATELY ALL ABOUT.
SO, I'M HAPPY TO SUPPORT THE
BILL TODAY WITH THE AMENDMENTS,
BUT I DO I DO WANT TO ENCOURAGE
THE AUTHOR TO, YOU KNOW,
CONTINUE WORKING WITH THE
OPPOSITION. I KNOW THAT, SOME OF
THE ARGUMENTS ARE COMING IN
RELATIVELY LATE, BUT I, YOU
KNOW, SO I DIDN'T FEEL
COMFORTABLE KIND OF STALLING THE
BILL. WITH THAT IN MIND,
ESPECIALLY SINCE WE'RE RIGHT UP
AGAINST THE, THE RECESS. BUT I
REALLY DO. I'D LIKE TO ASK YOU
TO COMMIT TO SITTING DOWN WITH
THE OPPONENTS AND, AND SPEND
SOME TIME WORKING WITH THEM ON
SOME OF THEIR CORE CONCERNS. NO,
I MEAN, ABSOLUTELY. LOOK, I'M A
PHYSICIAN. I CARE ABOUT AIR
POLLUTION. THAT'S OBVIOUS. AND
IT'S OFFENSIVE. IF PEOPLE THINK
THAT I DON'T CARE ABOUT AIR
POLLUTION, I SEE PATIENTS THAT
SUFFER FROM IT DAILY. BUT AT THE
SAME TIME, DOES THAT MEAN WE
SACRIFICE THE LIFE OF PEOPLE
THAT ARE WORKING AS MARITIME
WORKFORCE RIGHT NOW? THERE ARE
TRUE SACRIFICE TO LIFE. WHAT DO
YOU MEAN BY THAT? YES. SO
LITERALLY, IF WE DON'T HAVE A
BYPASS SYSTEM, A TUGBOAT IS NOT
A VEHICLE. THEY CAN'T JUST PULL
OVER TO THE SIDE. IF THERE'S AN
EMERGENCY, YOU TURN OFF POWER,
YOU LOSE POWER. THAT THING
SINKS. WE SAW THIS HAPPEN. WE.
THERE'S BEEN LIVES THAT HAVE
BEEN TAKEN. THAT IS NOT. THAT IS
NOT LIKE UP FOR DISCUSSION.
THERE IS A SAFETY CONCERN HERE.
LOOK, I HAVE BEEN WORKING WITH
THE OPPOSITION. THAT'S THAT'S
NOT YOU CANNOT SAY THAT WE HAVE
NOT BEEN DOING THAT. BUT TRYING
TO PUT ALL OF OUR EGGS IN ONE
BASKET. I APPLAUD THE FACT THAT
THERE'S THE FIRST ELECT OR
EMISSION ZERO EMISSION
ELECTRONIC TUGBOAT, BUT THAT'S
ONE OF SO MANY THAT WE HAVE OUT
THERE. THE TRANSITION IS
HAPPENING. NO ONE'S FIGHTING
THAT. LET'S SAVE THE LIVES TODAY.
LET'S SAVE THE LIVES IN 30
YEARS. LET'S SAVE THE LIVES IN
100 YEARS. BUT LET'S NOT
SACRIFICE THE LIVES THAT ARE
HERE TODAY. AS A PHYSICIAN, I
CARE ABOUT THE LIVES TODAY,
RIGHT? I CARE ABOUT THE LIVES
TOMORROW. I CARE ABOUT THE LIVES
IN 100 YEARS AS WELL. IT SEEMS
LIKE A LOT OF THE CONCERNS COME
DOWN TO THE DELAYING OF
COMPLIANCE DATES FOR RETROFIT
AND REPLACEMENT, THAT KIND OF
THING. SO THAT'S NOT A QUESTION
OF KIND OF EMERGENCY
PREPAREDNESS AS OF RIGHT NOW, IF
WE DON'T OFFER A BYPASS SYSTEM,
IT COULD COST LIVES, WHICH WE
SAW HAPPEN ALREADY. WHAT
HAPPENED BEFORE? WHAT ARE YOU
REFERRING TO? IN BALTIMORE,
THERE WAS LOSS OF PROPULSION.
OKAY WELL, ALL RIGHT, LET'S HAVE
SOME FURTHER DISCUSSION, I'LL
SUPPORT THE BILL, WITH THE
AMENDMENTS HAVING BEEN TAKEN,
BUT I'D LOVE TO HAVE SOME
FURTHER DISCUSSION. ALL RIGHT.
YES SENATOR. THE TOPIC OF LIFE.
HAPPY BELATED BIRTHDAY TO THE
ASSEMBLYWOMAN. AND WITH THAT,
I'D MOVE THE BILL. THANK YOU.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
AB 1122. THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED AS AMENDED, TO
APPROPRIATIONS. SENATORS ALLEN,
A ALLEN. I TALLY. GONZALEZ.
HURTADO. HURTADO I MENGIBAR
NGUYEN. SKINNER ALL RIGHT. WE'LL
LEAVE ON A CALL FOR OTHER FOLKS
TO ADD ON. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
OKAY, LET'S GO TO SOME NUMBER.
GRAYSON. YEAH OH, THE ALARM GOES
OFF THE SECOND YOU STEP UP. TIM
ALL RIGHT, FUTURE SENATOR
GRAYSON, YOU MAY PROCEED. I
APPRECIATE YOUR OPTIMISM AND
GOOD, IS IT MORNING STILL? YES.
YEAH, GOOD MORNING, MR. CHAIR.
MEMBERS AB 20 1296 PROHIBITS
STATE REGULATIONS FOR FROM
REQUIRING OR COMPELLING THE SAN
FRANCISCO BAR PILOTS TO REPLACE
THREE SPECIFIED PILOT STATION
BOATS UNLESS THE REGULATION
AUTHORIZES THE REPLACEMENT OF A
PILOT STATION BOAT ONCE IT
REACHES THE END OF ITS USEFUL
SERVICE LIFE. SAN FRANCISCO BAR
PILOTS, OR SP, PROVIDE AN
ESSENTIAL SERVICE BY SAFELY
NAVIGATING COMMERCIAL VESSELS TO
AND FROM NINE NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA PORTS NOW UNDER THE
CALIFORNIA CODE S CBP IS
MANDATED TO MAINTAIN A MINIMUM
OF TWO PILOT BOATS IN SERVICE
WITH ONE BOAT ON STATION IN THE
OPEN OCEAN AT ALL TIMES. TO MEET
THESE REQUIREMENTS, CBP
MAINTAINS A FLEET OF FIVE FIVE
PILOT BOATS. CALIFORNIA AIR
RESOURCES BOARD'S COMMERCIAL
HARBOR CRAFT REGULATIONS, WHICH
WERE EFFECTIVE OR WILL BE
EFFECTIVE DECEMBER 31ST, 2024,
WILL RENDER SBP'S SERVICES
NEARLY IMPOSSIBLE, WITH A TOTAL
CONSTRUCTION COST OF 68 MILLION,
NOT INCLUDING FINANCING.
REPLACING THESE THREE VESSELS
WITHIN THE SPECIFIED DEADLINES
IS NEITHER FINANCIALLY NOR
LOGISTICALLY FEASIBLE. AB 1296
PROPOSES A VIABLE PATHWAY TO
ACHIEVE CARB COMPLIANCE BY
EXTENDING CARB DEADLINES TO
MATCH THE SERVICE LIFE OF THE
STATION BOATS. THIS APPROACH
ALLOWS SUFFICIENT TIME TO
COLLECT THE NECESSARY FUNDS TO
BUILD NEW CARB COMPLIANT BOATS,
ONE AT A TIME, WITHOUT FINANCING
THE CONSTRUCTION COST AND SAVING
TENS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
ULTIMATELY, THOUGH, AB 1296 WILL
ENSURE THE ECONOMIC HEALTH AND
STABILITY OF THE PILOTAGE SYSTEM
WHILE ALIGNING WITH CALIFORNIA'S
ENVIRONMENTAL GOALS. AND I DO
HAVE WITNESSES WITH US HERE
TODAY. I'LL HAVE SELF INTRODUCE.
OKAY. GOOD MORNING. MR.
CHAIRMAN, MY NAME IS KEVIN
BALDWIN. I'M GENERAL COUNSEL FOR
THE SAN FRANCISCO BAR PILOTS AND
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK TODAY ON BEHALF OF THIS
BILL. THIS BILL PROVIDES THE SAN
FRANCISCO BAR PILOTS WITH A
VIABLE PATH TO COMPLIANCE WITH
THE CARB REGULATIONS, UNDER
CURRENT REGULATIONS, IT'S AS AS,
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GRAYSON
MENTIONED, IS NEITHER
FINANCIALLY NOR PRACTICALLY
FEASIBLE TO COMPLY WITH THE
REGULATIONS ON THE EXISTING
DEADLINES, SAN FRANCISCO BAR
PILOT STATION BOATS CANNOT BE
REPOWERED IN ORDER TO COMPLY,
DUE TO SPACE RESTRICTIONS AND
THE SIZE OF THE DIESEL
PARTICULATE FILTERS NEEDED TO
BRING THE BOATS INTO COMPLIANCE.
INSTEAD, WE NEED TO BUILD BRAND
NEW CUSTOM BOATS AT A COST OF
$22 MILLION A PIECE. IF WE HAD
TO BUILD ALL THREE OF THOSE
BOATS, UNDER THE EXISTING
DEADLINES TODAY, WE WOULD HAVE
TO FINANCE THAT PROJECT. AND THE
COST OF, PAYING BACK THAT
FINANCING WOULD BE OVER $86
MILLION, CBP AS AN ENTITY IS
SIMPLY UNABLE TO GUARANTEE THAT
AMOUNT OF DEBT, AND IN ADDITION,
IT'S NOT PRACTICALLY POSSIBLE TO
DO SO. THE LEAD TIMES ON, THE
EQUIPMENT NEEDED TO BUILD THOSE
BOATS, CURRENTLY WOULD NOT ALLOW
US TO COMPLETE THEM WITHIN THE
EXISTING DEADLINES. THE ENGINES
THEMSELVES HAVE A LEAD TIME OF
OVER A YEAR. AND THERE'S ALSO
EXTREMELY LIMITED SPACE IN
SHIPYARDS THAT ARE CAPABLE OF
BUILDING THESE TYPES OF BOATS,
PARTICULARLY ON THE WEST COAST,
IN PART DUE TO, COMPETITION FROM
OTHER ENTITIES THAT ARE
ATTEMPTING TO COMPLY WITH THE
CARB REGULATIONS, IT SIMPLY
WOULDN'T BE POSSIBLE TO BUILD
THREE OF THESE BOATS IN THE NEXT
YEAR, THIS BILL WILL ALLOW SAP
TO COLLECT THE FUNDING IN
ADVANCE AND BUILD THE STATION
BOATS. ONE AT A TIME, WE WOULD
BE ABLE TO BUILD ONE BOAT
APPROXIMATELY EVERY THREE YEARS.
UTILIZING THE PILOT BOAT
SURCHARGE, WHICH IS A SURCHARGE
ADDED TO THE PILOT FEE. PILOTAGE
FEE THAT EVERY SHIP CALLING IT
SAN FRANCISCO BAY PORTS PAYS,
THAT THAT SURCHARGE COLLECTS
APPROXIMATELY $6 MILLION A YEAR.
SO APPROXIMATELY EVERY THREE
YEARS, WE WOULD HAVE ENOUGH
MONEY TO BUILD A NEW BOAT
WITHOUT FINANCING IT, THIS WOULD
SAVE THE INDUSTRY APPROXIMATELY
$20 MILLION OR MORE IN FINANCE
CHARGES. IT'S INDUSTRY THAT
ULTIMATELY PAYS FOR THESE
VESSELS, THIS BILL WOULD ALSO
ALLOW THE INDUSTRY TO RECEIVE
THE BENEFIT OF THEIR PREVIOUS
INVESTMENT IN THE EXISTING
VESSELS BY ALLOWING THE EXISTING
VESSELS TO SERVE OUT THEIR
USEFUL SERVICE LIFE, THE BILL IS
VERY NARROWLY TAILORED. WE
SPECIFICALLY NAME THE VESSELS IN
THE BILL SO THAT THERE CAN'T BE
ANY KIND OF BLEED OVER, ALLOWING
UNINTENDED, BENEFICIARIES OF
THIS BILL TO DELAY THEIR OWN
CARB COMPLIANCE, THE SAN
FRANCISCO BAR PILOTS ARE, AS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAYSON
MENTIONED, ARE STATUTORILY
MANDATED TO PROVIDE THIS SERVICE
STATUTORILY MANDATED TO MAINTAIN
A BOAT ON STATION OUTSIDE OF THE
GOLDEN GATE AT ALL TIMES, 24
HOURS A DAY, SEVEN DAYS A WEEK.
IN ORDER TO DO THIS, WE NEED
THESE THREE BOATS OPERATIONAL.
IT'S SIMPLY NOT, FEASIBLE TO
TAKE THEM OFFLINE WHILE WE BUILD
NEW BOATS. SO THIS BILL WILL
ALLOW US TO MAINTAIN THAT
CRITICAL SERVICE THAT IS
REQUIRED TO KEEP TRADE COMING IN
AND OUT OF PORTS IN THE NINE BAY
AREA PORTS. CARB DOES HAVE
EXTENSIONS WITHIN ITS FRAMEWORK.
THOSE EXTENSIONS AREN'T
SUFFICIENT TO ALLOW SAN
FRANCISCO BAR PILOTS TO
UNDERTAKE A BUILD PROJECT OF
THIS SIZE, THE EXTENSIONS ARE 1
OR 2 YEARS IN LENGTH ONLY, AND
CARB WON'T EXCEED THOSE, THOSE
AMOUNTS. AND WITH A BUILD
PROJECT THAT EXCEEDS $66
MILLION, IT'S JUST NOT FEASIBLE
TO OPERATE THAT THAT PROJECT, TO
UNDERTAKE THAT PROJECT. WITH THE
UNCERTAINTY OF WHETHER OR NOT
WE'LL BE ABLE TO GET ANOTHER
EXTENSION EACH AND EVERY YEAR,
BUT AND SO, IN SUM, THIS BILL
ALLOWS SAN FRANCISCO BAR PILOTS
TO ATTAIN COMPLIANCE, WITH CARB
REGULATIONS. IT JUST DOES SO ON
A, ON A TIMELINE THAT'S
FEASIBLE, AND SO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING, MR. CHAIRMAN. MIKE
JACOB WITH PACIFIC MERCHANT
SHIPPING ASSOCIATION. AND WE
REPRESENT OCEAN CARRIERS. SO WE
REPRESENT THE CUSTOMERS OF THE
PILOTS. AND WE WANT TO THANK,
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GRAYSON FOR THE
WORK ON THIS, GOING BACK TO LAST
SESSION, WE WORKED ON TRYING TO
GET EVERYTHING PUT TOGETHER. SO
WE COULD GO THROUGH THIS PROCESS
IN A PROSPECTIVE MANNER AND
BEGIN TO BUILD THOSE FUNDS
NECESSARY TO REPLACE THE
VESSELS, WHICH IS MR. BALDWIN
POINTED OUT, ARE PART OF OUR
COMPULSORY PILOTAGE SYSTEM. SO
THAT'S A THAT'S A TWO WAY STREET
AS THE CUSTOMERS BASICALLY, YOU
KNOW, WE'RE REPRESENTING OCEAN
CARRIERS THAT ARE COMING TO THE
PORT OF OAKLAND, PORT OF SAN
FRANCISCO, PORT OF REDWOOD CITY,
STOCKTON, SACRAMENTO. WE CANNOT
ACCESS THOSE PORTS LAWFULLY
WITHOUT ACCESS TO A PILOT. AND
THE ONLY WAY TO ACCESS A PILOT
IF THE PILOT STATION IS WITH ONE
OF THESE VESSELS, THE VESSELS
WILL NOT BE COMPLETED ON JANUARY
1ST, 2025. THEY WON'T EVEN BE
ORDERED YET. AND IF THEY ARE
ORDERED, THE ENGINES WON'T BE
READY. SO WHAT WE'RE ASKING FOR
IS A WAY TO ACTUALLY PLAN FOR
COMPLIANCE, WE THINK AS STATED
IN THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS, IT
WAS VERY, VERY CLEAR THAT
THERE'S ALREADY A PROCESS. THE
CARB HAS PUT TOGETHER FOR MEN
MANAGING THAT TYPE OF COMPLIANCE
ON AN AD HOC, ONE OFF BASIS ON A
YEAR TO TWO YEAR SCHEDULE. AS
MR. BALDWIN POINTED OUT, WHAT
WE'RE ASKING FOR IS SOMETHING A
LITTLE MORE COMPREHENSIVE A
GLIDE PATH FOR COMPLIANCE THAT'S
PLANNED, THAT GOES FORWARD AND
MATCHES WITH OUR FINANCING THAT
WE ALREADY HAVE AUTHORIZED UNDER
THE BILL THAT MR. GRAYSON,
AUTHORED FOR US AND WAS
SUPPORTED BY THE LEGISLATURE.
TWO YEARS AGO. SO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. WE APPRECIATE YOUR
CONSIDERATION. I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS. OKAY ALL
RIGHT. LET'S, LET'S ASK, OTHER
FOLKS WHO WANT TO SUPPORT THE
BILL TO COME TO THE MICROPHONE
AND EXPRESS SUPPORT. ALL RIGHT.
YES BALTHASAR CORNEJO WITH
BROWNSTEIN ON BEHALF OF THE BAY
AREA COUNCIL IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT. OPPOSITION
FOLKS, YOU WANT TO RAISE
CONCERNS ABOUT THE BILL? SORRY.
IT'S ME AGAIN, THERESA BOWIE
WITH PACIFIC ENVIRONMENT. YOU
KNOW, WHILE WE ARE SYMPATHETIC
TO, THE SPONSORS OF THE BILL,
THE ASSEMBLY ALREADY THE
LEGISLATURE ALREADY KILLED ONE
BILL THIS YEAR THAT WAS
PROPOSING TO EXEMPT JUST ONE
VESSEL FOR 15 YEARS, AB 3153
WERE VERY CONCERNED WITH HOW
THIS WOULD SET A TERRIBLE
PRECEDENCE, AND THAT OTHER
INDUSTRIES WOULD ALSO SEEK
EXEMPTIONS OR EXTENSIONS AND
DELAYS THAT WOULD UNDERMINE THE
COMMERCIAL HARBOR CRAFT RULE. MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THE TWO
BIGGEST CONCERNS WITH THE,
SPONSORS IS THAT THE COSTS, AS
WELL AS THE SHIPYARDS, IN TERMS
OF THE COSTS, WE ARE SUPPORTING
SB 295 BY SENATOR DODD. THAT
WOULD ALLOW, THE SPONSORS TO
RAISE THE PILOTAGE RATE, AND
THEN, WERE, YOU KNOW, CARB
ALREADY ALLOWS FOR TWO YEAR
EXTENSIONS THAT ARE RENEWABLE SO
THEY CAN RENEW IT EVERY TWO
YEARS WHILE THEY'RE FIXING THE,
THE, ADDRESSING THE SHIPYARD AND
AS I MENTIONED EARLIER, WE SAW
THE FIRST ELECTRIC TUGBOAT IN
SAN DIEGO LAST WEEK. NEXT WEEK
WE'RE GOING TO SEE THE FIRST
HYDROGEN FUEL CELL FERRY
LAUNCHING AT THE PORT OF SAN
FRANCISCO. SO, YOU KNOW, THE
TECHNOLOGY IS ALREADY COMING
INTO PLACE THANKS TO THE HARBOR
CRAFT RULE. AND WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT, THAT THESE BILLS ARE
NOT GOING TO UNDERMINE CARB'S
ABILITY TO REGULATE AND
IMPLEMENT THE HARBOR CRAFT RULE,
AND ALL THE EMISSIONS BENEFITS,
THANKS TO THIS RULE. AS I
MENTIONED BEFORE, HARBOR CRAFT
IS THE ONE OF THE TOP THREE
CANCER CAUSING EMISSIONS AT THE
PORTS THEMSELVES. SO AGAIN, WE
HOPE THAT YOU, WOULD HOLD THIS
BILL, THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
ATTENTION. YEAH, BUT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT THREE VOTES HERE,
RIGHT? YES, BUT IT WILL GO TILL
2030 AND 2040. AND AGAIN, WE
THINK THAT THERE ARE CARB
ALREADY. IS THAT REALLY. I'M
SORRY. IS THAT REALLY THE CASE
THAT. NO, NO. THE I THINK
RESPECTFULLY THAT MISS BOWIE'S
CONFUSED ABOUT WHAT WE'RE ASKING
FOR, WHAT WE'RE ASKING FOR IS
THE ABILITY TO USE THESE BOATS
UNTIL THEIR USEFUL SERVICE LIFE
HAS ENDED. TWO OF THESE BOATS
WERE BUILT IN 2020. THEY'RE
USEFUL IN 20. IN 2000. SORRY,
THEIR USEFUL SERVICE LIFE IS
EXPECTED TO BE 30 YEARS. SO
THOSE BOATS HAVE ABOUT SIX YEARS
LEFT ON THEIR USEFUL SERVICE
LIFE. AND WE ANTICIPATE THAT
THEY WOULD BE RETIRED. BOTH OF
THOSE BOATS WITHIN SIX YEARS. WE
ANTICIPATE BEING ABLE TO BUILD
ONE BOAT EVERY THREE YEARS. SO
WITHIN SIX YEARS WE OUGHT TO
HAVE TWO BOATS BUILT AND
OPERATING THAT ARE CARB
COMPLIANT. AND THE THIRD ONE
WITHIN AN ADDITIONAL THREE
YEARS. SO AT MOST WHAT WE'RE
LOOKING AT IS PROBABLY NINE
YEARS OF EXTENSION ON ONE OF THE
BOATS, THREE YEARS EXTENSION ON
ONE, SIX YEARS ON THE OTHER.
IT'S NOT GUARANTEED. RIGHT. IS
THAT IS THAT THAT'S YOUR
ESSENTIAL POINT? YEAH. UNDER NO
CIRCUMSTANCES ARE WE LOOKING AT
2040. THE THIRD BOAT WAS BUILT
IN 2010. SO IT'S USEFUL. SERVICE
LIFE IS MAYBE 20 YEARS. I DON'T
KNOW, WITH A GOOD ENOUGH
MECHANIC. WE GOT A GOOD
MECHANIC. WE CAN STRETCH IT OUT,
BUT I DON'T. WE'RE TRYING TO
REDUCE WASTE AND RECYCLE HERE.
OKAY. ALL RIGHT, I'M GOING TO
SUPPORT THE BILL. I MEAN, I BUT
I, I, YOU KNOW, I UNDERSTAND
THERE'S A SLIPPERY SLOPE
ARGUMENT HERE. I THINK THAT
YOU'RE ESSENTIALLY MAKING. AND I
THINK IT'S ULTIMATELY UP TO, TO
US TO ENSURE THAT WHILE WE'RE
PROVIDING A VERY NARROW,
FLEXIBILITY HERE, YOU KNOW, THIS
DOESN'T MEAN THAT THERE'S ANY
INTEREST ON THE PART OF THIS
COMMITTEE TO OPEN, THE, THE
FLOODGATES ON, ON THIS ISSUE
MORE BROADLY, SO I'M, I
RECOGNIZE HOW NARROW THIS IS,
AND I'M WILLING TO SUPPORT IT
WHEN WE HAVE A MOTION. BUT BUT I
DO I THINK YOU'RE YOU'RE RIGHT
TO COME IN AND RAISE THESE
CONCERNS. TERESA. YEAH. OKAY.
ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU. OTHER
OPPOSITION, YEAH. SO, SOPHIA,
THE COALITION FOR CLEAN AIR IN
OPPOSITION. REBECCA. MARCUS
REPRESENTING THE UNION OF
CONCERNED SCIENTISTS, OPPOSED.
THANK YOU. AND MARK FENSTERMAKER
FOR EARTHJUSTICE. OPPOSED. I
MEAN, ESSENTIALLY, THE
OPPOSITION IS ALL RELATED TO
WHAT MISS BOWIE WAS BRINGING UP.
OKAY, OKAY. THANK YOU, I
APPRECIATE IT. I'LL LET YOU
CLOSE. THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. I
DO WANT TO EXPRESS MY
APPRECIATION. GRATITUDE TOWARD
THE COMMITTEE AND THEIR
ANALYSIS, AS WELL AS YOUR YOUR
LENS AND PERSPECTIVE AS WELL.
AND I DO APPRECIATE THE VOICE OF
OPPOSITION, WHICH IS VERY, VERY
IMPORTANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
REACH OUR GOALS AND WE FOLLOW
REGULATIONS AS HANDED DOWN BY
CARB, WHICH IS ONE REASON WHY
THE BILL IS INCREDIBLY
PRESCRIPTIVE, EVEN TO THE NAMING
OF THE BOATS, AS WELL AS THE
FACT THAT WE'RE NOT ASKING
ASKING FOR AN EXEMPTION, BUT AN
EXTENSION JUST FOR THE LIFE OF
THE BOATS WITH THE, THE ULTIMATE
GOAL OF THREE YEARS EACH. AS FAR
AS A BUILD OUT, THESE ARE NOT
BOATS YOU CAN ORDER FROM AMAZON,
NOR CAN YOU GO TO THE NEAREST
SPORTS STORE AND PULL OFF THE
LOT WITH A TRAILER. THESE ARE
BOATS THAT REQUIRE EXTENSIVE
DESIGN AND WORK, AND TAKE YEARS
TO BE ABLE TO BUILD AND PUT IN
PLACE AND PUT INTO PLACE. SO
WITH THAT, WE GREATLY APPRECIATE
THE WORK OF THE OF THE
COMMITTEE, AND I WILL
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME. THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU, THANK
YOU. SAME MEMBER. COME ON UP.
OKAY. ALL RIGHT. GOOD GOOD. YOU
MAY PROCEED. THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR, GOOD MORNING. I'M HERE TO
PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL 2958,
WHICH WOULD COMPENSATE LOCAL AIR
DISTRICT REPRESENTATIVES ON THE
GOVERNING BOARD OF THE
CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES BOARD.
EXISTING LAW UNFAIRLY PROHIBITS
THE COMPENSATION OF SIX AIR
DISTRICT REPRESENTATIVES. THIS
PROHIBITION DOES NOT APPLY TO
OTHER VOTING BOARD MEMBERS WHO
HAVE SIMILAR DUTIES AND RECEIVE
AN ANNUAL SALARY, LIMITING THESE
BOARD MEMBERS COMPENSATION
DISCREDITS THE UNIQUE LOCAL
PERSPECTIVE THEY BRING TO CARB'S
PROGRAMS. AB 2958 WOULD ENSURE
PAY PARITY BY COMPENSATING LOCAL
AIR DISTRICT REPRESENTATIVES IN
THE SAME MANNER AS OTHER VOTING
REPRESENTATIVES. WITH ME IN
SUPPORT OF AB 2958 IS ALAN ABBS,
ON BEHALF OF THE BAY AREA AIR
QUALITY MANAGEMENT DISTRICT AND
DEREK ALATORRE ON BEHALF OF THE
SOUTH COAST AIR QUALITY
MANAGEMENT DISTRICT. GOOD
MORNING. CHAIR, MY NAME IS DEREK
ALATORRE. I'M DEPUTY EXECUTIVE
OFFICER FOR LEGISLATIVE, PUBLIC
AFFAIRS AND MEDIA AT SOUTH COAST
AQMD WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
AB 2958 AND SERVE AS THE BILL'S
SPONSOR. AS THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
STATED, THE BILL WOULD ALLOW
CARD BOARD MEMBERS REPRESENTING
AIR DISTRICTS TO START RECEIVING
THE SAME COMPENSATION AS OTHER
VOTING CARB BOARD MEMBERS.
PARITY. CURRENTLY, THERE IS AN
EXTREME AND UNFAIR IMBALANCE
REGARDING COMPENSATION FOR CARB
BOARD MEMBERS. THE AIR DISTRICT
BOARD MEMBERS GET AT THE MAXIMUM
20% OF WHAT THE OTHER VOTING
CARD MEMBERS GET, EXCLUDING THE
CHAIR VOTING BOARD MEMBERS WHO
DO NOT REPRESENT OUR LOCAL AIR
DISTRICTS RECEIVE UP TO OVER
$50,000 A YEAR. IN CONTRAST, THE
SIX BOARD MEMBERS THAT REPRESENT
AIR DISTRICTS RECEIVED JUST THE
PER DIEM FOR THE MEETINGS THAT
THEY ATTEND. SINCE THERE IS NO
DIFFERENCE IN THE JOB PERFORMED,
THERE SHOULD BE PAY EQUITY AND
FOR AMONGST THE VOTING, ALL OF
THE VOTING MEMBERS AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL, AIR DISTRICT BOARD
MEMBERS THROUGHOUT THE STATE
RECEIVE A NOMINAL COMPENSATION
FOR THEIR HARD WORK CLEANING THE
AIR AND PROTECTING THE PUBLIC
HEALTH. THESE DEDICATED PUBLIC
SERVANTS HAVE ESSENTIAL DUTIES
TO PERFORM AS ELECTED OFFICIALS,
OR ARE PRIVATE CITIZENS WITH
EXISTING CAREERS. MINIMAL
COMPENSATION AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
ALREADY MAKES IT HARDER AND MORE
DIFFICULT TO BALANCE EXISTING
PROFESSIONAL AND PERSONAL
OBLIGATIONS, WITH DUTIES
REQUIRED TO SERVE THEIR
COMMUNITIES. THESE BURDENS ARE
COMPOUNDED BY THE LACK OF
COMPENSATION FOR THOSE WHO
ANSWER THE CALL TO SERVE ON
CARB. AB 2958 COULD FACILITATE
MORE DIVERSE PARTICIPATION ON
THE BOARD. THUS, WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST THAT I VOTE FOR THIS
IMPORTANT BILL. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING, CHAIR ALAN,
MY NAME IS ALAN ABS. I'M THE
LEGISLATIVE OFFICER WITH THE BAY
AREA AIR QUALITY MANAGEMENT
DISTRICT. MY COUNTERPART, PRETTY
MUCH COVERED EVERYTHING THAT
NEEDS TO BE SAID. I'LL JUST GIVE
A VERY BRIEF, LOCAL PERSPECTIVE
FROM THE BAY AREA AQMD. WE HAVE
24 BOARD MEMBERS ON OUR BOARD
ABOUT EQUALLY SPLIT BETWEEN
COUNTY SUPERVISORS AND CITY
COUNCIL MEMBERS. MANY OF THOSE
CITY COUNCIL MEMBERS REPRESENT
VERY SMALL CITIES IN THE BAY
AREA. THEY GET LITTLE TO NO
COMPENSATION FOR SERVING AS A
CITY COUNCIL MEMBER, THEN GET
LITTLE TO NO COMPENSATION FOR
SERVING ON THE BAY AREA AQMD AND
THEN ONE LUCKY MEMBER GETS TO
ALSO HAVE ALMOST A, YOU KNOW, A
PRETTY FULL, JOB REPRESENTING
THE AIR DISTRICT ON THE
CARDBOARD. AND SO IN SOME CASES,
YOU KNOW, WE HAVE PEOPLE DOING A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF WORK
SUPPORTING THEIR LOCAL COMMUNITY
AS AN ELECTED OFFICIAL AND THEN
SUPPORTING LOCAL AIR QUALITY
POLICIES AND THEN STATEWIDE AIR
QUALITY POLICIES. AND SO WE
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO
RECOGNIZE THE WORK THAT THEY DO
AND COMPENSATE THEM EQUALLY WITH
OTHER CARDBOARD MEMBERS. AND SO
I'D RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE, VOTE. YEAH. OKAY. THANK YOU
FOLKS WANT TO RAISE A VOICE
SUPPORT FOR THE BILL.
GOOD MORNING, MR. CHAIR. AND
MEMBERS, MARCUS DETWILER WITH
THE CALIFORNIA SPECIAL DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. YES, SIR. HELLO,
CHAIR. AND MEMBERS, KEVIN SHIVE,
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA AIR
POLLUTION CONTROL OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT, LET'S
HEAR FROM. YEAH YES, SIR. SORRY
ABOUT THAT. JARED MOSS, ON
BEHALF OF THE SACRAMENTO AIR
QUALITY SUPPORT. OKAY. ALL
RIGHT, OPPOSITION CONCERNS ABOUT
THE BILL. IS THAT YOU. KNOW,
OKAY, YOU'RE GOING OUT. YOU'VE
HAD ENOUGH. OKAY ALL RIGHT.
YEAH. IT'S BEEN A LONG DAY
ALREADY. OKAY NO OPPOSITION. I
SUPPORT THE BILL. I AM AWARE OF
THIS ISSUE, AND WE'LL WE'LL,
TAKE A MOTION WHEN WE HAVE MORE
MEMBERS. SO THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
MR. CHAIR. YEAH. OKAY, LET'S
HEAR FROM MEMBER PAPPIN WHO'S
GOT, PRESENTING TWO BILLS TO THE
COMMITTEE.
HEY, YOU MAY PROCEED. ONE READY?
CHAIR. HOW ARE YOU? YES, YES.
YOU KNOW, ALL ALONE, WELL, WITH
SOME WONDERFUL PEOPLE. THAT'S A
WONDERFUL PEOPLE. GOOD MORNING.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE. WHICH
ONE WOULD YOU LIKE? ME? LET'S
START WITH 1359. YOU GOT IT.
GREAT SO THIS ONE IS ABOUT,
GEOTHERMAL ENERGY. AND IT
PRESENTS A TREMENDOUS
OPPORTUNITY FOR GREEN ENERGY. AB
1359 IS A REALLY SIMPLE BILL
THAT WILL JUMP START GEOTHERMAL
ENERGY PRODUCTION IN CALIFORNIA.
IT FOCUSES ON MAKING THE CEQA
PERMITTING PROCESS OF
EXPLORATORY WELLS, LOCAL LOCAL
EXPLORATORY WELLS, IT REPEALS
THE REQUIREMENT THAT CAL GEM BE
THE LEAD AGENCY TO DO A SEQUEL
REVIEW OF EXPLORATORY WELLS BY
WAY OF BACKGROUND BEFORE
DEVELOPMENT OF A GEOTHERMAL
FIELD CAN BE IN EARNEST, THE
DEVELOPER NEEDS TO DRILL
EXPLORATORY WELLS TO GATHER DATA
AND CONFIRM PROJECT FEASIBILITY.
UNDER SEQUA, THE EXPLORATION
PHASE AND THE BUILDING PHASE AND
THE BUILDING GEOTHERMAL FIELD
ARE TREATED AS TWO SEPARATE
PROJECTS. SO NOW WE'RE ONLY
DEALING WITH THE EXPLORATORY
EXPLORATION PHASE.
UNFORTUNATELY, AN OLD MISGUIDED
PROVISION OF THE LAW DESIGNATES
THE STATE GEOLOGICAL ENERGY
MANAGEMENT DIVISION, OR CAL GEM,
AS THE LEAD AGENCY FOR SEQUA FOR
EXPLORATORY WELLS RATHER THAN A
LOCAL AGENCY ACTING AS THE LEAD.
THIS PROVISION WAS INTENDED TO
STREAMLINE THE PROCESS AND GET
GEOTHERMAL PLANTS ONLINE FASTER,
BUT WHAT'S ENDED UP HAPPENING IS
WITH PROJECTS LANGUISHING IN CAL
CHEN PURGATORY BEFORE THEY CAN
EVEN BEGIN. COUNTIES ALREADY
TYPICALLY SERVE AS THE LEAD
AGENCY ON THE GEOTHERMAL FIELD
AND ARE WELL EQUIPPED TO SERVE
AS THE LEAD ON THE EXPLORATORY
WELLS. IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE
THIS BILL WILL NOT WEAKEN CEQA
IN ANY WAY. IN FACT, THIS MAY BE
THE ONLY CEQA BILL IN WHICH THE
SPONSORS WANT TO BE TREATED.
JUST LIKE EVERY OTHER CEQA
PROJECT. BY HAVING THE
EXPLORATORY CEQA SUBMISSIONS
REVIEWED LOCALLY HERE TO TESTIFY
WITH ME TODAY IS KATE
BRANDENBURG. ON BEHALF OF SONOMA
CLEAN POWER. THANK GOOD MORNING.
THANK YOU, CHAIRMAN, AND THANK
YOU, ASSEMBLY MEMBER PAPAN FOR
CARRYING THIS BILL. MY NAME IS
KATE BRANDENBURG AND I REPRESENT
SONOMA CLEAN POWER. SONOMA CLEAN
POWER IS A COMMUNITY OWNED POWER
PROVIDER FOR BOTH SONOMA AND
MENDOCINO COUNTIES, SONOMA IS
REALLY PROUD THAT WE ARE AHEAD
OF THE CURVE ON CLEAN ENERGY. WE
ACTUALLY PROCURE, ABOUT 90%
CLEAN ENERGY AS OUR PORTFOLIO AT
THIS TIME. BUT WHAT'S HAPPENING
WITH, WITH ENERGY IS THAT DURING
THE EVENING. SO NIGHT TIME AND
ALSO IN THE WINTER, WE DO NOT
HAVE A SUN OR WIND AT TIMES. AND
SO WE'RE HAVING TO RELY ON
NATURAL GAS JUST LIKE THE REST
OF THE STATE. AND WE'RE PAYING
FOR NATURAL GAS WHEN WE'RE NOT
USING IT. AND THE COSTS ARE
GOING ARE EXTREMELY HIGH. AND SO
OUR ANALYSTS LOOKED AT THE ISSUE
IS HOW DO WE SOLVE THIS. AND
WHAT THEY CAME UP, CAME UP WITH
IS THAT, NEXT GENERATION
GEOTHERMAL IS ONE OF THE
SOLUTIONS. IT'S NOT THE
SOLUTION, BUT IT'S ONE OF THEM.
AND AS WE STARTED LOOKING INTO
IT, SONOMA CLEAN POWER HAS A GEO
ZONE INITIATIVE THAT OUR PLAN IS
TO BUILD 600MW OF GEOTHERMAL,
NEW GENERATION OR NEXT
GENERATION IS WHAT THEY'RE
CALLING IT. AND THIS WE HAVE
FOUND, IS VERY AFFORDABLE. IT IS
RELIABLE, IT'S CLEAN, FIRM
ENERGY RESOURCES. AND, IT IS
ALSO RESILIENT TO NATURAL
DISASTERS. IT'S ONE THAT AS WITH
GEOTHERMAL RIGHT NOW, YOU CAN
TURN IT. YOU KNOW, WITH NEXT
GENERATION GEOTHERMAL YOU'LL BE
ABLE TO TURN IT ON OR OFF WHEN
NEEDED. AND SO THERE'S A VARIETY
OF DIFFERENT, ASPECTS TO NEXT
GENERATION GEOTHERMAL. AND THE
US DEPARTMENT OF ENERGY CAME UP
WITH A REPORT RECENTLY THAT SAID
ON AFFORDABILITY. THE REPORT
HIGHLIGHTED THE STUDY THAT FOUND
THAT THE AGGRESSIVE DEPLOYMENT
OF NEXT GENERATION GEOTHERMAL
POWER COULD LOWER THE COST OF
DECARBONIZING THE WESTERN GRID
AS MUCH AS 25% COMPARED WITH THE
STATUS QUO. AND SO, YOU KNOW,
UNFORTUNATELY, AS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER PAPPIN MENTIONED, THAT
THERE IS AN ISSUE WITH, EXISTING
STATUTE WHERE CAL JAM IS THE
LEAD AGENCY. AND THIS WAS
SOMETHING THAT WAS BROUGHT ABOUT
IN THE 70S. NOW WE'RE LOOKING AT
IT AND WE WOULD LIKE TO JUST BE
RECOGNIZED AS EVERYONE ELSE,
SON, YOU KNOW, FOR SOLAR, FOR
WIND PROJECTS, FOR OIL AND GAS
PROJECTS, WE WOULD LIKE TO HAVE
THE LEAD AGENCY, BE THE LOCAL,
LOCAL AGENCY, BE THE LEAD AGENCY
ON THIS, AND, THE ONE THING I
WOULD LIKE TO POINT OUT IS,
SINCE THE STATE ADOPTED THE 100%
CLEAN ENERGY GOAL IN 2018, CAL
GEM HAS ISSUED ZERO APPROVALS
FOR NEW GEOTHERMAL EXPLORATION
AND IMPERIAL COUNTY, THOUGH
BECAUSE OF THE WAY THE STATUTE
IS DRAFTED, THEY HAVE IT IN
THEIR GENERAL PLAN TO BE ABLE
TO, SITE AND BE THE LEAD AGENCY
FOR GEOTHERMAL PLANTS. AND SO
THEY HAVE THROUGHOUT, APPROVED
MANY EXPLORATION PROJECTS FOR
GEOTHERMAL, UNLIKE ANYWHERE ELSE
IN THE STATE, BECAUSE THEY HAVE
THE ABILITY TO BE THE LEAD
AGENCY. SO JUST STRAIGHTFORWARD,
AB 1359 JUST MAKES IT THE SAME.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU.
OTHER FOLKS WANT TO VOICE
SUPPORT FOR THE BILL. GOOD
MORNING. KENDRA HARRIS WITH THE
CLIMATE CENTER IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU, MR. CHAIR. MARK
FENSTERMAKER FROM PENINSULA
CLEAN ENERGY AND STRONG SUPPORT.
FOR SOLAR HERE ON BEHALF OF
MENDOCINO COUNTY IN SUPPORT.
GREAT. ALL RIGHT. OPPOSITION.
ANYONE WANTS TO RAISE CONCERNS.
ALL RIGHT. SEEING NONE. WE'LL
WE'LL ENTERTAIN A MOTION WHEN,
WHEN WE HAVE MORE MEMBERS. BUT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
ALL RIGHT, LET'S LET'S MOVE TO
YOUR NEXT BILL, WHICH IS, 1921.
MAYBE 1921. THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR, AB 1921 IS A SIMPLE BILL
THAT WILL INCLUDE LINEAR
GENERATORS IN RFPS.
SPECIFICALLY, THE BILL UPDATES
AND CLARIFIES THE DEFINITION OF
A RENEWABLE ELECTRICAL
GENERATION FACILITY TO INCLUDE
LINEAR GENERATORS USING RPS
ELIGIBLE FUELS. LINEAR
GENERATORS ARE CUTTING EDGE
TECHNOLOGY THAT OFFERS A
TREMENDOUS OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE
RENEWABLE POWER. AT THE FLIP OF
A SWITCH, THEY CAN RUN ON A
NUMBER OF DIFFERENT FUELS, JUST
LIKE FUEL CELLS, WHICH ARE
ALREADY INCLUDED IN RPS. IF
LINEAR GENERATORS REMAIN
EXCLUDED FROM RPS, THE STATE
WILL HAVE A SORELY LACKING
PORTFOLIO OF ON DEMAND POWER. AS
WE APPROACH OUR 2045 DEADLINE.
AB 1921 WILL ESTABLISH
TECHNOLOGICAL PARITY AND HELP
MEET THE STATE'S RENEWABLE
ENERGY GOALS. HERE TO TESTIFY
WITH ME TODAY IS KENT LEACOCK
WITH MAINSPRING ENERGY. GREAT.
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. KENT
LEACOCK, ON BEHALF OF
MAINSPRING. AND I'D LIKE TO
THANK THE STAFF FOR THEIR
COMPREHENSIVE AND THOROUGH
ANALYSIS AND I'M GLAD TO BE HERE
TO ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE. THANK
YOU. OKAY. THANK YOU. FOLKS. YOU
WANT TO VOICE SUPPORT FOR THE
BILL? GOOD MORNING, MATT
KLOPFENSTEIN. ON BEHALF OF THE
BIOENERGY ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. GREAT
GOOD MORNING, MEGAN MURRAY, ON
BEHALF OF PROLOGIS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING, ALFREDO
ARREDONDO, ON BEHALF OF THE
GREEN HYDROGEN COALITION IN
SUPPORT. GREAT, GOOD. ONE MORE.
SORRY. GOOD MORNING. I'M ALLISON
HILLIARD WITH THE MICROGRID
RESOURCES COALITION HERE IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT, OPPOSITION FOLKS WANT
TO RAISE CONCERN ABOUT THE BILL.
ALL RIGHT. SEEING NONE. THANK
YOU. WE'LL ONCE AGAIN, YOU KNOW,
OBVIOUSLY, I'M GOING TO SUPPORT
THE BILL. APPRECIATE IT. THANK
YOU, SENATOR ALLEN. THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT. HOW'S IT GOING,
SENATOR BERMAN? ITEM 11. THIS
IS, AB 2083. GOOD MORNING, MR.
CHAIR. HOW ARE YOU, SIR? WELL,
I'M, YOU KNOW, HANGING IN. OH,
GOOD. IT'S BEEN A WILD COUPLE
DAYS. BEAT THE HEAT. NOTHING
GOING ON. YEAH, NOTHING GOING ON
VERY SLOW TIME IN SACRAMENTO,
MR. CHAIR. I WOULD LIKE TO BEGIN
BY THANKING THE COMMITTEE STAFF
FOR THEIR WORK ON THIS BILL. I
WILL BE ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE'S AMENDMENTS DESCRIBED
IN THE ANALYSIS. INDUSTRIAL
EMISSIONS MAKE UP 23% OF
CALIFORNIA'S GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS, WHICH IS THE SECOND
LARGEST SOURCE BEHIND
TRANSPORTATION. WHILE THE STATE
CONTINUES TO BE A LEADER IN
TRANSITIONING FROM COMBUSTION TO
ZERO EMISSION TECHNOLOGIES AND
THE ELECTRICITY AND
TRANSPORTATION SECTORS,
INDUSTRIAL EMISSIONS HAVE
LARGELY REMAINED UNADDRESSED. AB
2083 IS A KEY FIRST STEP FOR
CALIFORNIA TO MODERNIZE
INDUSTRIAL MANUFACTURING AND
PLAN FOR HOW THE INDUSTRIAL
SECTOR WILL REDUCE ITS
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS. THIS
BILL WOULD TASK THE CALIFORNIA
AIR RESOURCES BOARD AS A PART OF
THE NEXT UPDATE OF THEIR SCOPING
PLAN TO ASSESS THE KEY
STRATEGIES THE INDUSTRIAL
MANUFACTURING SECTOR CAN
UNDERTAKE TO CUT ITS EMISSIONS
IN LINE WITH CALIFORNIA'S
EXISTING CARBON NEUTRALITY
REQUIREMENTS. ADDITIONALLY, IT
WOULD REQUIRE THE CALIFORNIA
ENERGY COMMISSION TO EVALUATE
THE POTENTIAL TO ELECTRIFY
CERTAIN INDUSTRIAL HEAT
PROCESSES AND REQUIRE CARB TO
INCORPORATE THAT EVALUATION INTO
ITS ASSESSMENT. AMENDMENTS TAKEN
IN SENATE ENERGY UTILITIES AND
COMMUNICATIONS COMMITTEE REMOVED
ALL OPPOSITION FROM THE BILL.
I'M ALWAYS A LITTLE NERVOUS WHEN
THERE'S NO OPPOSITION. I FEEL
LIKE A LITTLE OPPOSITION IS GOOD
FOR YOU, BUT HERE WE ARE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE, AND WITH ME TODAY ARE MARK
FENSTERMAKER ON BEHALF OF
EARTHJUSTICE AND KAYLA ROBINSON
ON BEHALF OF INDUSTRIOUS LABS.
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. MARK
FENSTERMAKER FOR EARTHJUSTICE,
PROUD CO-SPONSOR OF THE BILL. AS
MR. BERMAN LAID OUT INDUSTRIAL
SOURCES ARE A SIGNIFICANT
PROPORTION OF OUR GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS. IN ADDITION, THEY ARE
A SOURCE OF TOXIC AIR
CONTAMINANTS DRIVING OUR POOR
AIR QUALITY IN CERTAIN PARTS OF
THE STATE, SO WE REALLY
APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEE STAFF
FOR THEIR AMENDMENT AND THEIR
WORK ON ENSURING THERE IS SOME
SCOPE ON AIR QUALITY AS THIS
PLAN GETS PUT TOGETHER. WE
REALLY WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
OUR INDUSTRIAL SECTOR, OUR
MANUFACTURING STAYS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA, BUT HAS THE PLAN,
HAS THE TOOLS IN PLACE TO
TRANSITION TOWARDS ZERO EMISSION
TECHNOLOGIES. I REALLY WANT TO
APPRECIATE MR. BERMAN'S WORK
OVER THE LAST 18 MONTHS ON THIS
ISSUE, AND STICKING WITH TRYING
TO FIND THE RIGHT SOLUTION AND
GET ALL, SIDES OF THIS EQUATION
FIGURED OUT. SO THANK YOU SO
MUCH. WE ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU. MARK. THANK YOU. YES
MA'AM, GOOD MORNING, MR. CHAIR.
KAYLA ROBINSON, ON BEHALF OF
INDUSTRIOUS LABS, I'LL KEEP IT
SHORT AND ECHO. WHAT MY
COLLEAGUE MARK SAID. BUT JUST
WANT TO THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR
ALL THEIR WORK ON THIS BILL, AS
WELL AS ASSEMBLYMEMBER BERMAN
FOR CHAMPIONING THIS ISSUE AND
JUST CLOSE WITH SAYING THAT THIS
BILL WILL ULTIMATELY STRENGTHEN
CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY AND REALLY
SET UP THE INDUSTRIAL SECTOR FOR
DECARBONIZING TOWARDS 2045. SO
THANK YOU SO MUCH. ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE. GREAT. ALL RIGHT. OTHER
FOLKS WANT TO COME TO THE MIC
AND VOICE SUPPORT FOR THE BILL.
DARRYL LIDDLE WITH NRDC IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING
AARON WITH CALIFORNIA ADVISORS
ON BEHALF OF ANTORA IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING, JACOB
EVANS WITH SIERRA CLUB
CALIFORNIA, IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. GREAT. CONGRATULATIONS ON
THE STRIKE. GETTING RESOLVED AT
SIERRA CLUB. THEY RESOLVED THE
STRIKE, RIGHT? YEAH. OKAY. ALL
RIGHT. VERY EXCITING. OKAY.
WE'LL ADD IT INTO THE BILL.
YEAH, YEAH I KNOW, SO HE'S HERE.
YOU KNOW, OKAY. THANK YOU. WE
WILL ENTERTAIN A MOTION. WHEN?
OH, I'M SO SORRY. NO OPPOSITION.
I DON'T THINK THERE IS, BUT,
ANYONE? WE TOOK IT ALL OFF
THERE. USED TO BE. THAT'S RIGHT.
NOW WE'RE HERE IN PEACE. JUST
LIKE SIERRA CLUB. NOW YOU'RE
HERE IN PEACE, RIGHT? YEAH.
GREAT, ANY FINAL THOUGHTS? BUT
OTHERWISE, WE'LL THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR. YEAH. ALL RIGHT, SO WE'LL
ENTERTAIN A MOTION WHEN WE HAVE
MORE MEMBERS I'M GOING TO TAKE.
WE'RE GONNA TAKE A BRIEF RECESS,
AND HOPEFULLY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
HART IS ON HIS WAY OUT.
ALEX! LEE, COME ON DOWN! OH.
GOOD MORNING, MR. CHAIR. GOOD
MORNING. ALL RIGHT. YOU'RE HERE
TO PRESENT TWO BILLS, AB 2346
AND AB 2454. WOULD YOU MIND IF
WE START WITH 2346? I DON'T
MIND. ALL RIGHT. VERY GOOD,
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. AND
SENATORS, FIRST, I WOULD LIKE TO
ACCEPT THE SUGGESTED AMENDMENTS
DESCRIBED THROUGHOUT THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS. AND THANK
YOU TO THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
THEIR CONTINUED WORK ON THIS
BILL. AS YOU'RE AWARE, SB 1383
WAS SIGNED INTO LAW IN 2016 AND
SETS THE TARGET TO REDUCE
ORGANIC WASTE DISPOSAL IN
LANDFILLS BY 75% BY 2025. THE
TARGET IS AMBITIOUS, BUT
CRITICAL TO SLOW THE IMPACT OF
LANDFILLS ON PUSHING CLIMATE
CHANGE. METHANE EMISSIONS FROM
ORGANIC WASTE REPRESENT
APPROXIMATELY 20% OF THE STATE'S
METHANE OVER THE PAST TWO YEARS.
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS HAVE BEEN
REQUIRED TO BEGIN THEIR ORGANIC
WASTE COLLECTION PROGRAMS.
DIFFERENT COMMUNITIES HAVE
DIFFERENT LEVELS OF PREPAREDNESS
AND MANY CHALLENGES TO MEET THE
TARGETS REQUIRED BY LAW. THE
BILL IS INTENDED TO CREATE
GREATER FLEXIBILITY FOR
JURISDICTIONS TO MEET THEIR
MANDATED TARGETS WITHOUT
UNDERMINING THE DIVERSION
MANDATES. IN BROAD CONCEPT, THE
BILL FOCUSES ON FLEXIBILITY IN
USING DIRECT SERVICE PROVIDERS,
DEFINING ORGANIC WASTE TO
ESTABLISH TARGETS, ENCOURAGING
THE CONSTRUCTION OF ORGANIC
PROCESSING INFRASTRUCTURE,
IMPLEMENTING IMPLEMENTATION OF
THE SB 1383 PROGRAM IS
COMPLICATED AND PRESENTS AN
IMPORTANT BUT SIGNIFICANT
CHALLENGE FOR JURISDICTIONS ALL
OVER THE STATE. THE CHANGES
PROPOSED BY THIS BILL ARE
INTENDED TO MAKE THE PROGRAM
WORK BETTER. WITH ME TODAY ARE
TIMOTHY BURROWS, THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF STOP WASTE, AND
MICHELLE YOUNG, SENIOR
MANAGEMENT ANALYST AT THE COUNTY
OF SANTA CLARA. OKAY. YOU MAY
PROCEED. THANK YOU. AND GOOD
MORNING. THANK YOU, MEMBER LEE,
FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP. THANK YOU,
CHAIR, AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. AND ALSO THANK YOU
FOR COMMITTEE STAFF FOR ALL YOUR
COLLABORATION WITH US ON THE
AMENDMENTS, STOP WASTE IS THE
ALAMEDA COUNTY WASTE MANAGEMENT
AUTHORITY, WHERE A JOINT POWERS
AGENCY REPRESENTING 17 LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS IN ALAMEDA COUNTY,
AND WE HAVE A 30 YEAR HISTORY OF
LEADING POLICIES AND PROGRAMS TO
KEEP ORGANIC WASTE OUT OF THE
LANDFILL AND ALSO TO PROMOTE AND
ADVANCE THE USE OF COMPOST,
INCLUDING DEVELOPING MARKETS FOR
COMPOST, SO WE'RE STRONG
ADVOCATES FOR COMPOST, AND WE
SUPPORT EFFORTS FOR
JURISDICTIONS TO USE MORE AND
MORE OF IT. THAT SAID, THE
REQUIREMENTS IN SB 1383 FOR
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS TO PROCURE A
MINIMUM AMOUNT OF COMPOST AND
MULCH EACH YEAR NEED TO BE
AMENDED TO MORE EFFECTIVELY
ACHIEVE THE GOALS OF SB 1383. AS
CURRENTLY STRUCTURED, THE
TARGETS ARE ONE SIZE FITS ALL,
AND THEY'RE A BLUNT TOOL THAT
DOES NOT INCENTIVIZE THE LONG
TERM SUSTAINED INVESTMENT IN
COMPOST. USE. THE ONE SIZE FITS
ALL NATURE OF THE REQUIREMENTS
ARE NOT SERVING JURISDICTIONS OR
THE STATE WELL IN REGIONS LIKE
OURS IN THE BAY AREA, THE
REQUIREMENTS DISRUPT EXISTING
MARKETS FOR COMPOST, AND IN
OTHER REGIONS WHERE COMPOST USED
IS AT AN EARLIER STAGE, THERE'S
SIMPLY NOT ENOUGH COMPOST TO GO
AROUND FOR JURISDICTIONS TO MEET
THE REQUIREMENTS. AND SO FOR
THESE REASONS, STOP WASTE IS
PARTNERING WITH OTHER COUNTIES
AND COMPOSTERS TO ADVOCATE FOR
ADJUSTMENTS TO THE TARGETS SO
THAT THEY'RE ACHIEVABLE AND THEY
BETTER SERVE THE INTERESTS OF SB
1383 CLIMATE GOALS. WE'RE A
PROUD SPONSOR OF THIS BILL, AND
IT'S BENEFITED FROM INPUT AND
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE FROM CAL
RECYCLE AND MANY ADDITIONAL
STAKEHOLDERS. THE BILL PROVIDES
INCREASED FLEXIBILITY FOR
JURISDICTIONS TO MEET THE
TARGETS, AND ALSO INCENTIVES FOR
TO USE COMPOST LOCALLY IN
COMMUNITIES. THE BILL WOULD ALSO
GIVE PARTIAL PROCUREMENT CREDIT
FOR A LIMITED TIME FOR
INVESTMENTS THAT STIMULATE
SUSTAINED LOCAL DEMAND FOR USE
OF COMPOST, AND THE BILL WOULD
ALSO PROVIDE AN AVENUE FOR
JURISDICTIONS TO ADJUST THEIR
LOCAL TARGET BASED ON PROGRESS
THEY MAKE IN DIVERTING ORGANIC
WASTE FROM THE LANDFILL. SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. ALL RIGHT. THANK
YOU SO MUCH, GOOD MORNING, MR.
CHAIR, AND SENATORS MICHELLE
YOUNG FROM THE COUNTY OF SANTA
CLARA. AND TODAY, REPRESENTING
THE 16 CITIES IN SANTA CLARA
COUNTY WHO ARE IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL, I'M GOING TO ECHO SOME OF
THE SENTIMENTS WE'VE HEARD
ALREADY, OUR CITIES ARE
SUPPORTING THE GOALS OF 1383,
BUT HAVING MULTIPLE CHALLENGES
IN MEETING EVEN THE LOWER, LOWER
RATE TARGETS. AS A RESULT,
THEY'RE SUPPORTING THE BILL AS
AN OPPORTUNITY TO COLLABORATE
THESE ON THE, TARGETS BASED ON
DECADES OF RATEPAYER INVESTMENT
IN DIVERSION, INFRASTRUCTURE AND
MARKET DEVELOPMENT. THEY'RE ALSO
INTERESTED IN AND CONCERNED
ABOUT THE IMPACT OF OUR NEARLY
90,000 TONS OF COUNTY
JURISDICTION, WHICH WOULD CREATE
A DEMAND ON AN ALREADY MATURE
MARKET THAT SELLS MATERIAL TO
OUR CURRENT AGRICULTURAL AND
LAND LANDSCAPE. USERS OUR COUNTY
CITIES, SIMILAR TO ALAMEDA, HAVE
OVER 25 YEARS OF EXPERIENCE WITH
DIVERSION AND COMPOSTING
PROGRAMS AND APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CONTINUE WORKING
WITH THE AUTHOR, CAL RECYCLE,
AND KEY STAKEHOLDERS TO ENSURE
THAT FINAL BILL PROVISIONS MEET
BOTH THE INTENT OF THE LAW AND
THE INTERESTS OF DIVERSE,
DIVERSE STAKEHOLDERS. SANTA
CLARA COUNTY CITIES URGE SUPPORT
OF AB 2346. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SO MUCH. ALL RIGHT, FOLKS WHO
WANT TO VOICE SUPPORT FOR THE
BILL. CHAIR. STAFF DHINGRA,
FELLOW. ON BEHALF OF LA COUNTY
WITH CAPITAL ADVOCACY HERE IN
SUPPORT OF AB 2346. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. JOHN KENNEDY WITH THE
RURAL COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA AND STRONG SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIR VICTORIA RODRIGUEZ
WITH NIELSEN MERKSAMER ON BEHALF
OF THE CITY OF VISALIA IN
SUPPORT. SHARON GONSALVES WITH
THE CITY OF SANTA ROSA IN
SUPPORT. MISTER CHAIR ROMAN
VOGELSANG WITH THE PRAYING
COMPANY ON BEHALF OF REPUBLIC
SERVICES AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING, LETICIA REYES, ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF SAN JOSE,
IN SUPPORT. PRISCILLA, KUDOS
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE CITY AND
COUNTY OF SAN FRANCISCO AND THE
SOLID WASTE ASSOCIATION OF NORTH
AMERICA LEGISLATIVE TASK FORCE.
THE CALIFORNIA CHAPTERS IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING. ZACH WITH THE LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA CITIES IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING, JARED
MOSS ON BEHALF THE CITY OF LONG
BEACH IN SUPPORT. CHRIS ARENAS
WITH CALIFORNIANS AGAINST WASTE.
WE SUPPORTED A WE SUBMITTED A
SUPPORTIVE, AMENDED POSITION ON
THE BILL, AND WE LARGELY SHARE
THE GOALS OF THE AUTHORS AND
SPONSORS, THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS ADDRESS MANY OF THE
CONCERNS THAT WE HAD ABOUT
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES, AND THE
SPONSORS HAVE COMMITTED TO
CONTINUE WORKING WITH US OVER
THE SUMMER. BASED ON THIS, WE'RE
CONFIDENT THAT THE FINAL PRODUCT
WILL OFFER LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
USEFUL NEW TOOLS TO DIVERT
ORGANIC WASTE FROM LANDFILLS AND
WILL END UP IN SUPPORT OF THE
FINAL LEGISLATION. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING, MISTER
CHAIR KAYLA ROBINSON, ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA COMPOST
COALITION, MOSTLY ALIGN OUR
COMMENTS WITH CALIFORNIANS
AGAINST WASTE AND JUST LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR AND SPONSORS TO GET THIS
IN A GOOD PLACE. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. ALL RIGHT, ANYONE WHO
WANTS TO COME UP IN FORMAL
OPPOSITION OR RAISE, OPPOSITION
AT THE MIC, I KNOW WE DON'T HAVE
ANYONE REGISTERED, BUT. OKAY.
THANK YOU. I KNOW YOU'RE GOING
TO BE DOING SOME MORE, WORK ON
THIS. I MEAN, I REALLY DO,
APPRECIATE YOU ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENTS BECAUSE I THINK AS
WRITTEN, WE WERE WE WERE VERY
CONCERNED, BUT, BUT WITH THE
AMENDMENTS, I'M CERTAINLY HAPPY
TO, TO RECOMMEND A Dð PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS WHEN WE HAVE MORE
COLLEAGUES HERE. SO THANK YOU.
AND, WHY DON'T YOU PRESENT YOUR
NEXT BILL? OKAY. ABSOLUTELY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. SO WHEN
THE TIME COMES, HOPEFULLY EARN
YOUR COLLEAGUES. I VOTE. I'M
GOING TO MOVE ON TO AB 2454. THE
NEXT ITEM, SO THANK YOU, CHAIR
AND SENATORS, I'D LIKE TO THANK
THE COMMITTEE AND THE SPONSORS
FOR THEIR HARD WORK ON THIS
BILL. THIS BILL FOLLOWS UP ON MY
WORK RELATED DOMESTIC WELLS AND
ENSURING SAFE DRINKING WATER FOR
ALL, DESPITE THE EXISTENCE OF
FREE DOMESTIC WELL TESTING
PROGRAMS IN MANY REGIONS OF THE
STATE, DOMESTIC WELL
PARTICIPATION REMAINS FAR TOO
LOW, PUTTING WELL DRINKERS AT
RISK OF EXPOSURE TO DANGEROUS
CONTAMINANTS. AS NOTED IN THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS, NEITHER THE
US, EPA NOR STATE WATER BOARD
REGULATE DOMESTIC WELLS,
ALTHOUGH BOTH RECOMMEND ANNUAL
TESTING OF WELLS USED FOR
DRINKING WATER. BECAUSE STATE
AND FEDERAL DO NOT REQUIRE
DOMESTIC WELLS TO BE TESTED FOR
DRINKING WATER CONTAMINANTS,
THOSE WHO ARE DRINKING FROM
THESE WELLS MAY NOT KNOW WHETHER
CONTAMINANTS ARE PRESENT IN
THEIR DRINKING WATER. THE BILL
REQUIRES THAT AN OWNER OF A
DOMESTIC WELL THAT IS NOT OWNER
OCCUPIED AND IS NOT NOTIFIED OF
A FREE DOMESTIC WELL TESTING
PROGRAM TO PARTICIPATE IN THE
PROGRAM. IF THE TEST RESULT
DEMONSTRATES THAT THERE ARE
DANGEROUS CONTAMINANTS IN THE
WATER, THEN THE DOMESTIC WELL
OWNER MUST ENSURE THAT THOSE
LIVING ON THE PROPERTY HAVE
ACCESS TO AN ADEQUATE SUPPLY OF
SAFE DRINKING WATER. THE BILL
WOULD ENSURE THAT THOSE LIVING
IN AREAS SERVICED BY DOMESTIC
WELLS ARE NOT DRINKING TOXIC
DRINKING TOXIC TAP WATER. THIS
IS CONSISTENT WITH CALIFORNIA'S
HUMAN RIGHT TO WATER LAW, WHICH
STATES THAT IT IS THE RIGHT OF
EVERY HUMAN BEING TO HAVE ACCESS
TO SAFE DRINKING WATER. AND I'D
LIKE TO INTRODUCE MY TWO
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. MICHAEL
CLAYBOURN, DIRECTING ATTORNEY OF
THE LEADERSHIP COUNCIL OF
JUSTICE FOR JUSTICE AND
ACCOUNTABILITY. AND ABRAHAM
MENDOZA FROM THE COMMUNITY WATER
PROJECT CENTER. YEAH, LET ME
PROCEED. GOOD MORNING TO THE
CHAIR AND THE COMMITTEE. MY NAME
IS MICHAEL CLAYBOURN. I'M A
DIRECTING ATTORNEY WITH
LEADERSHIP COUNCIL FOR JUSTICE
AND ACCOUNTABILITY, TEN YEARS
AFTER THIS STATE RECOGNIZED THE
HUMAN RIGHT TO SAFE AND
AFFORDABLE DRINKING WATER,
APPROXIMATELY 1 MILLION PEOPLE
STILL LACK ACCESS TO SAFE WATER
IN THEIR HOMES. A SIGNIFICANT
PORTION OF THIS CRISIS INVOLVES
HOUSEHOLDS SERVED BY DOMESTIC
WELLS, WHICH PROVIDE DRINKING
WATER TO NEARLY 2 MILLION
CALIFORNIANS. THERE'S NO LEGAL
REQUIREMENT IN MOST OF THE STATE
FOR WELL OWNERS TO EVER TEST
THEIR WATER. WATER QUALITY OF
THEIR WELLS, MEANING RESIDENTS
MAY DRINK CONTAMINATED WATER FOR
YEARS OR DECADES WITHOUT KNOWING
IT. IN AN ATTEMPT TO ADDRESS
THIS PROBLEM, STATE AND REGIONAL
AGENCIES HAVE ESTABLISHED FREE
WELL TESTING PROGRAMS OFFERED TO
WELL OWNERS. THESE PROGRAMS
TARGET HIGH RISK AREAS, AND
WE'VE SEEN IN SOME AREAS, OVER
50% OF TESTED WELLS HAVE
EXCEEDED STANDARDS FOR ARSENIC.
123 TCP NITRATES, URANIUM AND
OTHER CONTAMINANTS. YET
PARTICIPATION IN THESE PROGRAMS
REMAINS DANGEROUSLY LOW. WE'RE
SEEING ABOUT 10 TO 20%
PARTICIPATION IN THESE FREE
AGAIN, FREE DOMESTIC WELL
TESTING PROGRAMS. THIS IS
ESPECIALLY TROUBLING WITH
DOMESTIC WELL OWNERS FAILURE TO
NGUYEN, FAILURE TO PARTICIPATE
PUTS OTHERS HEALTH AT RISK. AB
2454 IS A COMMON SENSE MEASURE
THAT WOULD REQUIRE DOMESTIC WELL
OWNERS WITH UNITS THAT ARE NOT
OCCUPIED BY THE OWNER TO
PARTICIPATE IN FREE WELL TESTING
PROGRAMS WHEN THEY ARE OFFERED.
PROVIDE NOTICE NOTICE TO THE
RESIDENTS ABOUT THE RESULTS, AND
THEN PROVIDE AN ADEQUATE SUPPLY
OF SAFE DRINKING WATER. IF
THERE'S AN ISSUE. AND WE URGE AN
I VOTE THANK YOU. THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR. AND MEMBERS. ABRAHAM
MENDOZA, ON BEHALF OF THE
COMMUNITY WATER CENTER HERE,
ONCE AGAIN THANKING THE MEMBER
FOR HIS SUPPORT AND HIS WORK ON
THIS BILL, AND ALSO JUST
ELEVATING THE COMMENTS THAT OUR
COLLEAGUES WITH LEADERSHIP
COUNCIL HAVE EXPRESSED, AS
MICHAEL MENTIONED, THERE ARE
MORE THAN 1 MILLION CALIFORNIANS
WHO LACK ACCESS TO SAFE, CLEAN
AND AFFORDABLE DRINKING WATER.
AND IN SOME AREAS OF THE CENTRAL
VALLEY, NITRATE AND OTHER
PESTICIDES HAVE ACCUMULATED TO
THE POINT THAT TAP WATER FOR
RURAL HOUSEHOLDS AND SMALL WATER
SYSTEMS DO NOT MEET SAFE
STANDARDS. OVER 1700 HOUSEHOLDS
RELY ON BOTTLED WATER DELIVERIES
FOR THEIR PRIMARY SOURCE OF
DRINKING WATER, AND SINCE 2022,
OVER 1800 DOMESTIC WELLS HAVE
GONE DRY FROM DROUGHT AND
OVERPUMPING. THIS YEAR ALONE,
THERE'S ALREADY BEEN 30, I'D
LIKE TO ELEVATE THE STORY OF A
COMMUNITY MEMBER THAT MYSELF AND
OUR TEAM HAS WORKED DIRECTLY
WITH IN TULARE COUNTY, SHE WAS
OUTREACH TO BY SELF-HELP
ENTERPRISES AND OURSELVES ABOUT,
WELL, TESTING, HAULED
REPLACEMENT AND BOTTLED WATER
SERVICES OFFERED FOR FREE AS
PART OF A LOCAL PUBLIC PRIVATE
PARTNERSHIP WITH GROWERS,
NONPROFITS AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
TO ENSURE SAFE DRINKING WATER
ACCESS. SHE LET US KNOW THAT HER
WELL HAD WENT DRY AND SHE WAS
FORCED TO PURCHASE REPLACEMENT
WATER SERVICES OUT OF HER OWN
POCKET. WE CONTACTED HER HOME
ABOUT THE SERVICES AVAILABLE IN
HER AREA, AND SHE AGREED TO
APPLY FOR ASSISTANCE FOR THE
PROGRAM, BUT UNFORTUNATELY SHE
WAS UNABLE TO RECEIVE AID
WITHOUT A WRITTEN, WRITTEN
AUTHORIZATION FROM THE OWNER OF
THE DOMESTIC WELL THAT SERVICED
HER PROPERTY, AND AS A RESULT,
SHE WAS LEFT WITHOUT WATER FOR
MORE THAN FIVE MONTHS FOR HER
HOUSEHOLD. HAVING TO AFFORD THAT
COST OUT OF POCKET. THIS BILL
ONCE AGAIN BUILDS ON EXISTING
LAW TO ENSURE THAT FARMWORKER
COMMUNITIES AND OTHER TENANTS IN
THESE HIGH RISK AREAS ARE ABLE
TO ACCESS VITAL SERVICES LIKE
WELL TESTING, HAULED WATER AND
BOTTLED WATER DELIVERY AND
FURTHER MOVES THE STATE CLOSER
TO DELIVERING ON THE HUMAN
RIGHTS OF WATER FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS. WE'RE PROUD TO
CO-SPONSOR THIS BILL, AND WE
RESPECTFULLY URGE AN AYE VOTE.
OKAY OTHER FOLKS WHO WANT TO
VOICE SUPPORT FOR THE BILL. HI,
I'M JAY KUSHNER WITH COMMUNITY
WATER CENTER ON BEHALF OF
SELF-HELP ENTERPRISES, RURAL
COMMUNITY ASSISTANCE
CORPORATION, CLEAN WATER ACTION
AND HUMAN IMPACT PARTNERS AND
SUPPORT. OKAY OPPOSITION
CONCERNS, NO. OKAY. AGAIN, I
APPRECIATE THE BILL, YOU KNOW, I
DO KNOW OF COURSE. YEAH. I MEAN,
THERE'S, I THINK GOING TO BE
SOME ADDITIONAL CHALLENGES FOR
THE BILL MOVING FORWARD, I KNOW
YOU'RE WELL AWARE OF, BUT, I'M
CERTAINLY HAPPY TO SUPPORT IT
OUT OF COMMITTEE TODAY, SO, I
SEE THE VICE CHAIR IS HERE NOW.
IT'S GREAT. BACK. I CAME BACK
JUST FOR THIS BILL. NO KIDDING.
YEAH, SO I DID A THIS IS AN AREA
WHERE I FOCUSED ON EARLY ON WHEN
I WAS IN THE ASSEMBLY BECAUSE
BIG PART OF MY DISTRICT IS
ACTUALLY ON WELLS. AND ALSO WE
WERE WORKING ON PORTERVILLE AND
ALL THE THINGS THAT WERE
HAPPENING IN THE VALLEY THAT YOU
RECOGNIZE. AND I ACTUALLY RAN A
BILL THAT WOULD LET YOU AT THE
POINT OF WHERE THE WATER COMES
INTO YOUR HOUSE, TO ACTUALLY PUT
A FILTER, YOU WE CAN FILTER THIS
AND THE BILL. I COULDN'T GET IT
DONE, I COULD I WAS SO
FRUSTRATED BECAUSE THESE FOLKS
DON'T FIRST OF ALL HAVE THE SOME
OF THEM DON'T HAVE THE RESOURCES
NUMBER ONE. NUMBER TWO, THEY'RE
DRINKING AND THERE'S, THERE'S
THEY HAVE TO THIS OUR SYSTEM IS
SET UP TO WHERE THEY WANT THEM
TO HAVE THEM, PUT IN A WHOLE
SYSTEM WHEN WE CAN ACTUALLY
FILTER THE WATER RIGHT AT THE
HOUSE AND TAKE CARE OF THE
PROBLEM. AND MY BILL, I COULDN'T
GET IT DONE. I COULDN'T GET IT
OUT OF HERE. SO MY QUESTION TO
YOU IS, I THINK THERE'S SOME
LIABILITY ISSUES HERE. SO LET'S
SAY THEY DO THE FREE TESTING AND
YOU COME UP WITH ALL THE THINGS
THAT ARE IN THE WELL. AND NOW
YOU HAVE THE OWNER OF THE HOUSE
WHO DOESN'T HAVE THE RESOURCES
TO FIX THE PROBLEM, DOESN'T HAVE
THE ABILITY TO BE ABLE TO. AND
THEN WHAT HAPPENS THEN? WHO'S
LIABLE? WHAT'S GOING TO WHAT'S
THE WHAT DO YOU THINK'S GOING TO
HAPPEN. YEAH I'LL TURN IT OVER
TO MY SPONSORS IN A SECOND. TALK
ABOUT SOME OF THE PROGRAMS THAT
EXIST OUT THERE AND SOME OF THE
MEDIATION. BUT I DO THINK THAT
IT'S IMPORTANT, THE WORK YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT, TO MAKE SURE THAT
IF THERE WAS CONTAMINANTS, THAT
THEY HAVE SOME WAY TO ADDRESS
IT. BUT THAT'S WHY THIS PROGRAM
IS IMPORTANT, RIGHT? BECAUSE
PEOPLE COULD BE WITHOUT EVEN NOT
WITHOUT ACKNOWLEDGING OR KNOWING
THEY COULD BE DRINKING
CONTAMINATED WATER AND THAT'S
WHY TESTING IS THE FIRST THING I
THINK WE WOULD AGREE THERE. BUT
WHAT HAPPENS TO MAKE SURE
PEOPLE, NOW THAT THEY KNOW IT'S
BAD WATER, WHAT IS THE NEXT
STEP? AND I'LL TURN IT OVER TO
MY SPONSOR TO TALK ABOUT SOME OF
THOSE PROGRAMS AND STUFF. YEAH,
ABSOLUTELY. SO I THINK PART OF
THE ANSWER IS THAT THE BILL
DOESN'T REQUIRE THAT THE
DOMESTIC WELL, OWNER ADDRESS THE
CONTAMINATION ISSUE IN THE.
WELL, IN A LOT OF CASES, YOU'RE
RIGHT, POINT OF ENTRY,
FILTRATION, POINT OF USE,
FILTRATION UNDER THE SINK CAN
WORK. CAN ADDRESS A PROBLEM.
THAT'S NOT ALWAYS THE CASE.
THERE'S SOME CONTAMINANTS THAT
DON'T EVEN HAVE AN APPROVED
FILTER AT THIS POINT. SO WHAT WE
WANTED TO DO IS MAKE SURE THAT
THERE'S FLEXIBILITY IN THE BILL.
IT REQUIRES AN ADEQUATE SUPPLY
OF REPLACEMENT WATER. OFTEN THAT
MEANS BOTTLED WATER. IF THERE'S
NOT A FILTRATION, OPTION. SO I
GUESS ANOTHER POINT TO MAKE IS
THAT THIS IS KIND OF ONLY ONLY
APPLIES WHERE THERE'S A FREE
DOMESTIC. WELL, TESTING PROGRAM,
LIKE THE CV SALTS PROGRAM IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY. THAT PROGRAM
ACTUALLY INCLUDES REPLACEMENT
WATER AS PART OF IT, AS A FREE
SERVICE. AS PART OF THE PROGRAM.
SO FOR, DOMESTIC WELL OWNERS IN
THE CENTRAL VALLEY THAT ARE IN
HIGH RISK AREAS WHERE THIS BILL
WOULD APPLY, THEY WOULD BE ABLE
TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THAT FREE
PROGRAM TO GET THAT REPLACEMENT
WATER DELIVERED FOR FREE. WHO
PAYS FOR IT, THOUGH? NOTHING'S
FREE. SOMEBODY HAS TO PAY FOR IT
IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY, THE CV
SALTS PROGRAM IS PAID FOR BY
DISCHARGERS OF NITRATES. SO
THAT'S GENERALLY AGRICULTURE
DAIRIES. IT'S ACTUALLY A PROGRAM
THAT AGRICULTURE CAME TOGETHER
AND DEVELOPED AND PROPOSED TO
THE REGIONAL BOARD IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY. REGIONAL
REGIONAL WATER BOARD THEN
APPROVED THAT. AND THEN THE
STATE BOARD APPROVED IT. THEY'RE
IN EARLY STAGES OF
IMPLEMENTATION AND HAVE REACHED
A LOT OF HOUSEHOLDS SO FAR. SO
WHAT IF YOU'RE NOT IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY? AND THIS THIS IS
A STATEWIDE BILL. CORRECT. SO
THIS BILL ONLY APPLIES WHERE
THERE'S AN OFFER OF FREE
DOMESTIC WELL TESTING, BUT
THAT'S AVAILABLE IN THE VALLEY,
THE CENTRAL VALLEY IN
PARTICULAR. THERE'S A PROGRAM IN
DEVELOPMENT ON THE CENTRAL COAST
THAT'S SIMILAR TO THE CENTRAL
VALLEY PROGRAM. IT'S NOT AN
IMPLEMENTATION YET, BUT WOULD BE
SIMILAR WHERE THERE ARE NOT FREE
DOMESTIC WELL PROGRAMS. THIS
BILL WOULD NOT APPLY. SO I JUST
I'M CONFLICTED ON THIS BILL. I
TRIED TO DO WHAT YOU LIKE. WE
DON'T WANT ANYBODY DRINKING BAD
WATER, BUT WE TALK ABOUT LOW
INCOME DISADVANTAGED FOLKS AND
THAT'S WHO THIS IS GOING TO
IMPACT STRAIGHT UP. WE KNOW THAT
WE ALREADY WE ALREADY WE ALREADY
KNOW THAT NUMBER ONE, NUMBER
TWO, I DON'T WANT THE PART
THAT'S DIFFICULT IS SAY LET'S WE
DO HAVE AN ISSUE WHERE YOU CAN'T
GET THE CONTAMINANT OUT. AND
THEN THE OWNER IS ON THE HOOK.
HE'S LIKE, HEY, YOU CAN'T CAN'T
RENT THIS PLACE. THAT'S THE NEXT
BILL THAT COMES. YOU CAN'T RENT
IT TO SOMEBODY IF YOU CAN'T GIVE
THEM, PROVIDE THEM WITH, YOU
KNOW, SUPPOSEDLY IT'S A RIGHT
NOW TO HAVE CLEAN WATER. BUT
ANYWAY, SO THAT'S MY, MY WORRY
IS THAT NOT THAT I WANT ANYBODY
TO DRINK BAD WATER. BUT IN THOSE
CASES, THE PERSON ENDS UP NOT
BEING ABLE TO LIVE THERE AGAIN.
AND NOW HERE WE ARE PUTTING
WE'RE NOT HELPING THAT PERSON IN
THE LOW INCOME AREA BECAUSE
WE'RE IN A CATCH 22. SO THOSE
ARE MY CONCERNS. I'M GONNA LAY
OFF YOUR BILL. IS WHERE IT GOES
TO JUST A PROCESS AFTER THIS.
YEAH. ALL RIGHT. I'LL BE
WATCHING IT. AND, MAYBE DIG IN A
LITTLE MORE, BUT I WOULD.
SOMEBODY NEEDS TO GET A BILL
THROUGH HERE THAT CAN ALLOW
POINT OF HOUSE FILTRATION. AND I
DON'T KNOW WHY. I HAD ALL KINDS
OF OPTIONS. I HAD LABOR AGAINST
IT. HAD TO HAVE A CERTIFIED THIS
AND CERTIFIED THAT AND DIFFERENT
FILTRATION COMPANIES. I HAD I
HAD MUNICIPALITIES OPPOSING MY
BILL AND IT'S LIKE, HEY, I JUST
WANT CLEAN WATER AT THE HOUSE
AND WE CAN PUT A FILTER RIGHT IT
AS IT GOES INTO, SO YOU'RE NOT
EVEN SHOWERING WITH IT. YOU'RE
GETTING YOUR WHOLE HOUSE DONE.
AND I COULDN'T GET IT DONE. SO
ANYWAY, JUST THROW IT OUT FOR
THOUGHTS. THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THE BILL FORWARD. DO YOU WANT,
ASSEMBLY MEMBER, DO YOU WANT TO
RESPOND TO SOME OF THE CONCERNS
THAT HAVE RAISED AND MAYBE SURE,
I'LL DO THAT AS MY CLOSE. I'LL
TAKE MY CLOTHES AS WELL. IT'S
JUST THAT, YOU KNOW, I'M HAPPY
TO COLLABORATE MORE ON THIS
ISSUE. I I THINK THE WAY WE
APPROACH THIS BILL AND WHY
THERE'S BEEN VERY LITTLE FORMAL
OPPOSITION IS TO TRY AND DO A
THOUGHTFUL APPROACH AND NOT DO
THAT CATCH 22, THE SAME PEOPLE
WHO MIGHT NOT HAVE THE RESOURCES
TO DO ALL THOSE COSTLY FILTERS
ARE ALSO THE SAME PEOPLE. BY
DEFAULT, DRINKING THE TOXIC
WATER. RIGHT? SO YOU'RE YOU'RE
REALLY STUCK BETWEEN NOT HAVING
ENOUGH MONEY TO DO SOMETHING OR
DRINKING, WHICH ARE BOTH BAD,
WHICH ARE BOTH TERRIBLE
OUTCOMES. AND THIS IS WHY THIS
PROGRAM IS ABOUT ENCOURAGING
PEOPLE TO TAKE, TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF THE FREE TESTING PROGRAMS
THAT EXIST OUT THERE. SO AT
LEAST YOU HAVE THE PEACE OF MIND
TO HAVE KNOWLEDGE AND TAKE THE
TAKE ACTION IF NECESSARY. RIGHT?
THAT'S WHY THIS BILL IS CRAFTED
THE WAY IT IS. WE ARE STILL
GETTING MORE INPUT FROM THE
STATE WATER BOARD ABOUT
ENFORCEMENT AND OTHER THINGS
LIKE THAT AS WE MOVE ON THROUGH
APPROPRIATIONS. BUT, YOU KNOW, I
AM HAPPY TO WORK WITH YOU ABOUT
THIS BECAUSE EVEN THOUGH YOU
KNOW, MY DISTRICT IS MOSTLY AN
URBAN DISTRICT, I THINK THIS IS
A STATEWIDE ISSUE WHERE PEOPLE,
ESPECIALLY IN RURAL REGIONS,
CAN'T BE LEFT BEHIND, AND THEY
CAN'T BE EITHER SAYING, WELL,
EITHER I GOT TO FORK OVER MY
SAVINGS OR I'M JUST GOING TO
DRINK A NITRATE WATER FOR THE
REST OF MY LIFE. BOTH ARE
UNACCEPTABLE, AND THAT'S WHY
WE'VE CRAFTED IT THIS WAY. AND I
HOPE THAT, YOU KNOW, WE CAN WORK
TOGETHER ON THIS TOPIC IN THE
FUTURE. AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE AND FOR YOU TO
CONTINUE WATCHING THIS BILL,
TOO. THANK YOU. OKAY SO WE'LL
ENTERTAIN A MOTION NGUYEN. OH,
YOU'LL MOVE IT. OKAY. OKAY,
GREAT. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ABBY. 2454. THE MOTION
IS DUE. PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS.
SENATORS ALLEN, I ALLEN I DALLI
GONZALEZ. HURTADO MENGIBAR
NGUYEN SKINNER. OKAY. THANK YOU.
THANKS VERY MUCH. ALL RIGHT, I
THINK WE HAVE SOME MEMBER HART
HERE OR. YEAH TO PRESENT AB 2298
OR I DON'T KNOW, DID YOU GUYS
FIGURE IT OUT OR. YEAH. WHO'S
DOING FIRST? OKAY. SENATOR
WILSON. OKAY, THIS IS ITEM 13 AB
2300. YOU MAY PROCEED. ALL
RIGHT, MR. CHAIR, SENATORS, I'M
PLEASED TO PRESENT AB 2300, A
BILL THAT PROHIBITS THE
MANUFACTURE, SALE, OR
DISTRIBUTION OF INTRAVENOUS
SOLUTION CONTAINERS AND TUBING
MADE WITH INTENTIONALLY ADDED
DEHP, I'D LIKE TO NOTE THAT DPS,
AND I'LL SAY IT REGULARLY STANDS
FOR A VERY COMPLEX WORD, WHICH
I'M SURE MOST OF YOU ARE
FAMILIAR WITH BEING IN THIS
COMMITTEE. AND IT'S DYE TO
ETHANOL. HEXYL FOLATES I THINK I
SAID THAT RIGHT, DEHP BELONGS TO
A FAMILY OF HORMONALLY ACTIVE
INDUSTRIAL CHEMICALS CALLED
FILLETS, WHICH ARE USED TO MAKE
PLASTICS SOFT AND PLIABLE AND
CAN BE FOUND IN A MYRIAD OF,
PARTICULARLY THOSE MADE FROM
POLYVINYL CHLORIDE OR PLASTIC,
WHICH IS PVC. WE CALL IT PVC.
DEHP IMPACTS THE THYROID AND
IMMUNE SYSTEM RESEARCH INDICATES
THAT DEHP PROMOTES DRUG
RESISTANCE AND INHIBITS THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF BREAST CANCER
DRUGS, INTERFERES WITH THE
ABILITY OF CHEMOTHERAPIES TO
FIGHT BREAST CANCER, AND THAT
PATIENTS WITH HIGHER LEVELS OF
DEHP IN THEIR SYSTEMS HAD HIGHER
RATES OF RELAPSE AND MORTALITY.
DEHP IS COMMONLY USED TO IMPART
FLEXIBILITY TO IV BAGS AND IV
TUBING. SOME IV BAGS AND TUBING
CAN CONTAIN UP TO 40% OF DEHP BY
WEIGHT. DEHP HAS BEEN SHOWN TO
LEACH OUT OF THE IV BAGS AND
TUBING, AND INTO THE MEDICATION
AND OTHER FLUIDS BEING INFUSED
INTO THE BLOODSTREAM OF
PATIENTS. THE GOOD NEWS IS, IS
THAT SAFER ALTERNATIVES EXIST
AND ARE ALREADY BEING USED IN
FDA APPROVED, DD FREE, DEHP FREE
IV BAGS FOR EXAMPLE, SOME
MANUFACTURERS ARE ALREADY
EXCLUSIVELY MANUFACTURING DD
FREE IV BAGS, AND OTHER
MANUFACTURERS ALSO HAVE A LARGE
PORTFOLIO OF FDA APPROVED NON
DEHP IV BAGS. I WOULD LIKE TO
THANK ALL OF THE STAKEHOLDERS
FOR THE ROBUST CONVERSATIONS
WE'VE HAD OVER THE PAST FEW
WEEKS, AND I'M HAPPY TO CONTINUE
THOSE CONVERSATIONS AS AB 2300
MOVES FORWARD. I THINK WE'VE
REACHED A GREAT PLACE OF WHERE
WE'VE REMOVED ALMOST ALL BUT ONE
OF THE OPPOSITIONS, THE BILL
CURRENTLY, WOULD BAN IV SOLUTION
CONTAINERS MADE WITH
INTENTIONALLY ADDED DEHP
BEGINNING 2030 AND IV TUBING BY
2035. THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS
WE TOOK IN SENATE-TV HEALTH
ALLOW FOR FLEXIBILITY TO ADDRESS
CONCERNS ABOUT POSSIBLE SUPPLY
CHAIN SHORTAGES OR
ADMINISTRATIVE HOLD UPS,
SPECIFICALLY AS IT RELATES TO
THE FDA APPROVAL PROCESS. ONCE
AGAIN, THERE WAS A LOT OF ROBUST
CONVERSATION SINCE THIS BILL HAS
BEEN INTRODUCED, I THINK WE
FOUND A PLACE TO RECOGNIZE HOW
DO WE PROTECT, PATIENTS. AND AT
THE SAME TIME, RECOGNIZING THAT
ALSO PROTECTING PATIENTS
INVOLVES PROTECTING THE SUPPLY
CHAIN. WITH ME TODAY TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT IS REED ADDIS, ON
BEHALF OF BREAST CANCER
PREVENTION PARTNERS, SPONSORS OF
THE BILL AND RYAN SPENCER, ON
BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN COLLEGE
OF OBSTETRICIANS AND
GYNECOLOGISTS. OKAY. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. CHAIR AND MEMBERS,
REED ADDIS, ON BEHALF OF THE
BREAST CANCER PREVENTION
PARTNERS AND THE CALIFORNIA
BLACK HEALTH NETWORK, TWO OF THE
SPONSORS FOR THIS MEASURE IN
STRONG SUPPORT TODAY. I WAS IN
THE UNENVIABLE CLUB OF HAVING TO
BATTLE CANCER. IN THE LAST TWO
AND A HALF YEARS, I HAD SIX
MONTHS OF CHEMOTHERAPY. IT IS
SHOCKING HOW MANY IV BAGS AND
TUBES ARE STUCK IN YOUR BODY TO
ADMINISTER MEDICATIONS. AND I
HAD NO IDEA THAT DEHP COULD HAVE
BEEN IN THOSE BAGS LEACHING INTO
MY BODY. I WAS LUCKY, HOWEVER,
AFTER THE FACT, TO FIND OUT THAT
MY HEALTH CARE NETWORK DOES NOT
ALLOW DEHP BAGS TO BE IN THEIR
FACILITIES. THAT WAS LUCK. THAT
IS UNFAIR TO MANY A CALIFORNIANS
WHERE THERE'S AN ALTERNATIVE OUT
THERE THAT THEY DON'T KNOW ABOUT
THIS, THAT HOSPITALS MAY NOT
KNOW ABOUT THIS. WE NEED A GOOD,
SOLID POLICY IN PLACE TO SAY
THIS SHOULD NOT BE ALLOWED
ANYMORE. THAT'S WHAT AB 2300
DOES. YES, WE'VE BEEN FRUSTRATED
THAT THERE WOULD EVEN BE
OPPOSITION TO THIS MEASURE. BUT
AS THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MENTIONED, SHE HAS BEEN
NAVIGATING THIS DUTIFULLY WITH
OPPOSITION, WORKED WITH THE
CHAIR OF THE LAST COMMITTEE AND
THE SET OF AMENDMENTS, WE THINK
WAS A GOOD COMPROMISE, IT MAKES
IT CLEAR THAT THESE BAGS SHOULD
NOT BE USED ANYMORE, BUT ALSO
HAS ALLOWED SOME OF THE
OPPOSITION TO GO TO NEUTRAL. SO
WE HOPEFULLY, HOPE THIS
COMMITTEE WILL PASS THIS MEASURE
SO THAT WE'RE NOT RELYING ON
LUCK TO PROVIDE SAFETY TO
PATIENTS. BUT WE HAVE A SOLID
POLICY THAT SAYS THESE BAGS
SHOULD BE NO LONGER THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. RIGHT. SPENCER, ON
BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN COLLEGE
OF OB GYN DISTRICT NINE, WE ARE
ALSO CO-SPONSORS OF THE MEASURE,
AND I THINK I COULDN'T SAY IT
ANY BETTER THAN MY COLLEAGUE
RIGHT HERE TO MY LEFT. AND SO WE
JUST URGE YOUR SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT. FOLKS
WANT TO VOICE SUPPORT FOR THE
BILL. HELLO, WHITNEY FRANCIS
WITH THE WESTERN CENTER ON LAW
AND POVERTY IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT. THE OPPOSITION,
CONCERNS, FOLKS WANT TO RAISE.
OKAY. QUESTIONS, MR. VICE CHAIR?
WELL, I JUST WANT TO SAY THANK
YOU FOR THE BILL. GOOD WORK. I
WAS OBVIOUSLY THE OPPOSITION
CAME IN EARLY, AND YOU GUYS HAVE
WORKED THROUGH IT. IT'S, IT'S A
BEAUTIFUL THING WHEN IT COMES
TOGETHER. SO I'LL BE MOVING YOUR
BILL, GIVE YOU THE OPPORTUNITY
TO CLOSE JUST TO SAY THANK YOU
SO MUCH. THIS HAS BEEN A LONG
ROAD, AND I'M SO GLAD WE WERE
ABLE TO GET TO WHERE, YOU KNOW,
THE MAJORITY OF THE OPPOSITION
WAS NEUTRAL, WHICH WAS
DIFFICULT, AS YOU KNOW, I LIKE,
MR. REID ADDIS IS A CANCER
SURVIVOR. AND WHEN WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT THE ISSUES OF, OF CANCER
AND WHAT YOU GO THROUGH, NOT
JUST THE TOLL ON YOUR BODY, BUT
MENTALLY, IT'S HARD WHEN THERE'S
OPPOSITION TO SUCH A THING THAT
SAVES LIVES, BUT WE REALIZE AT
THE SAME TIME, PART OF PATIENT
CARE IS HAVING SUPPLY TO BE ABLE
TO PROVIDE THAT CARE. AND SO
THAT WE TOOK, THE, THE
AMENDMENTS AND THE SPIRIT OF
THAT. AND SO THIS, BILL AB 2300
IS A SMALL STEP TOWARDS REDUCING
THE RISK OF CANCER WITH DEHP AND
THE LONG STANDING EFFECTS THAT
HAPPEN TO PEOPLE, THAT DON'T NOT
ALLOW THEM TO HAVE A SUCCESSFUL
OUTCOME AS IT RELATES TO
TREATING CANCER. AND REALLY
PROTECTING SOME OF OUR MOST
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS. I
RESPECTFULLY URGE, AND I VOTE.
WELL, CONGRATULATIONS AGAIN ON
THE, ON THE DEAL. AND, IT'S A
MOVE BY SENATOR DASCHLE AND
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
AB 2300. THE MOTION IS DUE.
PASS. SENATORS ALLEN I ALLEN I
DOLLY. DOLLY I GONZALEZ HURTADO
MENGIBAR NGUYEN SKINNER TWO.
OKAY, WE'LL LEAVE THAT ON CALL.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT, LET'S, ASK
A MEMBER HART, TO COME UP AND
PRESENT AB 2298, ITEM 12.
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. I'M
PLEASED TO PRESENT AB 29 2298,
AND I'M HAPPY TO ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEE'S AMENDMENTS.
INCREASED SEA TRAFFIC FROM
SHIPPING, INDUSTRIAL OPERATIONS
AND RECREATIONAL BOATING ADDS TO
THE COMPLEX MARINE ENVIRONMENT
WHALES MUST NAVIGATE. IN
ADDITION TO THE THREAT OF SHIP
STRIKES, SHIPPING NOISE CAN
DISRUPT WHALE MIGRATION,
NAVIGATION, FEEDING PATTERNS,
AND SOCIAL INTERACTIONS.
RESEARCH POINTS TOWARDS A
STRAIGHTFORWARD BUT IMPACTFUL
SOLUTION SLOWING DOWN SHIPS. AB
2298 WILL ESTABLISH THE
CALIFORNIA PROTECTING BLUE
WHALES AND BLUE SKIES, A
STATEWIDE VOLUNTARY VESSEL SPEED
REDUCTION PROGRAM. THIS BILL
BUILDS UPON THE SUCCESSES OF THE
VOLUNTARY VESSEL SPEED REDUCTION
PROGRAM THAT STARTED IN SANTA
BARBARA AND VENTURA COUNTIES IN
2014, LEADING SHIPPING COMPANIES
INCLUDING NYK LINE AND YANG MING
MARINE TRANSPORT HAVE EXPRESSED
PRIDE IN RECEIVING RECOGNITION
AND THE PRESTIGIOUS WHALE TAIL
TROPHIES FOR HELPING PREVENT
WHALE STRIKES. AB 2298 WILL
PROVIDE THESE SHIPPING COMPANIES
AND MANY OTHER PARTICIPANTS WITH
FORMAL RECOGNITION AND
ENDORSEMENT FROM THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA FOR SLOWING THEIR
SPEED TO LESS THAN TEN KNOTS,
REDUCING EMISSIONS AND
SAFEGUARDING WHALES. AB 2298
WILL HELP PREVENT BOAT STRIKES,
REDUCE DISRUPTIVE NOISE THAT
HAMPERS WHALE COMMUNICATION AND
LOWER CARBON EMISSIONS ALONG THE
COAST. SPEAKING IN SUPPORT TODAY
IS ALAN ABS, WHO'S REPRESENTING
THE BAY AREA AIR QUALITY
MANAGEMENT DISTRICT. GOOD
MORNING, CHAIR ALLEN AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS
ALAN ABS. I'M THE LEGISLATIVE
OFFICER FOR THE BAY AREA AIR
QUALITY MANAGEMENT DISTRICT,
ALONG WITH THE SANTA BARBARA
COUNTY AND VENTURA COUNTY AIR
POLLUTION CONTROL DISTRICTS. WE
ARE THE CO-SPONSORS OF AB 22,
98, AB TWO, AB 22, 98 WOULD
ESTABLISH A PROCESS TO EXPAND
THE EXISTING VOLUNTARY VESSEL
SPEED REDUCTION PROGRAM, KNOWN
AS THE PROTECTING BLUE WHALES
AND BLUE SKIES FOR OCEAN GOING
CARGO SHIPS ALONG THE ENTIRE
CALIFORNIA COAST. THE BILL WOULD
RECOGNIZE THE DECADE LONG WORK
INITIATIVE INITIATED BY THE
SANTA BARBARA COUNTY AND VENTURA
COUNTY AIR POLLUTION CONTROL
DISTRICTS, AND CREATE A
STAKEHOLDER PROCESS TO EXPAND
THE EXISTING VOLUNTARY BSR
PROGRAM TO COVER THE REST OF THE
STATE. THE PROGRAM IS.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER HART MENTIONED,
WAS CREATED IN 2014, IN SANTA
BARBARA AND VENTURA COUNTY,
EXPANDED TO PORTIONS OF THE BAY
AREA IN LATER YEARS, AND HAS
RESULTED IN INCREASED SLOW SPEED
TRANSITS FROM 30% OF SHIPS IN
ITS INCEPTION TO OVER 80% OF
SHIPS IN THE YEAR 2023. THESE
EXISTING VOLUNTARY PROGRAMS
REDUCE AIR POLLUTION IN COASTAL
COMMUNITIES, REDUCE UNDERWATER
NOISE AND REDUCE THREATS OF SHIP
STRIKES TO SEVERAL SPECIES OF
WHALES, SOME OF WHICH ARE LISTED
AS ENDANGERED. OUR EXISTING
PROGRAMS HAVE BEEN EMBRACED BY
INTERNATIONAL SHIPPING COMPANIES
WHO ROUTINELY TOUT THEIR
PARTICIPATION AS THE NEW YORK
TIMES ARTICLE FROM YESTERDAY
MENTIONED THAT THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WAS QUOTING FROM AND
EXPANDING THIS VOLUNTARY PROGRAM
TO OTHER PARTS OF THE COAST AND
RECOGNIZING PARTICIPATION BY
SHIPPING COMPANIES WOULD
INCREASE MARINE, MAMMAL AND AIR
QUALITY BENEFITS. AB 2298 IS
SUPPORTED BY COASTAL AIR
DISTRICTS. THE MARINE SANCTUARY
FOUNDATION, OCEAN AND MAMMAL
PROTECTION GROUPS, AND OTHER
ENVIRONMENTAL GROUPS. I'D LIKE
TO THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER HART
FOR HIS LEADERSHIP ON THIS
ISSUE, AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
ANSWERING ANY QUESTIONS YOU
HAVE. AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT. OTHER FOLKS WANT TO VOICE
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. CHAIR
MEMBERS ROSS BUCKLEY, ON BEHALF
OF SOUTH COAST AIR QUALITY
MANAGEMENT DISTRICT, IN SUPPORT.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS. BALTASAR
CORNEJO, WITH BROWNSTEIN ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA MARINE
SANCTUARY FOUNDATION, IN SUPPORT.
ISABELLA GONZALEZ POTTER WITH
THE NATURE CONSERVANCY IN
SUPPORT. JOSH GALLAGHER ON
BEHALF OF THE SANTA BARBARA
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN
SUPPORT. JACOB EVANS WITH SIERRA
CLUB, CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. KEVIN SHIVE, ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA AIR
POLLUTION CONTROL OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. GREAT OPPOSITION FOLKS WHO
WANT TO RAISE CONCERNS. COME ON
UP. THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR,
SENATOR DALI, MIKE JACOB WITH
PACIFIC MERCHANT SHIPPING
ASSOCIATION, AND WE'D LIKE TO BE
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. WE WERE
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL WHEN IT
WAS INTRODUCED AS A PAST
ASSEMBLY POLICY COMMITTEE. AND
WE APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS. MOVING IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION TODAY AND TAKEN BY THE
AUTHOR, WE STILL WOULD LIKE TO
SEE A STATEWIDE, PROGRAM
ADMINISTERED BY A STATE AGENCY
INSTEAD OF WHAT'S BEING
PROPOSED. EVERYTHING YOU HEARD
FROM THE AUTHOR AND THE SPONSORS
TODAY ABOUT THE PARTICIPATION BY
OUR MEMBERS, IS CORRECT. OUR
MEMBERS REALLY DO LIKE
PARTICIPATING IN IN VOLUNTARY
VESSEL SPEED REDUCTION PROGRAMS.
THEY ARE VERY EFFECTIVE, NOT
ONLY THE BLUE WHALE BLUE SKY
PROGRAM, BUT ALSO GREEN FLAG
PROGRAMS AND OTHER PROGRAMS,
BOTH IN CALIFORNIA AND AROUND
THE COUNTRY. IN THE WORLD, AND
SO WE WOULD REALLY LIKE TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL, BUT
UNFORTUNATELY, WITH THE
AMENDMENTS THAT WERE TAKEN THAT
TOOK OUT THE STATEWIDE CHARACTER
OF THE ADMINISTRATION OF THE
PROGRAM, WE ARE OPPOSED. OKAY.
THANK YOU. APPRECIATE IT. ALL
RIGHT, YOU CAN STAY UP IF, IF
THERE'S ANY QUESTIONS, YOU CAN
STAY. YEAH, YEAH, YEAH. PLEASE
YEAH. WHY DID WHAT? WHY DID WE
CHANGE AMENDMENTS? WHAT WAS THE
REASON FOR THAT? I'LL. I'LL TAKE
THE FIRST STAB AT THIS. SO, SO
THIS IS THE, THE SECOND ATTEMPT
AT THIS BILL. LAST YEAR'S BILL.
WAS HELD IN SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS FOR FISCAL
CONCERNS RELATED TO THE COST OF
OPC TAKING OVER THIS PROGRAM.
AND SO WE HAD TALKED WITH OPC
EARLIER THIS YEAR ABOUT WAYS TO
REDUCE THAT FISCAL AND WHAT WE
CAME UP WITH AS AMENDMENTS IN
ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS WAS TO
MOVE THE OPC'S, ROLE TO AN
ADVISORY. THEY'LL STILL BE ABLE
TO PARTICIPATE, PROVIDE THEIR
EXPERTISE, BUT THEY'RE NOT IN
CHARGE OF THE OVERALL EXPANSION
OF THE PROGRAM. SO NOW TO THE
OPPOSITION. WHAT'S THE
DIFFERENCE? THAT'S A GOOD
QUESTION. AND I THINK THE ANSWER
IS THAT IN THE SHORT TERM, THERE
THERE IS NO DIFFERENCE, WHICH
MEANS THAT IT BELIES THE POINT
OF THE BILL. THE POINT OF THE
BILL SHOULD BE TO EXPAND
PARTICIPATION RATES, HAVE A
UNIFIED PROGRAM THAT'S
ADMINISTERED BY THE STATE THAT
ACTUALLY PROVIDES THE ABILITY
FOR YOU TO MOVE THIS PROGRAM
FORWARD BEYOND WHERE IT IS RIGHT
NOW. WE'RE HAPPY WITH THE WAY
THE PROGRAM WORKS RIGHT NOW, WE
HAVE MEMBERS, AS YOU HEARD, THAT
ARE VERY HAPPY TO PARTICIPATE IN
IT. AND WE HAVE A LOT OF
SUCCESSFUL MOU PROGRAMS AND
OTHER TYPES OF VOLUNTARY
PROGRAMS, IF THE STATE IS GOING
TO MOVE FORWARD WITH A STATEWIDE
PROGRAM, WE WOULD LIKE TO
SUPPORT THAT. SO AS, MR. ABS
POINTED OUT LAST YEAR, WE
SUPPORTED THE SAME BILL, THAT
MOVED FORWARD WITH THE OCEAN
PROTECTION COUNCIL AND CONTROL.
BUT I THINK JUST IN GENERAL, IF
YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE A STATEWIDE
PROGRAM, IT SHOULD BE
ADMINISTERED BY A STATEWIDE
AGENCY. IT SHOULD BE SUPPORTED
BY THE STATE, AND THAT'S OUR
POSITION, CERTAINLY IT'S IT IT
GOES TO YOUR POINT, WHICH IS,
ARE YOU ACTUALLY ENCOURAGING
MORE PEOPLE TO DO SOMETHING
THROUGH THE STATE ACTUALLY BEING
INVOLVED? AND THE WAY WE SEE
THIS RIGHT NOW, IT DOESN'T
ACHIEVE THAT PURPOSE. AND I
WOULD ONLY JUST ADD THAT I THINK
THE POINT OF EXPANDING THE
PROGRAM STATEWIDE IS TO INCREASE
THE RECOGNITION OF THE COMPANIES
THAT VOLUNTARILY WANT TO
PARTICIPATE. IT'S, YOU KNOW,
IT'S GREAT RECOGNITION PROGRAM
AS IT EXISTS NOW. BUT HAVING THE
IMPRINT OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND THE GOVERNOR
PARTICIPATING, POTENTIALLY IN
THE AWARD CEREMONIES AND THE
RECOGNITION THAT COMES FROM THAT
IS A SIGNIFICANT ADVANTAGE TO
HAVING A STATEWIDE PROGRAM.
HOWEVER, WE HAVE TO GET IT TO
THAT PLACE. WELL I JUST WANT TO
SAY, AS SOMEBODY THAT'S
CONSERVATIVE AND DOESN'T THINK
WE NEED MORE GOVERNMENT, I LIKE
THE OPPORTUNITY THAT IT'S A
VOLUNTARY PROGRAM AND IT
ACTUALLY WORKS. PEOPLE ABIDE BY
IT. SO I'M GOING TO BE
SUPPORTING IT. I DON'T THINK
THAT WE NEED TO HAVE MONEY SPENT
TO DO SOMETHING. THAT'S RIGHT.
IF YOU WANT TO DO WHAT'S RIGHT,
THEN DO WHAT'S RIGHT AND WE CAN
RECOGNIZE THAT. AND PEOPLE TEND
TO WANT TO DO WHAT'S RIGHT. I
MEAN, WHO DOESN'T WANT BLUE
SKIES AND BLUE WHALES? I MEAN,
COME ON, I'LL MOVE THE BILL.
OKAY THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE? I
THINK THAT SENATOR DALI MADE MY
CLOTHES. OKAY, GREAT. ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. EVERYBODY,
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
AB 2298. THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED AS AMENDED, TO
APPROPRIATIONS. SENATORS ALLEN I
ALLEN I DALLY DALLY I GONZALEZ
HURTADO, MENGIBAR NGUYEN.
SKINNER. OKAY, OKAY. THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT. I SEE ASSEMBLYMEMBER
BONTA HERE, SHE'S HERE TO
PRESENT ITEM 17. THAT'S AB 2851.
GOOD RESOURCE. YOU MAY PROCEED
ONE READY? HELLO, CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS, I WANT TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE AND THEIR
STAFF FOR WORKING VERY CLOSELY
WITH MY TEAM TO PROVIDE
AMENDMENTS TO THIS BILL, WHICH I
ACCEPT AT THIS MOMENT. I DECIDED
TO AUTHOR AB 2851 TO PROTECT THE
COMMUNITY IN THE 18TH DISTRICT
AND ACROSS CALIFORNIA WITH TOXIC
AIR EMISSIONS FROM MULTIPLE,
FROM METAL SHREDDING FACILITIES.
WHY? MY DISTRICT IS A HOME TO A
METAL SHREDDING FACILITY,
SHREDDER WASTE FROM VEHICLES AND
LARGE APPLIANCES CONTAIN HEAVY
METALS LIKE LEAD, COPPER, ZINC,
CADMIUM AND HAZARDOUS CHEMICALS.
FOR DECADES, SUCH OPERATIONS
HAVE RESULTED IN MANY TOXIC
FIRES, POLLUTION, POLLUTING OUR
COMMUNITIES, EVEN THOUGH PRIOR
LEGISLATION CALLED ON DTSC TO
PLACE STRONG REGULATORY
STANDARDS ON METAL SHREDDERS,
NUMEROUS INCIDENTS HAVE
JEOPARDIZED THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY OF CALIFORNIANS AND THEIR
ENVIRONMENT SINCE 2018, THE
LOCAL AIR DISTRICT IN OUR
COMMUNITY HAS ISSUED 13 NOTICES
OF VIOLATION TO THE METAL
SHREDDING FACILITY. THE METAL
SHREDDER FACILITY HAS ALSO BEEN
THE SUBJECT OF LAWSUITS FOR
VIOLATING EMISSIONS RULES.
LOCATED WITHIN A MILE OF THIS
METAL SHREDDING FACILITY ARE 18
DAYCARE CENTERS, TEN PARKS,
EIGHT SCHOOLS, FOUR SENIOR
CENTERS, AND TWO HOSPITALS.
WHILE MOTIVATED TO WORK ON THIS
ISSUE FROM THE EXPERIENCES IN MY
BACKYARD, THIS ISN'T JUST A
PROBLEM IN MY DISTRICT. SIMILAR
TO REFINERIES, METAL SHREDDING
FACILITIES ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY LOCATED IN
OUR MOST VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES,
WHICH ARE UNDERSERVED AND ARE
ALREADY SUFFERING FROM HIGHER
AMOUNTS OF POLLUTION EXPOSURE
KNOWN TO CAUSE NEGATIVE HEALTH
IMPACTS LIKE CANCER, ASTHMA, AND
OTHER RESPIRATORY AND HEART
DISEASE. AB 2851 IS AN ESSENTIAL
FIRST STEP IN ACCOUNTABILITY. AB
2851 WILL BRING TOGETHER LOCAL
AIR MANAGEMENT DISTRICTS, THE
OFFICE OF ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH
HAZARD ASSESSMENT AND DTSC TO
DEVELOP AND IMPLEMENT FACILITY
WIDE FENCE LINE AIR MONITORING
AND METAL SHREDDING FACILITIES.
LOCAL AIR MANAGEMENT DISTRICTS
WILL DEVELOP THRESHOLD LEVELS
FOR AIRBORNE CONTAMINANTS AT
THESE FACILITIES AND DETERMINE
THE COMMUNITY NOTIFICATION
PROCESS. AB 2851 WILL PUSH
FORWARD THE STATE'S COMMITMENT
TO ADVANCING ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE AND EQUITY FOR THOSE WHO
ARE IMPACTED THE MOST BY TOXIC
EMISSIONS, AND I KNOW, CHAIR,
THAT THIS IS ALSO AN ISSUE THAT
YOU ARE VERY PASSIONATE ABOUT
AND HAVE DONE A LOT OF GREAT
WORK IN. I BELIEVE THAT THERE IS
GREAT SYNERGY BETWEEN
LEGISLATION THAT YOU'RE MOVING
FORWARD THIS YEAR AND AB 2851,
AND I WILL BE PROUD TO CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH YOU ON THAT WITH ME
TODAY TO SPEAK MORE ON THESE
BILLS. ALLEN ABS FROM THE BAY
AREA AIR QUALITY MANAGEMENT
DISTRICT AND DARRYL LITTLE,
JUNIOR FROM THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL. THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING, CHAIR ALLEN.
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE AGAIN
ALLEN AB. SO WITH THE BAY AREA
AIR QUALITY MANAGEMENT DISTRICT,
WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BONTA FROM FROM THE
INTRODUCTION OF THIS BILL, AND
TO GET TO WHAT WE ALL WANT AND
THAT IS TO HAVE METAL SHREDDERS
OPERATE IN CALIFORNIA BETTER, TO
NOT ALLOW LIGHT FIBROUS MATERIAL
ASSOCIATE AND ASSOCIATED TOXIC
PARTICULATE PAST THE FACILITY
BOUNDARY AND TO NOT HAVE THOSE
FACILITIES CATCH ON FIRE AND TO
HAVE A NOTIFICATION PROCEDURE
THAT INFORMS THE COMMUNITY WHEN
THOSE STANDARDS AREN'T BEING
MET. AS THE ANALYSIS NOTES,
THERE'S A LEGISLATIVE HISTORY
ASSOCIATED WITH TRYING TO
IMPROVE METAL SHREDDER
OPERATIONS. BUT DESPITE BEING
MAKING PROGRESS, THERE'S STILL
RECENT INSTANCES DEMONSTRATING
THAT THERE'S MORE TO BE DONE.
AND IF NO ONE KNOWS WHEN
EMISSIONS CROSS THE BOUNDARY,
THEN THE PUBLIC CAN'T BE
APPROPRIATELY INFORMED AND THE
FACILITY HAS NO INCENTIVE TO
OPERATE BETTER. AS THE ANALYSIS
ALSO NOTES, DTSC WITH THE
ASSISTANCE OF THE AIR DISTRICT,
CONDUCTED AN AIR MONITORING
STUDY AND COLLECTED LIGHT
FIBROUS MATERIAL OUTSIDE THE
SCHNITZER FACILITY BOUNDARY FOR
A MULTI-YEAR PERIOD ENDING IN
2023. THE ANALYSIS ALSO NOTES
THAT A FACILITY IN REDWOOD CITY,
NEAR SEVERAL HOSPITALS, PARKS
AND SCHOOLS RECEIVED AN ORDER TO
CLEAN UP OFFSITE TOXIC POLLUTION
OVER CONCERNS OF NEGATIVE HEALTH
IMPACTS. AB 2851 ATTEMPTS TO
PROTECT PEOPLE LIVING, WORKING
AND GOING TO SCHOOL NEAR METAL
SHREDDING FACILITIES AND, IF
NEEDED, INFORM THEM OF ANY
ADVERSE HEALTH IMPACTS AND IS
CONSISTENT WITH ACTIONS TAKEN IN
THE PAST. ONLY AFTER ELEVATED
CONCERNS FROM THE PUBLIC. THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK
ON THIS TOPIC. I'M HERE TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
GOOD MORNING, CHAIR AND MEMBERS,
GERALD LITTLE, JUNIOR WITH NRDC
HERE IN SUPPORT OF AB 2851 METAL
SHREDDING FACILITIES PLACE AN
INCREDIBLE BURDEN ON CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITIES, PARTICULARLY LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES AND
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR. METAL
SHREDDERS ACROSS THE STATE,
THROUGH THEIR SHREDDING PROCESS,
RELEASE SUBSTANTIAL AMOUNTS OF
DANGEROUS AIR POLLUTION TO
SURROUNDING COMMUNITIES,
INCLUDING PARTICULATE MATTER,
LEAD, CADMIUM AND LIGHT FIBROUS
MATERIAL. WE KNOW METAL METAL
SHREDDER FACILITIES RELEASE
THESE POLLUTANTS ONLY BECAUSE OF
AD HOC ENFORCEMENT ACTIONS BY
THE STATE AND ADVOCACY BY
COMMUNITY GROUPS OVER THE PAST
DECADE. BUT THESE AD HOC ACTIONS
ARE NOT SUFFICIENT TO PROTECT
COMMUNITIES FROM METAL SHREDDER
POLLUTION. IN REAL TIME. AB 2851
IS AN IMPORTANT STEP IN THAT
DIRECTION. IT REQUIRE FENCE LINE
AIR QUALITY MONITORING AT ALL
METAL SHREDDING FACILITIES
ACROSS THE STATE FOR THE
POLLUTANTS. MOST CLOSELY
ASSOCIATED WITH METAL SHREDDERS,
AND IT WOULD ENSURE THAT NEARBY
COMMUNITIES ARE ALERTED WITH
WHEN POLLUTION LEVELS IN THE AIR
THEY BREATHE EXCEED REGULATORY
THRESHOLDS. IT IS CRITICAL THAT
REGULATORS AND THE PUBLIC ALIKE
KNOW WHAT POLLUTION IS LEAVING
THESE FACILITIES AND HARMING
CALIFORNIANS IN THEIR HOMES,
SCHOOLS, PARKS AND PLACES OF
WORK. FOR THAT REASON, WE
RESPECTFULLY URGE YOUR AYE VOTE
ON AB 2851. THANK YOU. GREAT ALL
RIGHT. OTHER FOLKS WANT TO VOICE
SUPPORT FOR THE BILL. GOOD
MORNING, CHAIR MEMBERS. ROSS
BARKLEY, ON BEHALF OF SOUTH
COAST AIR QUALITY MANAGEMENT
DISTRICT. WE HAVE A SUPPORTIVE,
AMENDED POSITION, BUT WE'VE HAD
A NUMBER OF GOOD CONVERSATIONS
WITH AUTHORS OFFICE. THANKS
THANK YOU. SOPHIA KHÎI WITH THE
COALITION FOR CLEAN AIR AND
SUPPORT. JACOB EVANS WITH SIERRA
CLUB CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. GREAT FOLKS WANT TO
RAISE CONCERNS OR OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL. SEEING NONE QUESTIONS
FROM THE MEMBERS. SO I READ UP
ON THE OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED. SO
BASICALLY THE QUESTION I HAVE IS
DTSC VERSUS THE LOCAL AIR
POLLUTION CONTROL. WHAT'S THE,
WHY IS IT WHY ARE YOU USING DTSC
AS YOUR INSTEAD OF USING THE AIR
CON AIR LOCAL AIR CONTROL
OFFICERS? THE AMENDMENTS THAT WE
ACCEPTED THROUGH COMMITTEE
ACTUALLY ADDRESSED THAT,
THROUGHOUT THIS PROCESS, THERE'S
BEEN KIND OF A DEBATE AND
DISCUSSION AROUND WHAT THE KIND
OF PURVIEW OF DTSC VERSUS THE
LOCAL AIR DISTRICTS WERE GOING
TO BE AT THIS POINT. THE LOCAL
AIR DISTRICTS ARE SPECIFICALLY
GOING TO BE FOCUSED IN ON, THE,
AIR MONITORING PARTNERSHIPS IN
WITH AIR WITH AIR DISTRICTS AS
THE MAJOR PIECE OF IT. THEY WILL
BE FOCUSED ON, EVERY OTHER
CONTAMINANT BESIDES LIGHT,
FIBROUS MATERIALS, WHICH WILL BE
UNDER THE MANAGEMENT OF DTSC. SO
WE ESSENTIALLY KIND OF TRIED TO
STRIKE A NICE BALANCE BETWEEN
WHAT WE KNEW DTSC ALREADY HAD
PURVIEW OVER AND ENSURING THAT
THE LOCAL AIR DISTRICTS HAD THE
ABILITY TO, FOCUS IN ON WHAT
THEY HAD ALREADY BEEN FOCUSED ON
WITH IN PARTNERSHIP WITH OHA. SO
IS THIS A NEW PRECEDENT TO USE
DTSC VERSUS THE LOCAL AIR
AGENCIES? I CAN'T SPEAK TO
ANYTHING OUTSIDE OF METAL
SHREDDING FACILITIES. I DON'T
KNOW. YOU CAN SPEAK TO THAT
BECAUSE THEY'RE GOING TO COLLECT
THE FEE. DTSC IS GOING TO
COLLECT THE FEE. TYPICALLY, THE
LOCAL AIR AGENCY WOULD BE THE
PERSON THAT WOULD COLLECT THE
FEE. AND THEN AND MONITORING
WITH THE WITH THE AMENDMENTS,
ACTUALLY THE FEES CAN EITHER GO
TO THE LOCAL AIR DISTRICT OR TO
DTSC, WHICH WILL BE PAID FOR BY
THE DISMANTLING THE FEES
ASSOCIATED FROM THE METAL
SHREDDING FACILITIES. THEN HOW
DO YOU DIFFERENTIATE BETWEEN WHO
IF THERE'S OTHER, MANUFACTURING
OR SOMETHING CLOSE BY, THEY
DON'T HAVE TO PAY THE FEE SO
THAT THE BURDEN LAYS ON THE ONE
FACILITY. OR HOW DO YOU
DETERMINE WHERE ALL THE
POLLUTANTS ARE COMING FROM? THE
FOCUS OF THIS BILL IS AROUND
CREATING A FENCELINE MONITORING
TO BE ABLE TO DO THAT. SO
ESSENTIALLY THE FENCE LINE IS
CREATED AROUND THE METAL
SHREDDING FACILITY, WHICH WILL
CREATE A HIGH ATTRIBUTION LEVEL
TO THAT METAL SHREDDING
FACILITY. OKAY YEAH. WELL, I
WANT TO THANK THE, THE AUTHOR
FOR, FOR YOUR YOUR WORK ON THIS
TOO. AND WE KNOW, OF COURSE, IN
YOUR DISTRICT HAS BEEN
PARTICULARLY IMPACTED BY THIS
CHALLENGE. AND IT'S SOMETHING
THAT'S BEEN COMING UP IN THE
CONTEXT OF OUR BILL. SO I'M
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE YOU WORKING
WITH US. WE, THERE'S SOME
EXTENSIVE AMENDMENTS THAT I
THINK, PUT THE BILL IN A, IN A
GOOD PLACE. AND, I'M CERTAINLY
LOOKING FORWARD TO SUPPORTING
THE BILL. I DON'T KNOW IF MY
COLLEAGUES WANT TO MOVE THE BILL
OR IF WE WANT TO WAIT FOR WE MAY
WANT TO MAKE. OKAY. ALL RIGHT,
IF YOU WANT TO CLOSE. THANK YOU.
I FIRST JUST WANT TO RECOGNIZE
THAT EVERY SINGLE TIME I'VE BEEN
ABLE TO TESTIFY, I PRESENT THIS
BILL IN COMMITTEE. I HAVE HAD
THE BEAUTY OF A FORCE CALLED
MISS MARGARET. COME FORWARD.
WHO'S A RESIDENT IN WEST OAKLAND
WHO HAS MADE IT HER LIFE'S WORK
TO REALLY DEFEND THE BASIC AIR
OF AND HEALTH AND SAFETY OF THE
COMMUNITY IN WEST OAKLAND. TWO
WEEKS AFTER SCHOOL STARTED IN
WEST OAKLAND, CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES WOKE UP TO ORANGE SKIES
FROM THE FIRE THAT WAS CREATED
BY THE 13TH VIOLATION FROM OUR
LOCAL AIR METAL AIR SHREDDING
FACILITY. AND THAT'S JUST
UNACCEPTABLE. WE NEED TO BE ABLE
TO PROVIDE PARAMETERS TO BE ABLE
TO ENSURE THAT THAT DOESN'T
HAPPEN. I'M THANKFUL TO HEAR
THAT YOU'RE MOVING FORWARD. SB
1234 I THINK OUR BILL AS AB
2851, WHICH I ALSO JUST WANT TO
THANK MY DISTRICT DIRECTOR,
ROWENA BROWN, FOR REALLY
BRINGING THE ISSUE TO OUR
ATTENTION, WORKING THIS BILL AND
HAVING THIS BE REPRESENTATIVE OF
A TRUE PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN LOCAL
ON THE GROUND, IN THE FIELD
STAKEHOLDERS WHO HAVE A DESIRE
TO PROTECT THEIR COMMUNITY AND
OUR STATE AND COUNTY AGENCIES TO
MAKE SURE THAT OUR LIVES ARE
HEALTHIER FOR CALIFORNIANS. WITH
THAT, I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOUR AYE VOTE. OKAY. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. AB 2851. THE
MOTION IS DUE. PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS. SENATORS
ALLEN I, ALLEN I, DALLI.
GONZALEZ HURTADO, MENGIBAR
NGUYEN. SKINNER OKAY. LEAVE THAT
OPEN FOR FOLKS TO ADD ON. OKAY.
WHY DON'T WE, FIRST ENTERTAIN A
MOTION? ORPHALI SORRY FOR
CONSENT. NO, WE HAVEN'T DONE
CONSENT YET. AND ZYGIER CURRY,
WE'RE CALLING HER AGUIAR-CURRY
AND GARCIA WERE PRESENTING, AND
THEY SHOULD BE OVER AFTER THAT.
OKAY I WILL SEND A QUICK NOTE.
ALL RIGHT. SO, SENATOR DOLLY HAS
MOVED THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
LET'S CALL THE ROLL ON THAT.
SENATORS ALLEN, I, ALLEN, I
DALLY A DALLY. I GONZALEZ
HURTADO MENGIBAR NGUYEN NGUYEN I
SKINNER. OKAY, WHY DON'T WE GO
THROUGH. LET'S LIFT SOME CALLS,
AND THEN WE MAY NEED TO TAKE
SOME MOTIONS IF THEY'RE AROUND,
LET'S FIRST. SO WE'VE ALREADY
DONE. ALL RIGHT. LET'S START
WITH ITEM ONE. THAT'S BACK, SEED
LABELING BILL OKAY. ALL RIGHT.
OKAY MOVED ON. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL AB 1042. THE
MOTION IS DUE. PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS. SENATORS
ALLEN I, ALLEN I DALI. GONZALEZ.
HURTADO MENGIBAR NGUYEN SKINNER.
OKAY, WE'LL HOLD THAT OPEN.
THANK YOU EVERYBODY, ABOUT NOW.
NEXT WE'LL DO A BAUER-KAHAN AB
2085, WHICH HAS BEEN MOVED
ALREADY. OKAY THE CURRENT VOTE
ON AB 2085 IS 2 TO 0. THE MOTION
IS DUE PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. SENATORS DALI,
NO. DALI NO. GONZALEZ. MENGIBAR
NGUYEN. NO. NGUYEN. NO. SKINNER
OKAY, WE'LL HOLD THAT ONE OPEN,
NEXT ITEM THREE. MOTION FOR
2214. YOU NEED A MOTION? YEAH
OKAY. MOVED. THANK YOU. AB 2214
Ã. THE MOTION IS DUE. PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. SENATORS ALLEN I
ALLEN I DOLLY. DOLLY NÓ
GONZALEZ. HURTADO MENGIBAR.
NGUYEN. SKINNER OKAY, WE'LL HOLD
THAT OPEN. I AB 2236, THAT HAS A
MOTION ALREADY. SENATORS. OH,
THE VOTE ON AB 2236 IS 2 TO 1
WITH THE CHAIR VOTING AYE AND
THE VICE CHAIR VOTING NO. THE
MOTION IS DUE. PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS. SENATORS
GONZALEZ MENGIBAR NGUYEN. NÓ.
NGUYEN. NO. SKINNER OKAY. NEXT
WE'LL DO. JASMEET BAINS AB 1122
AB 1122. THE MOTION IS DUE PASS
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
THE CURRENT VOTE IS 2 TO 0.
SENATORS. DOLLY DOLLY I,
GONZALEZ. MENGIBAR NGUYEN.
NGUYEN I SKINNER. OKAY, WE'LL
HOLD THAT OPEN. ITEM SIX AB
1296. WE NEED A MOTION. THANKS,
MR. VICE CHAIR, AB 1296, THE
MOTION IS DUE. PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. SENATORS ALLEN
I, ALLEN I, DOLLY I, DALI I
GONZALEZ HURTADO, MENGIBAR
NGUYEN. NGUYEN I SKINNER. OKAY,
LET'S GO TO PAPINE AB 1359, WE
NEED A MOTION, SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL AB 1359. THE
MOTION IS DUE. PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. SENATORS ALLEN I
ALLEN I DOLLY I DOLLY I GONZALEZ
HURTADO, MENGIBAR NGUYEN NGUYEN
I SKINNER. OKAY, PAT BINNS AB
1921. NEED A MOTION. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL AB 1921.
THE MOTION IS DUE. PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. SENATORS ALLEN,
I ALLEN I DOLLY. DOLLY I
GONZALEZ. HURTADO MENGIBAR
NGUYEN. SKINNER OKAY, WE'LL NEXT
GO TO BERMAN'S AB 2083. NEED A
MOTION? I'LL MOVE IT. OKAY. AB
2083, THE MOTION IS DUE. PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
SENATORS ALLEN I, ALLEN I, DOLLY.
DOLLY NÓ GONZALEZ. HURTADO
MENGIBAR NGUYEN. NGUYEN. NO.
SKINNER OKAY. AB 2298. HART. WE
ALREADY HAVE A MOTION. AB 2298.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS, AS
AMENDED, TO APPROPRIATIONS. THE
CURRENT VOTE IS 2 TO 0. SENATORS
GONZALEZ HURTADO, MENGIBAR
NGUYEN NGUYEN I. SKINNER ALL
RIGHT, SENATOR WILSON'S AB 2300
AB 2300. THE MOTION IS DUE.
PASS. THE CURRENT VOTE IS 2 TO
0. SENATORS GONZALEZ HURTADO
MENGIBAR NGUYEN NGUYEN I.
SKINNER OKAY, AB 2346 NEED A
MOTION AB 2346 THE MOTION IS
DUE. PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. THE SENATORS
ALLEN I, ALLEN I DOLLY. DOLLY I
GONZALEZ HURTADO, MENGIBAR
NGUYEN I NGUYEN I SKINNER OKAY,
LET'S LET ASSEMBLYMEMBER GARCIA
PRESENT HIS BILL. WE'LL GO TO,
THIS IS ITEM 20, AB 3238. I
THINK THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR AND
COLLEAGUES, I'M HERE TO PRESENT
AB 3238. FIRST OFF, I WANT TO
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR, AND YOUR
COMMITTEE CONSULTANTS, FOR THE
TIME YOU'VE PUT INTO THIS
PARTICULAR CONVERSATION, THIS
CONVERSATION HAS GONE UP UNTIL
THE WEE HOURS OF THE MORNING,
AND THAT'S NOT ALWAYS THE CASE.
AND SO I REALLY APPRECIATE THIS
MORNING AND THIS MORNING, THAT
YOU HAVE, ALLOWED US THAT,
OPENNESS. BUT, MR. CHAIR, I WANT
TO JUST BE VERY CANDID AS I
ALWAYS HAVE BEEN. AND THOSE OF
YOU WHO ARE ON THE DAIS KNOW ME
TO BE, WHEN THE ANALYSIS ON
MONDAY WAS ROLLED OUT, I WAS
QUITE SURPRISED AT SOME OF THE
INACCURACIES THAT IT CONTAINED,
AND WE BROUGHT THAT TO YOUR
ATTENTION. AND WE AND WE SHARED
WITH YOU WHAT THOSE WERE, IN OUR
INTERPRETATION AND PERSPECTIVE,
IT'S A MISINTERPRETATION OF A
NUMBER OF DIFFERENT THINGS,
INCLUDING VOTE COUNTS FROM PRIOR
COMMITTEES TO USING OPPOSING
ARGUMENTS THAT WERE INTRODUCED
IN PRIOR VERSIONS OF THE BILL
THAT NO LONGER ARE RELEVANT DUE
TO AMENDMENTS THAT WE TOOK TO
ADDRESS THE CONCERNS OVER THE
COURSE OF FOUR POLICY
COMMITTEES, INCLUDING THE
APPROPRIATIONS THAT ALSO TOOK A
POLICY STAB AT THE BILL AND ONE
IN THE SENATE. YES, YES, YOU DID.
YOU CORRECT THE TWO PARTICULAR
ONES THAT I'LL POINT OUT THE
VOTE COUNT AND THE OUTDATED
LETTER. BUT BUT WHAT WASN'T
REALLY ADDRESSED WAS THE
SUBSTANCE. RIGHT. AND THERE ARE
NUMEROUS OTHER INACCURACIES IN
THE ANALYSIS THAT MISSTATES THE
CURRENT OPERATION OF SEQUA
REVIEW AT THE CPUC. THE
COMMISSION ALREADY HAS THE
ABILITY TO LIMIT THE RANGE OF
ALTERNATIVES IN THE EIR SEQUA
THE COMMISSION, THE CEQA DOES
NOT REQUIRE AN AGENCY TO INCLUDE
ALL POTENTIAL ALTERNATIVES. IT
REQUIRES A REASONABLE RANGE OF
ALTERNATIVES THAT MEET MOST
PROJECT OBJECTIVES. THE ANALYSIS
ALSO COMPLETELY IGNORES THE
ROBUST PUBLIC PROCESS THAT CASA
UNDERGOES PRIOR TO APPROVAL OF
TRANSMISSION PROJECTS. THIS IS
WHERE THE GRID OPERATOR USES THE
EXPERTISE TO DETERMINE WHETHER
THE STATEWIDE SYSTEM REQUIRES
TRANSMISSION PROJECT. IT ALSO
MISSTATES THE WAY THAT AN
ELECTRICAL INFRASTRUCTURE
PROJECT MOVES THROUGH AGENCY
APPROVAL, OBTAINING, RIGHT OF
WAY IS NOT THE FIRST STEP OF A
PROJECT FOR THE PROJECTS THAT
ARE ADDRESSED BY THIS BILL, THE
FIRST STEP IS TO FILE AN
APPLICATION WITH THE CPUC, WHICH
TRIGGERS THEIR SECRET REVIEW.
UNFORTUNATELY, THE LATEST
PROPOSED COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS GO
TOO FAR, AND I DO NOT FEEL
COMFORTABLE ACCEPTING THOSE
TODAY. AND, YOU KNOW, TYPICALLY
WE COME BEFORE A COMMITTEE AND
WE THANK EVERYONE FOR THEIR
WORK. AND WE SAY WE RESPECTFULLY
AND GRATEFULLY ACCEPT THOSE
AMENDMENTS. BUT WE JUST DON'T
FEEL COMFORTABLE, GIVEN THE
INACCURACIES OF THE ANALYSIS
THAT MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE
WILL HAVE HAD A VERY ACCURATE
DEPICTION OF THE BILL, THAT'S
BEFORE THEM, THAT'S RECEIVED A
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF SCRUTINY
AND A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT
POLICIES. AND WE'RE HAPPY TO
HAVE THAT CONVERSATION AND
DEBATE OR DELIBERATION WITH THE
EXPERTS THAT ARE HERE TODAY TO
SPEAK ABOUT IT, AND THE EXPERTS
THAT ARE SITTING ON THE DAIS.
BUT LET ME JUST GET TO THE CORE
OF THE INTENTION OF THE BILL.
IT'S A SIMPLE EFFORT. IT'S TO
ACCELERATE THE BUILDOUT OF
ELECTRIC TRANSMISSION
INFRASTRUCTURE SO WE CAN MEET
THE CLIMATE GOALS. THIS
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR
CREATED, WHILE STILL ENSURING
PROJECTS STILL GO THROUGH FULL
ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW. LET ME BE
CLEAR, MEMBERS, IF THE CURRENT
VERSION OF THIS BILL GOES INTO
EFFECT, NOT ONE SHOVEL WILL GO
INTO THE GROUND WITHOUT A
SEQUEL. REVIEW OF THE PROJECT.
THE BILL ONLY AIMS TO REMOVE
DUPLICATIVE REVIEWS AT THE CPUC
AND LEVERAGE WORK THAT CAISO THE
STATE'S TRANSMISSION PLANNING
AUTHORITY ALREADY DOES, SO THAT
THE SIGNIFICANT TIME AND DELAYS
ARE REMOVED FROM TRANSMISSION
PROJECTS AND ITS TIMELINES. IN
OUR CONVERSATIONS OVER THE PAST
SEVERAL WEEKS, I HAVE HEARD
CONCERNS FROM YOU, MR. CHAIR,
FROM THE OPPOSITION, I'M HOPING
THAT WE CAN HAVE A ROBUST
DISCUSSION, TO ENSURE THAT ONE
ONE OF THE FOCUSES OF THE BILLS
HAS BEEN THE SETTLEMENT
AGREEMENT THAT'S BEEN IN
DISCUSSIONS FOR QUITE SOME TIME,
NUMBER TWO IS THAT WE HAVE TAKEN
THIS EFFORT ONE STEP FURTHER TO
LOOK AT WAYS THAT CEQA CAN BE
REFORMED IN THE MOST PRAGMATIC
WAY, WHERE RIGHT OF WAYS EXIST,
WHERE LAND HAS BEEN DISTURBED
AND WHERE WE CAN BE PRACTICAL IN
NATURE, NO PUN INTENDED, TO BOTH
PROTECT IT, BUT ALSO ACCELERATE
OUR BUILDOUT OF OUR TRANSMISSION
TO GET POWER TO WHERE IT NEEDS
TO GO. SO THAT WE CAN CONTINUE
TO MEET THESE GOALS, BUT ALSO
SEE A ECONOMIC THRIVING STATE IN
SPECIFIC REGIONS OF CALIFORNIA,
THAT THAT NEED THIS POWER, OUR
STATE HAS SET THESE TARGETS, FOR
A REASON. RIGHT, WE'RE NOT GOING
TO MEET THEM IF WE DON'T TAKE
THESE TYPES OF BOLD ACTIONS. I,
I RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT, WE HAVE
THIS OPEN DISCUSSION AND THAT WE
CAN LEAVE FROM HERE WITH AN
UNDERSTANDING THAT WE ARE
COMMITTED TO CONTINUING TO WORK
ON THIS MATTER AND, AND TRY TO
ACHIEVE THE OBJECTIVES. I THINK
THAT YOU'VE PUT FORWARD IN
CONCEPT, BUT THAT REALLY LAND AT
A PLACE WHERE IT KEEPS US ON
TRACK TO MEETING THESE, ENERGY
GOALS FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WITH ME. IS OUR KEY
WITNESS THAT WILL TALK ABOUT,
THE DETAILS OF THE BILL AND
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THAT I'VE
PUT ON THE TABLE, ERICA MARTIN,
DIRECTOR OF ENVIRONMENTAL
SERVICES, SAN DIEGO GAS AND
ELECTRIC COMPANY. GREAT. I'M
LOOKING FORWARD TO HEARING FROM
ERICA BY, ALL I WOULD SAY IS,
THAT I THINK YOU POINTED OUT A
COUPLE OF, OF INACCURACIES THAT
WE BOTH AGREED WERE INACCURACIES,
THOSE WERE CORRECTED. IN THE
ANALYSIS. I THINK THE REST ARE
ISSUES WHERE THERE'S A CERTAIN
POINT OF DISCUSSION AND DEBATE
AND DISAGREEMENT. BUT, YOU KNOW,
AS YOU KNOW, I'M HAPPY TO
CONTINUE THAT THOSE DISCUSSIONS
AND, BUT, I THINK TO SOME EXTENT
THERE'S AN AGREEMENT TO DISAGREE
OVER, OVER SEVERAL THINGS THAT
YOU MENTIONED. ASSEMBLYMEMBER'S.
SO I'D LOVE TO HEAR FROM, FROM
YOUR WITNESS, GOOD MORNING. I'M
VERY HAPPY TO BE WITH YOU TODAY
IN SUPPORT OF AB 3238 AND THE
ESSENTIAL ROLE IT WILL PLAY IN
THE CLEAN ENERGY TRANSITION, SDG
AND E IS VERY ENCOURAGED AT THE
GROWING ACKNOWLEDGMENT THAT WE
WILL, AS A STATE, NEED TO BUILD
ELECTRIC INFRASTRUCTURE
TRANSMISSION INFRASTRUCTURE AT
AN UNPRECEDENTED RATE AND SCALE.
HOWEVER, WE ARE VERY CONCERNED
THAT SOME STAKEHOLDERS,
INCLUDING SOME OF THE OPPOSITION
HERE TODAY, STATE THEIR
UNDERSTANDING OF THESE FACTS.
BUT CONTINUE TO CLING TO THE
STATUS QUO AND OPPOSE EVEN
MODEST CHANGES TO ACCELERATE THE
PROCESS. THE FACT IS, WE CAN NO
LONGER SIMPLY PAY LIP SERVICE TO
THIS ISSUE IF OUR PLANET IS
FACING AN EXISTENTIAL CRISIS,
THEN WE NEED TO TAKE SOME ACTION
AS IF IT IS THE EXISTING PROCESS
FOR APPROVAL TO CONSTRUCT
ELECTRIC INFRASTRUCTURE IS
DUPLICATIVE. IT IS LENGTHY AND
COSTLY. BY THE TIME A
TRANSMISSION PROJECT COMES TO
THE CPUC FOR AUTHORITY TO
APPROVE, IT HAS ALREADY
UNDERGONE YEARS OF REGULATORY
PLANNING AND FORECASTING AT THE
CPUC. AT THE CEC, AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY, AT THE CALIFORNIA
INDEPENDENT SYSTEM OPERATOR. OUR
STATE TRANSMISSION AUTHORITY. WE
CAN NO LONGER AFFORD 5 TO 10
YEARS OF PERMITTING AND REVIEW
AND YEARS OF CONSTRUCTION BEFORE
A PROCESS COMES ONLINE. FROM THE
PERSPECTIVE OF AN ENTITY THAT IS
BEING ASKED BY CAISO TO BUILD
THESE PROJECTS, I'M HERE TO SAY
THAT THE STATUS QUO OF PROCESS
AND PROCEDURE WILL NOT ALLOW US
TO GET THERE. WE WILL NOT BE
ABLE TO MOVE THE CLEAN ENERGY
TRANSITION FORWARD AND PROTECT
THE ENVIRONMENT FROM THE RISKS
OF A WARMING CLIMATE. AB 3238 IS
A MEASURED PROPOSAL THAT FOCUSES
ON THE PLACES WHERE THERE ARE
THE MOST OBSTACLES TO THESE
PROJECTS, AS WE HAVE FULFILLED,
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GARCIA'S
COMMITMENT TO WORK WITH ALL
INTERESTED STAKEHOLDERS, THE
BILL HAS BECOME EVEN MORE
MEASURED AND NARROWLY TAILORED
WITH A SHARP FOCUS. THE CPUC
RULES FOR PERMITTING ELECTRIC
INFRASTRUCTURE ARE OF PRIMARY
CONCERN. THE PROPOSED REFORMS DO
NOT ELIMINATE CPUC OVERSIGHT,
AND THEY DO NOT ELIMINATE CEQA
REVIEW FOR THE PROJECTS THAT GO
BEFORE THEM. AMONG OTHER THINGS,
THE BILL WOULD APPLY A NINE
MONTH TIME LIMIT FOR THE CPUC. S
REVIEW AND WOULD ALSO LEVERAGE
THE IMPORTANT TRANSMISSION
PLANNING OF CAISO SO THAT THE
CPUC DOES NOT HAVE TO REDO THE
WORK THAT CAISO HAS ALREADY
UNDERTAKEN, AND FOR WHICH THEY
DO NOT HAVE THE EXPERTISE. TAKEN
TOGETHER, THESE WILL RESULT IN
MEANINGFUL REDUCTION OF
PERMITTING TIMELINE IN ADDITION,
THE BILL CONTAINS A NARROWLY
TAILORED CEQA EXEMPTION FOR THE
ACQUISITION OF THE LAND RIGHT
BEFORE ANY PHYSICAL IMPACT TO
THE LAND. THIS WOULD ONLY OCCUR
WHEN A UTILITY HAS EXISTING
RIGHT OF WAY, AND TO BE CLEAR,
THE PROJECT ITSELF WOULD NOT BE
EXEMPT FROM CEQA. ONLY THE
AGENCY DECISION TO PROVIDE THE
LAND RIGHT. THIS CONCLUDES MY
TESTIMONY. THANK YOU AGAIN FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO APPEAR BEFORE
THE COMMITTEE. OKAY. FOLKS WHO
WANT TO VOICE SUPPORT FOR THE
BILL CHIRLA MEMBERS, JOHN WHITE
WITH THE CLEAN POWER CAMPAIGN,
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL
BECAUSE THE SETTLEMENT AGREEMENT
WAS DEVELOPED AT THE PUC BY 18
PARTIES FROM ACROSS ALL THE
SECTORS. THERE IS A FAILURE ON
THE PC'S PART TO RECOGNIZE THE
URGENCY OF MAKING REFORMS AND
THE TIME IT TAKES TO REVIEW
THESE PROJECTS. WE THINK THAT
WITHOUT MAJOR STREAMLINING, OF
WHICH THIS BILL NOW STILL HAS
IMPORTANT PROVISIONS DESPITE THE
AMENDMENTS, THAT WE'RE NOT GOING
TO MEET OUR TARGETS. WE'RE
SIMPLY WE MIGHT AS WELL JUST SAY
WE'RE NOT GOING TO GET THERE
BECAUSE THERE IS NO TRANSITION
TO CLEAN ENERGY WITHOUT BUILDING
6 TO 8, NINE LINES AT A TIME,
INSTEAD OF JUST ONE EVERY TEN
YEARS. THAT THAT'S THE SEA
CHANGE THAT WE'RE IN. AND WHILE
WE DON'T WANT TO WEAKEN OUR
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTIONS, WE DO
WANT TO SEE WHAT WE CAN DO TO
MAKE THINGS TAKE LESS TIME
WITHOUT SACRIFICING
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION. SO
WE'D ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU. MELISSA CORTEZ, ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA WIND ENERGY
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT. ELLEN
BRITTINGHAM, ON BEHALF OF SAN
DIEGO COMMUNITY POWER, IN
SUPPORT. JOHN MOFFAT, ON BEHALF
OF THE AMERICAN COUNCIL OF
ENGINEERING COMPANIES, IN
SUPPORT JOHN KENNEDY WITH RURAL
COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. OKAY. ALL
RIGHT, LET'S HEAR FROM
OPPOSITION.
IS IT MORNING? STILL NO GOOD
AFTERNOON, MY NAME IS KIM
DELFINO, AND I'M HERE
REPRESENTING DEFENDERS OF
WILDLIFE IN THE CALIFORNIA
NATIVE PLANT SOCIETY. LET ME
START OUT BY SAYING THAT MY
CLIENTS SUPPORT EFFICIENCIES TO
BRING TRANSMISSION ON QUICKLY.
AND THEY'VE BEEN WORKING VERY
HARD TO HAVE THAT HAPPEN IN THE
DESERT AND THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA. HOWEVER EFFICIENCIES
SHOULD NOT EQUAL WEAKENING CORE
PROTECTIONS FOR CULTURAL AND
NATURAL RESOURCES. TODAY, I WANT
TO HIGHLIGHT TWO PROVISIONS IN
THIS BILL THAT ARE NOT WITHIN
THE QUOTE UNQUOTE, SETTLEMENT
AGREEMENT, WHICH IS ESSENTIALLY
A PROPOSAL BEING DEBATED BY THE
PUC RIGHT NOW. LAST NIGHT, I
REREAD ALL 138 PAGES OF THE
SETTLEMENT AGREEMENT. AND I CAN
TELL YOU TWO THINGS THAT ARE NOT
IN THAT AGREEMENT. THE FIRST
THING IS THE CEQA EXEMPTION FOR
AN EXPANSION OF RIGHT OF WAYS ON
STATE LANDS. AND THE SECOND IS A
REBUTTABLE PRESUMPTION THAT
WOULD NEGATE ANY REQUIREMENT TO
PROVIDE SUBSTANTIAL EVIDENCE IN
THE RECORD TO SUPPORT A
STATEMENT THAT OVERRIDING
BENEFITS OF A TRANSMISSION
PROJECT OUTWEIGH SIGNIFICANT
EFFECTS ON THE ENVIRONMENT, I
WAS WROTE MY TESTIMONY THINKING
WE MIGHT BE DISCUSSING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS A LITTLE
BIT MORE. LET ME JUST SIMPLY SAY
THAT THE RIGHT OF WAY EXPANSION
HONESTLY DOESN'T MAKE ANY SENSE.
YOU ARE ALLOWING A RIGHT OF WAY
EXPANSION TO GO WITHOUT ANY CEQA
ANALYSIS WHATSOEVER. YOU'RE
DEFERRING THAT ANALYSIS TO THE
ACTUAL PROJECT. I DO NOT KNOW OF
MANY TRANSMISSION PROJECTS THAT
ARE MOVING FORWARD BLINDLY,
WITHOUT DOING SURVEYS AND
FIGURING OUT IF THE RIGHT OF
WAYS THEY'RE EXPANDING INTO ARE
GOOD PLACES TO GO, OR NOT GOOD
PLACES TO GO. SO BY DOING THIS
EXEMPTION, WE ARE OPENING UP
SENSITIVE HABITATS, STATE PARKS,
POTENTIALLY CULTURAL RESOURCES
CDFW WILDLIFE AREAS, CDF W
ECOLOGICAL RESERVES AND ALL
STATE LANDS COMMISSION LANDS. AS
FOR THE REBUTTABLE PRESUMPTION,
IT'S A LOT HAS BEEN SAID THAT
THIS IS SOMEHOW IN THE
SETTLEMENT AGREEMENT. IT IS NOT
THIS IS A SIGNIFICANT ISSUE. IF
THIS BILL GOES INTO LAW, IT
ESSENTIALLY TURNS ON ITS HEAD
THE REQUIREMENT THAT IF YOU WANT
TO DO A STATEMENT OF OVERRIDE,
AND WE'RE NOT SAYING YOU
SHOULDN'T DO A STATEMENT OF
OVERRIDING CONSIDERATIONS, WE'RE
SIMPLY SAYING PROVIDE
SUBSTANTIAL EVIDENCE THAT YOU
ARE GOING TO OVERRIDE
SIGNIFICANT EFFECTS ON THE
ENVIRONMENT. AND I DON'T HAVE A
PROBLEM IF A PROJECT THAT IS IN
A TPP TAKES THE ANALYSIS, THAT'S
IN THE TPP AND PUTS IT INTO THE
STATEMENT OF OVERRIDE, BUT THAT
SHOULD NOT BE PER SE A
REBUTTABLE PRESUMPTION. IT MAY
BE ENOUGH TO PROVIDE A
NOT. THIS BILL SIMPLY SAYS WE'RE
JUST GOING TO DE FACTO GO
STRAIGHT TO THE REBUTTAL TO THE
FACT THAT THE STATEMENT OF
OVERRIDE IS OKAY, JUST BECAUSE
THE PROJECT SHOWS UP IN THE TPP.
WE'VE NEVER, EVER DONE THAT IN
CEQA. AND AGAIN, WHAT I'M TRYING
TO THERE'S A LOT OF OTHER THINGS
IN THIS BILL THAT WILL PROVIDE
EFFICIENCIES. WE'RE NOT
OBJECTING TO THOSE. WE'RE
OBJECTING TO THE PARTS IN THIS
BILL THAT ARE NOT PART OF THAT
SETTLEMENT AGREEMENT. AND FOR
THESE REASONS, IF THE AMENDMENTS
ARE NOT TAKEN AND FRANKLY, EVEN
IF THEY ARE, BECAUSE THEY STILL
WOULD HAVE OPENED UP SENSITIVE
ECOLOGICAL AREAS, WE URGE AN AYE
VOTE. I MEAN, SORRY, IT'S BEEN A
LONG WEEK AND IT'S ONLY
WEDNESDAY. WE URGE A NO VOTE ON
THIS BILL. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT,
GOOD AFTERNOON, CHAIRMAN ALAN.
AND, COMMITTEE MEMBERS, I WANT
TO. MY NAME IS RANDY WIDERA. I
AM THE DIRECTOR OF PROGRAMS AT
THE CALIFORNIA STATE PARKS
FOUNDATION. FIRST OF ALL, I'D
LIKE TO THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GARCIA, WHO'S BEEN A CHAMPION
FOR STATE PARKS, AND WE
APPRECIATE WORKING WITH HIM ON
ALL WAYS TO SUPPORT AND HELP
STATE PARKS. AND ALSO, I WANT TO
COMMEND THE COMMITTEE ON YOUR
HARD WORK ON THIS, ON THE
LANGUAGE AND IN WORKING IN GOOD
FAITH WITH US TO, AMEND THIS
BILL SO THAT IT, PROTECTS STATE
PARKS AS WELL AS HELPS WITH OUR
ENERGY INFRASTRUCTURE. I REALLY
HAD HOPED TO BE HERE TO BE
NEUTRAL ON THIS BILL, BECAUSE IT
IS IMPORTANT AND WE KNOW HOW
IMPORTANT IT IS TO EVERYONE. BUT
WITH THE 280 STATE PARKS, THEY
ARE THE BEST OF CALIFORNIA AND
THEY ARE ON THE FOREFRONT OF
FIGHTING CLIMATE CHANGE RIGHT
NOW TOO. AND WE BELIEVE THAT
WITHOUT REMOVING THE CEQA, WITH
REMOVING THE CEQA EXEMPTION AND
THE REBUTTABLE ASSUMPTIONS THAT
WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE TO PUT
THEM AT RISK AND WORK BACKWARDS.
SO WE REALLY HAVE TO REMAIN
OPPOSED UNLESS THEY'RE ADMITTED
TO, UNLESS THOSE ARE ADMITTED.
FROM THE BILL. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. OKAY. WHILE FOLKS WHO WANT
TO VOICE OPPOSITION LINE UP AT
THE MIC, I WANT TO JUST GET SOME
CLARITY FROM THE AUTHOR BECAUSE
I'M HEARING MIXED THINGS. ARE
YOU ON THE ON THE CEQA
EXEMPTION? I UNDERSTAND YOU CAME
IN AND SAY YOU'RE NOT ACCEPTING
THE AMENDMENTS. WHAT ABOUT THE
IT INCLUDES THE CEQA BECAUSE I'M
HEARING FROM A MEMBER THAT YOU
AGREED TO DROP, REMOVE THE SEQUA
PROVISION. LET ME SHARE WITH YOU
THAT, YOU KNOW, WE HAVE ALWAYS
SAID THAT THE PORTION OF THE
BILL THAT IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT
AND IT SHOULD BE RECOGNIZED IS
THAT THE 18 PARTY SETTLEMENT
AGREEMENT. AND ALTHOUGH, YOU
KNOW, WE CAN SAY IT'S NOT AN
AGREEMENT YET, IT'S STILL GOING
THROUGH THE PROCESS. BUT THERE
WAS A LOT OF WORK THAT WENT INTO
THAT BY A DIVERSE GROUP OF FOLKS
WHO SELDOMLY, WILL BE ON THE
SAME PAGE, WE HAVE SAID THAT
TIME AND TIME AGAIN, AND I THINK
THE OPPOSITION HAS ALSO SAID
THAT THEY WERE GOOD. IF THE BILL
FOCUSED SPECIFICALLY ON THAT, WE
ARE THERE. WE GET TO THIS
COMMITTEE AND SOME OF THE
PROPOSED AMENDMENTS THAT COME
FORWARD KIND OF REGRESS US FROM
SOME OF THE PROGRESS THAT WE'VE
MADE, NOT ONLY IN THE FIVE
STAKEHOLDER CONVERSATIONS THAT
WE'VE HAD, BUT THE FIVE
COMMITTEES THAT WE'VE HAD
LEADING UP TO HERE. AND SO IT
ALMOST SEEMS LIKE IT KIND OF
TOOK US IN A DIFFERENT
DIRECTION. SO IF WE CAN REFOCUS
AND GET THE SETTLEMENT AGREEMENT
CONVERSATION RECENTERED. I'M ALL
IN ON THAT. AND I THINK THAT OUR
SPONSORS AND THOSE SUPPORTERS OF
THE BILL ARE GOOD WITH THAT. IF
IT'S GOING TO REQUIRE FOR US TO
COMPROMISE AND SAY WE'RE GOING
TO GET THE CEQA PORTION OUT OF
THIS BILL, OUT TO MOVE THIS BILL
AND FOCUS JUST ON THE AGREEMENT,
I'M GOING TO BE GOOD WITH THAT.
BUT BUT I ALSO JUST WANT TO
STATE FOR THE RECORD THAT I
THINK WE'RE MISSING A UNIQUE
OPPORTUNITY BECAUSE IT REQUIRES
US TO ROLL UP OUR SLEEVES. IT
REQUIRES US TO MOVE AWAY FROM
OUR IDEOLOGICAL PERSPECTIVES ON
THAT. CEQA CANNOT BE REFORMED,
THAT WE CANNOT DO IT THIS WAY OR
THAT WAY, BECAUSE THAT'S NOT
WHAT WE'VE DONE BEFORE AND NOT
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THE TARGETS
THAT WE'VE SET FORWARD, THAT THE
ANTIQUATED RULES THAT ARE IN
PLACE, THAT GO BACK TO 1995. ON
HOW THE CPUC IS REVIEWING AND
APPROVING TRANSMISSION PROJECTS.
KAGISO IS DOING, YOU KNOW,
THINGS IN A DIFFERENT WAY THAT
IT JUST DOESN'T ALIGN WITH THE
ACCELERATED TARGETS THAT WE HAVE
FOR RENEWABLE ENERGY PROCUREMENT
AND SO IT WOULD BE, I THINK,
JUST SHOOTING OURSELVES IN THE
FOOT, NOT WANTING TO GIVE
OURSELVES AN OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE
THAT CONVERSATION. YOU KNOW, WE
HAD A MEETING ON MONDAY WHERE WE
SPENT SOME TIME TALKING ABOUT
THE CEQA COMPONENT. AND AS I
MENTIONED, AND I WANT TO STATE
THIS AGAIN, THAT IF REMOVING THE
CEQA COMPONENT ALLOWS US TO
FOCUS ON THE SETTLEMENT
AGREEMENT MOVING FORWARD, WE ARE
IN A POSITION TO DO THAT. BUT WE
HAD A CONVERSATION ON MONDAY
WITH OPPOSITION YOURSELF AND
YOUR COMMITTEE CONSULTANTS WHERE
WE PUT OUT CONCEPTS ON HOW TO
NARROW THE CEQA PIECE EVEN
FURTHER TO PROTECT OUR STATE
PARKS, TO PROTECT OTHER LANDS
WHERE ALREADY THE LAND HAS BEEN
DISTURBED, WHERE ALREADY THERE
ARE LINES RUNNING THROUGH THERE,
AND WE CAME UP WITH SOME
CONCEPTS. AND THE MINUTE THAT IT
SEEMED LIKE WE COULD GET SOME
TRACTION, ALL OF A SUDDEN IT
WASN'T A GOOD IDEA ANYMORE. AND
IT'S THOSE TYPES OF
CIRCUMSTANCES THAT I FEEL LIKE
GET IN OUR WAY OF ACTUALLY
SEEING PROGRESS FROM BUILDING
OUT THIS INFRASTRUCTURE THAT WE
NEED FOR THE PROCUREMENT OF THIS
CLEAN ENERGY THAT WE'RE NOT
GOING TO BE ABLE TO ACHIEVE ON
THE SCHEDULE THAT WE'RE ON. AND
IF WE'RE OKAY WITH THAT, THEN I
WILL BE OKAY WITH EXCLUDING THE
CEQA PIECE TO THIS BILL, AND
I'LL, YOU KNOW, SUPPORT, YOU
KNOW, THAT PIECE OF THE
CONVERSATION IN AN AMENDMENT
THAT ALLOWS US TO FOCUS ON THE
SETTLEMENT AGREEMENT? OKAY A LOT
THERE. I MEAN, I MEAN, WE DID
OFFER TO, YOU KNOW, NARROW THE
REBUTTABLE PRESUMPTION TO WHAT'S
IN THE SETTLEMENT AGREEMENT. I
KNOW THAT THAT'S WHERE A LOT OF
THE POINT OF CONTENTION IS NOW,
YOU KNOW, OBVIOUSLY WE HAVEN'T
BEEN ABLE TO LAND LANGUAGE, AND
WE WANT, WE WANT, WE WANT TO
TAKE THE REBUTTABLE PRESUMPTION
OUT UNTIL WE GET IT HAMMERED
OUT. THAT'S I THINK THAT SEEMS
TO BE THE CRUX OF THE ISSUE,
THOUGH. YOU SAID A LOT OF
DIFFERENT THINGS JUST NOW. I
WANT TO GET TO THE DETAILS AS WE
GET INTO DISCUSSION. BUT LET'S
HEAR FROM FOLKS WHO WANT TO
WEIGH IN, IN OPPOSITION, IN
OPPOSITION. GOOD AFTERNOON. BREE
FORDHAM FROM ANZA-BORREGO
FOUNDATION, PARTNER WITH
ANZA-BORREGO DESERT STATE PARK,
OPPOSED UNLESS AMENDED. DARRYL
LITTLE WITH NRDC IN RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. JACOB
EVANS WITH SIERRA CLUB
CALIFORNIA IN OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU. ALEX LIMMER, ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA COASTAL
PROTECTION NETWORK AND THE
CENTER FOR BIOLOGICAL DIVERSITY
IN OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON. CAITLIN REDNER SUTTER
WITH ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE FUND.
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED. WE ARE
PARTIES TO THAT SETTLEMENT
AGREEMENT AND WOULD VERY MUCH
LIKE TO SEE THIS BILL NARROWED
TO JUST THE TERMS OF THAT
AGREEMENT, MAYBE SOMEONE ABOVE
AGREES WITH ME, SO I THINK WHAT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GARCIA WAS JUST
OFFERING IS, IS TO CONSIDER
THAT. SO THAT'S THAT'S WHERE WE
ARE TOO. BUT, YOU KNOW, DEVIL'S
CLEARLY IN THE DETAILS ON THIS.
YES NATALIE BROWN WITH THE
PLANNING AND CONSERVATION LEAGUE
AND ENDANGERED HABITATS LEAGUE
AND RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU. OKAY THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT.
SORRY OH WE. YEAH YEAH. LÀ.
YEAH. LONG AGO. LONG AGO. WE
STARTED 9 A.M. THIS MORNING. ALL
RIGHT, LOOK, LET ME LET ME JUST
BEFORE WE OPEN UP TO EVERYONE,
AND I THINK THIS IS GOING TO GO
ON FOR SOME TIME BECAUSE THERE'S
A LOT OF DETAIL TO WORK OUT
HERE, AND I DON'T WANT TO LEAVE
THIS HEARING WITHOUT A GREAT
DEAL MORE CLARITY, ESPECIALLY
GIVEN ALL THE MANY, MANY THINGS
THAT HAVE BEEN SAID BY THE
AUTHOR, LET ME START BY SAYING
THAT, YOU KNOW, THERE'S NO DOUBT
IN MY MIND THAT WE I AGREE WITH
THE CORE PREMISE OF THAT. YOU'VE
STATED IN MANY WAYS, ASSEMBLY
MEMBER, THAT WE NEED TO
ACCELERATE OUR TRANSMISSION
INFRASTRUCTURE DEPLOYMENT IN
ORDER TO MEET THE VERY DIRE
ENERGY NEEDS FACING THE STATE.
YOU KNOW, I THINK THE BILL TAKES
SEVERAL IMPORTANT STEPS TO
STREAMLINE THE CEQA AND
ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW PROCESSES
IN THOSE TARGETED PLACES, IN
THE, YOU KNOW, IN THE PROCESS
WHERE THAT MAKES SENSE. NOW IT'S
MY STRONG FEELING THAT AS
WRITTEN ON THE BILL IN FRONT OF
US TODAY GOES TOO FAR TO
RESTRICT AND CUT OUT IMPORTANT
ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW AND
PROTECTIONS. NOW, WE'VE HAD MANY
CONVERSATIONS TRYING TO LAND A
DEAL, IT SEEMS TO ME THERE ARE
TWO OUTSTANDING ISSUES IN THE
BILL THAT THAT NEED TO BE
RESOLVED IN ORDER TO WIN MY
SUPPORT. FIRST OF ALL, AS
WRITTEN THIS, THE BILL CREATES A
SEQUA EXEMPTION FOR UTILITY
RIGHTS OF WAY, THIS APPLIES TO
ANYWHERE IN THE STATE, INCLUDING
STATE PARKS, COASTAL ZONES,
WETLANDS, OTHER SENSITIVE
HABITATS, YOU KNOW, I MEAN,
WE'VE HEARD FROM FOLKS FROM
ANZA-BORREGO THAT'S A SPECIAL
PLACE, I'VE SPENT A LOT OF TIME
THERE AS A AS A KID, AND I JUST,
YOU KNOW, I'M PERSONALLY NOT
GOING TO PUT MY, MY STAMP ON
ANYTHING THAT'S GOING TO MAKE IT
EASIER FOR, FOR FOLKS TO RUN BIG
TRANSMISSION LINES IN THE MIDDLE
OF THE STATE PARK, AS WRITTEN,
THE BILL, YOU KNOW, YOU KNOW,
MAKES IT EASIER FOR, FOR JUST
THAT, TO HAPPEN. AND I JUST I'M
NOT I'M NOT GOING TO SUPPORT
THAT, I, YOU KNOW, I BELIEVE
IT'S CRITICAL TO PROTECT SOME OF
THESE VERY SPECIAL PLACES. AND
BY THE WAY, WE'RE JUST BEING
CONSISTENT IN OUR POSITION IN
THE BECKER BILL FROM LAST, FROM
LAST YEAR WITH REGARDS TO THAT,
SO THE OTHER NOW, THAT BEING
SAID, YOU'VE EXPRESSED SOME
FLEXIBILITY ON SEEK EXEMPTION
AND YOU MADE SOME COMMITMENTS TO
MENGIBAR. YOU KNOW, I UNDERSTAND
THAT THEY'RE PENDING THE BROADER
DISCUSSION, THE BROADER
NEGOTIATION, AT LEAST THAT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING FROM YOUR YOUR
ANSWER EARLIER, NOW, THE OTHER
BIG ISSUE I THINK IT SEEMS TO ME
THE BIGGEST STICKING POINT SEEMS
TO BE ON THIS REBUTTABLE
PRESUMPTION QUESTION, AND THIS
IS A THIS IS THE IDEA THAT, YOU
KNOW, THE BENEFITS OF ANY
TRANSMISSION PROJECT THAT HAS
CAL ISOS APPROVAL, SHOULD
OUTWEIGH ANY ENVIRONMENTAL COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH THE PROJECT. AND
I THINK THAT'S, THAT'S THE
CHALLENGE HERE, THE AUTHOR'S
OFFICE ARGUES THAT THIS IS
CODIFYING THE EXISTING
SETTLEMENT AGREEMENT PROPOSAL TO
THE PUC. AND, YOU KNOW, OF
COURSE, IT'S NOT SETTLED, RIGHT?
I MEAN, I KNOW THAT'S THE THAT'S
THE TERM OF ART, AND IT'S IT IS
THE CORRECT TERM OF ART. BUT BUT
NOBODY IN THE ROOM SHOULD TAKE
FROM THE WORD SETTLEMENT THAT
HAS BEEN SETTLED, IT'S UNDER
REVIEW BY THE PUC AND BY THE
WAY, THE PUC HAS ITS OWN SET OF
CONCERNS WITH WHAT'S HAPPENING
HERE, THE CONCERN I THINK YOU'RE
HEARING FROM THE COMMITTEE IS
THAT THE REBUTTABLE PRESUMPTION
AS WRITTEN IN THE BILL, YOU
KNOW, GOES BEYOND WHAT'S
ACTUALLY IN THE SETTLEMENT
AGREEMENT, YOU KNOW, THE PIECE
OF THE BILL IN PRINT. YOU KNOW,
I THINK THE CONCERN IS THAT THE
PIECE IN THE BILL IN PRINT COULD
UNDERMINE SEQUA BY TURNING THE
STATEMENT OF OVERRIDING
CONSIDERATION ON ITS HEAD. I
UNDERSTAND THERE'S A THERE'S A
DISAGREEMENT OVER THAT ISSUE.
AND, YOU KNOW, PART OF WHAT I'VE
OFFERED TO YOU, ASSEMBLY MEMBER
AND TO YOUR SPONSOR, SDG AND I
WAS IN TOUCH WITH KENT EARLIER,
WAS A, YOU KNOW, DEEP DIVE WITH
HIM. EVERY MEMBER OF THE
COMMITTEE WOULD BE WELCOME TO
JOIN ON A ZOOM NEXT WEEK. WE
COULD GO, YOU KNOW, SPEND AN
HOUR OR TWO ON THIS AND REALLY
TRY TO GET ENGAGED IN TRYING TO,
REALLY GRAPPLE WITH, THE WITH
THIS ISSUE. BUT CLEARLY THERE'S
SOME SERIOUS DISAGREEMENTS AND I
THINK THEY'RE REFLECTED IN YOUR
CRITICISM OF THE ANALYSIS, YOU
KNOW, AS YOU KNOW. RIGHT, THE
STATEMENT OF OVERRIDING
CONSIDERATION IS THE BACKSTOP TO
CEQA. PROJECTS CAN ALWAYS MOVE
FORWARD WITH SIGNIFICANT
UNMITIGATED IMPACTS, BUT THEY
HAVE TO PROVIDE JUSTIFICATION IN
THE STATEMENT OF OVERRIDING
CONSIDERATION THAT THOSE
PROJECTS ARE WORTH THE IMPACTS
TO THE ENVIRONMENT. AND, OF
COURSE, CREATING A REBUTTABLE
PRESUMPTION WOULD REPLACE THE
NEED TO PROVIDE, JUSTIFICATION
AND EVIDENCE THAT THE PROJECT IS
TRULY WORTH IT. SO THAT'S THE I
THINK THAT'S THE THAT'S THE
CONCERN HERE. NOW, I YOU KNOW, I
KNOW THAT, YOU KNOW, THAT THAT,
THAT SO, SO, SO THERE'S A
CONCERN THAT THAT AS, AS WRITTEN,
WE COULD BE TURNING SEQUA INTO
JUST A RUBBER STAMP PROCESS, YOU
KNOW, TO PROCEED WITH PROJECTS
THAT, YOU KNOW, HAVE SIGNIFICANT
IMPACTS ON THE ENVIRONMENT, I
KNOW THAT'S NOT THE AUTHOR
STATED INTENT HERE, THAT'S WHY,
YOU KNOW, WE'VE OFFERED TO WORK
WITH AUTHOR'S OFFICE ON THIS,
YOU KNOW WHAT? WE'VE WHAT WE'VE
SAID KIND OF SEVERAL TIMES IS
THAT WE, WE WANT TO, YOU KNOW,
WORK ON IT TOGETHER BECAUSE WE
CLEARLY HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE TO
LAND THIS YET, YOU KNOW, WE
OFFERED SITE EXCLUSIONS. I KNOW
YOU'VE OFFERED A BROADER
EXCLUSION EXEMPTION. EXEMPTION,
YOU KNOW, CERTAINLY, IF YOU WANT
TO NARROW THE SECRET EXEMPTION
MORE, THAT'S GREAT. YOU KNOW,
WE'RE OKAY WITH NARROWING THE
REBUTTABLE PRESUMPTION TO WHAT'S
ACTUALLY IN THE SETTLEMENT
AGREEMENT. I MEAN, SO THE
FRUSTRATION HERE IS I THINK
WE'RE ACTUALLY. WELL, THE
FRUSTRATION AND THE AND THE
LIGHT AT THE END OF THE TUNNEL
HERE IS THAT WE'RE ALL SAYING
THE SAME THING, WHICH IS THAT
WE'RE OKAY WITH NARROWING THE
REBUTTABLE PRESUMPTION TO WHAT'S
ACTUALLY IN THE SETTLEMENT
AGREEMENT, BUT OF COURSE, WE
HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE TO LAND ON
WHAT THAT LOOKS LIKE. EXACTLY.
SO YOU KNOW, IT'S MY HOPE THAT,
IT WAS MY HOPE. AND I'VE
EXPRESSED THIS TO YOU,
ASSEMBLYMEMBER, THAT YOU WOULD
ACCEPT THE AMENDMENTS WITH THE
COMMITMENT FROM US, THAT WE
WOULD WORK HARD WITH YOU TO KIND
OF GET THIS REBUTTABLE
PRESUMPTION ISSUE. TRULY
ADHERING TO THE SETTLEMENT
AGREEMENT FRAMEWORK, AND THEY'RE
JUST GOING TO TAKE SOME TIME,
RIGHT? I MEAN, BOTH OF US HAVE
BEEN REALLY INVOLVED IN OTHER
THINGS. I MEAN, WE'RE BOTH YOU
KNOW, IN ENGAGED IN TRYING TO
GET THE BOND PASSED TODAY, AND
AMONG AMONG 20 OTHER ISSUES,
THAT WE'RE PARTNERING ON. BUT
CLEARLY, WE WEREN'T ABLE TO LAND
THIS LANGUAGE ON THE REBUTTABLE
PRESUMPTION IN TIME FOR TODAY.
AND, YOU KNOW, IT JUST IT IS
IMPORTANT TO US THAT WE THAT WE
DO THAT. AND AGAIN, I REITERATE
OUR COMMITMENT TO YOU, TO REALLY
WORK IN GOOD FAITH. TO, TO DO
JUST THAT. SO THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
OFFERING TO YOU. I'D HOPE THAT
WOULD BE ENOUGH, GIVEN THE YOU
KNOW, TIME FRAME, BUT I'M, I'M
SENSING THAT YOU'RE STILL TRYING
TO FIGURE OUT, GIVEN ALL THESE
MOVING PARTS WHERE YOUR POSITION
IS ON, ON THE NEGOTIATIONS,
THERE ISN'T A LOT TO FIGURE OUT.
WE, ARE GOOD WITH FOCUSING ON
THE SETTLEMENT AGREEMENT.
LANGUAGE AND WE WOULD HOPE THAT
YOU WOULD NOT TIE OUR HANDS DOWN
TO A SPECIFIC, APPROACH OR AN
AMENDMENT. YOU KNOW, I'VE BEEN
CHAIRING COMMITTEES THE ENTIRE
TIME THAT I'VE BEEN HERE, AND I
KNOW THAT THERE ARE WAYS OF
GOING ABOUT, YOU KNOW, WORKING
COLLABORATIVELY AND COLLEGIATELY
WITH OUR COLLEAGUES HERE WHERE
WHEN THE SPIRIT OF WANTING TO
GET TO AN END GOAL WHERE THERE
IS FAR MORE IN COMMON THAN NOT,
WE ALLOW FOLKS TO CONTINUE TO
WORK IN THAT SPIRIT. THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE OFFERING AND WE'RE NOT.
BUT WE'RE NOT TYING PEOPLE DOWN
TO A SPECIFIC SET OF AMENDMENTS
AND THEN WORKING THE OTHER WAY
BACK, BY LAYING A MARKER THAT
MAY OR MAY NOT BE IN LINE WITH
THE END GOAL, THAT IS KIND OF
TILTING THIS THIS IS LITERALLY
JUST AN ISSUE OF LEVERAGE IS
THAT I KNOW IT'S AN ISSUE OF, OF
KIND OF GOOD FAITH EFFORT.
RIGHT. CONVERSATIONS REMAINING
OPEN AND TRANSPARENT TO BE ABLE
TO LAND AT A PLACE WHERE THE
SETTLEMENT AGREEMENT IS
REFLECTIVE OF WHAT ALL THESE
PARTIES CAME TO. I'VE PUT ON THE
TABLE THE STRIKING OF THE CEQA
EXEMPTION, AND I JUST KIND OF
EDITORIALIZED IT SAID, I THINK
WE'RE MISSING AN OPPORTUNITY BY
NOT WANTING TO ROLL UP OUR
SLEEVES AND PUT A LITTLE MORE
WORK INTO IT AND NARROWING IT
DOWN IN A WAY WHERE WE CAN AT
LEAST FIND A WAY TO THREAD THE
NEEDLE. BUT THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
OFFERING. THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT
WE'RE OFFERING. BUT, BUT, BUT IT
SEEMS TO ME THAT, YOU KNOW, AND
WE'RE GOING TO BE OKAY IF WE
EXCLUDE THE SEQUEL PIECE. I WANT
TO BE VERY CLEAR WITH THAT, I'M
JUST GIVING MY COMMENTARY ON
THAT. WHAT WHAT I WANT TO FOCUS
ON IS THE SETTLEMENT AGREEMENT
AND GETTING THAT LANGUAGE RIGHT.
YEAH, BUT NOT TYING OUR HANDS
DOWN TO AMENDMENTS THAT WE FIND
DIFFICULT TO KIND OF WORK BACK
INTO. AND I'M GOING TO DEFER TO,
OUR KEY WITNESS HERE WHO MAY BE
ABLE TO KIND OF ARTICULATE
THINGS BETTER IN TERMS OF WHAT
ARE SOME OF THE CHALLENGES IN
THAT PARTICULAR AREA WITH
SETTLEMENT AGREEMENT AMENDMENTS
THAT YOU'RE PUTTING FORWARD? BUT
OUR HOPE IS THAT WE COULD MOVE
THE BILL FORWARD, NARROW IT DOWN
TO THE SETTLEMENT AGREEMENT, AND
TAKE YOUR OFFER OF CONTINUING TO
WORK ON THIS MATTER AND BE VERY
CLEAR THAT WE HAVE ELIMINATED
THE CEQA PORTION, THAT IF THAT
MAKES EVERYONE FEEL MORE
COMFORTABLE, THEN WE HAVE A BILL
THAT NOW IS MUCH NARROWER AND
FOCUSES ON WHAT MANY PEOPLE HAVE
ALREADY AGREED TO CONTINUE TO
WORK ON. OKAY. ALL RIGHT. I WANT
TO GIVE THE MEMBERS AN
OPPORTUNITY. AND THEN I THINK
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO ENGAGE
ALL FOUR OF YOU IN ASPECTS OF
THIS DISCUSSION, I SEE SENATOR
MENGIBAR VICE CHAIR. WELL, I GOT
YOUR VICE CHAIR. UNFORTUNATELY
YOU LOVE THE VICE CHAIRMAN.
WELL, I DON'T EVEN KNOW WHERE TO
START. I THIS IS YOU ALL BEEN IN
NEGOTIATIONS. I'M ON THE OUTSIDE
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WHAT THE
HELL IS GOING ON, AND IT PISSES
ME OFF. I WANT TO DO THE RIGHT
THING FOR THE ENVIRONMENT. I
WANT TO DO THE RIGHT THING TO
MEET THE GOALS. AND I HAVE A LOT
OF FRUSTRATIONS ON A LOT OF
BILLS THAT, I MEAN, I COULD GO
OFF ON WIND AND WE'RE JUST GOING
TO THE OCEAN AND WE'RE GOING TO
DO I MEAN, I COULD SAY HOW
FRUSTRATED I AM ABOUT THAT
PROCESS, HOW FRUSTRATED I AM
WITH THE PROCESS. ALLOW THE CEC
TO GO SITE NGUYEN PROJECTS IN MY
DISTRICT WITHOUT THE LOCALS
CONTROL. AND HERE WE ARE TODAY
WORKING ON A BILL THAT I HAVE NO
IDEA. IS IT THE SAME AS WHAT I
VOTED ON WHEN I WAS IN IN ENERGY
OR IS IT NOT? AND SO YOU ALL
HAVE YOUR PARTY AND YOU DO ALL
YOUR THINGS IN YOUR PARTY. AND
THOSE OF US WHO ARE ON THE
OUTSIDE WHO ARE TRYING TO DO THE
RIGHT THING, HAVE NO OPPORTUNITY
TO WEIGH IN. I HAVE NOT BEEN
PART OF ANY OF THESE
CONVERSATIONS, AND YOU'RE DOING
A DEAL RIGHT HERE IN FRONT OF
ME, AND I DON'T HAVE NO IDEA
WHAT I'M VOTING ON OR NOT VOTING
ON. SO WHERE ARE WE AT? THAT'S
WHAT I WANT TO KNOW. AND WE'RE
WE'RE FLUSHING THAT OUT RIGHT
HERE. AND WHAT ABOUT THE PUBLIC?
THAT'S NOT HERE, THAT DOESN'T
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO KNOW
WHAT AMENDMENT THAT WE'RE EVEN
VOTING ON. SO YEAH, I'M VERY
FRUSTRATED. WELL, CLEARLY,
CLEARLY, UNLIKE EVERY OTHER BILL
THAT WE'VE HEARD TODAY. A DEAL
HAS NOT BEEN FINALIZED. THAT'S
WHAT HAPPENED. SO THIS IS AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR YOU TO WEIGH IN.
YOU WEIGH IN ON NEARLY EVERY
BILL, AND I ALWAYS APPRECIATE
YOUR FEEDBACK AND ENGAGEMENT,
AND IT'S WELCOME HERE TODAY.
CLEARLY, A DEAL HAS NOT BEEN
FINALIZED. I WILL SAY THAT, YOU
KNOW, FOR YOU TO KNOW, AND YOU
HAVE THE ANALYSIS, YOU'VE HAD
ACCESS TO IT FOR SOME TIME, YOU
KNOW, FOR A COUPLE FEW DAYS.
THE, THE CORE STICKING POINT,
SEEMS TO BE COMING DOWN TO,
SEEMS TO BE COMING DOWN TO THE
AMENDMENT SUGGESTS THE AMENDMENT
ON PAGE 11 OF THE ANALYSIS
RELATING TO REBUTTABLE
PRESUMPTION THAT THAT THAT IS
THE IF I, IF I, IF I COULD
DIRECT ANYONE TO, THE MOST
IMPORTANT SECTION OF THE
ANALYSIS TO READ FOR THE
PURPOSES OF WHERE WE HAVE A
STICKING POINT AND IT SOUNDS
LIKE YOU KNOW, BOTH OF US ARE
EXPRESSING THE SAME PRINCIPLE,
WHICH IS THAT WE REALLY, YOU
KNOW, THAT WE'RE OKAY WITH,
WITH, WITH REALLY AND I AND I BY
THE WAY, I CAN'T SPEAK FOR THE
OPPOSITION ON THIS. I THINK THEY
MAY HAVE A MORE STRICT POSITION,
BUT AT LEAST FROM THE FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE, YOU KNOW, MAKING
SURE THAT THERE'S COHERENCE
BETWEEN THE SETTLEMENT AGREEMENT
AND THE REBUTTAL, YOU KNOW,
PRESUMPTION SO THAT WE DON'T
THAT AND OUR CONCERN IS THAT, AS
WRITTEN, THE REBUTTABLE
PRESUMPTION COULD GO MUCH
FURTHER THAN THE SCOPE OF THE
SETTLEMENT AGREEMENT. AND THEY
DON'T AGREE THAT THAT I MEAN, IF
I, IF I COULD CRYSTALLIZE THE
DISAGREEMENT, I THINK THAT'S THE
BEST I COULD SAY. YES, MAYBE
HEARING FROM KEY WITNESS,
HEARING FROM THE OPPOSITION ON
THOSE PERSPECTIVES COULD SHED
LIGHT TO THE MEMBERS. AND JUST
THROUGH THROUGH YOU. MR. CHAIR,
TO THE QUESTIONS BY THE VICE
CHAIR, THE BILL THAT'S BEFORE
YOU IS WHAT CAME OUT OF THE LAST
COMMITTEE THAT YOU VOTED ON. SO
THERE SHOULD BE NO CONFUSION ON
THAT. THE CONFUSION THAT MAY BE,
COMES ABOUT IS US SAYING, LOOK,
WE DON'T AGREE WITH THE ANALYSIS
AND WE DON'T AGREE WITH THE
AMENDMENTS THAT ARE REFLECTIVE
OF THIS ANALYSIS THAT WE THINK
IS A BIT INCONSISTENT WITH THE
PROCESS THAT'S TAKEN PLACE. AND
IN PARTICULAR, IT'S THAT ONE
AMENDMENT RIGHT THAT THAT'S
THAT'S JUST OUR PERSPECTIVE THAT
WE'RE SHARING. RIGHT. AND WE IN
ADVANCE PROVIDED THAT FEEDBACK
TO THE CHAIR AND TO THE
COMMITTEE. RIGHT AND THAT'S
MAYBE WHAT'S CAUSING THE
CONFUSION. BUT WHAT WE'RE SAYING
IS WE WOULD LIKE TO CONTINUE TO
WORK ON THE BILL WITHOUT BEING
STRAPPED DOWN WITH SOME
AMENDMENTS THAT MAY PUT US IN A
DIFFERENT PLACE TO GET TO A
SETTLEMENT AGREEMENT PIECE OF
THE BILL THAT IS REFLECTIVE,
ULTIMATELY, OF THE CONVERSATIONS
THAT HAVE BROUGHT THESE PARTIES
TOGETHER. THAT COULD STILL BE A
GOOD OUTCOME FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. AND FOR THE
ACCELERATION OF TRANSMISSION
DEVELOPMENT, AND TO HELP US MEET
OUR GOALS. YES. YOU KNOW, ME
BEING, YOU KNOW, AMBITIOUS, ME
BEING PRAGMATIC IN NATURE AND MY
APPROACH TO DEALING WITH
ENVIRONMENTAL AND ECONOMIC,
ISSUES, SENSITIVE TO THE
ENVIRONMENT, I'M NOT WANTING TO
TEAR DOWN AND TEAR THROUGH, YOU
KNOW, OUR STATE PARKS AND BUILD
MAJOR TRANSMISSION LINES THROUGH
MY DISTRICT. BORREGO NATIONAL,
YOU KNOW, STATE PARK. YOU KNOW
THAT THAT'S NOT THE INTENTION.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT EXISTING
RIGHT OF WAYS WHERE THERE'S
ALREADY LINES GOING THROUGH
THERE. AND I'M SAYING, COULD WE
UTILIZE THOSE RIGHT OF WAYS? AND
IF THERE'S SEQUA THAT, YOU KNOW,
WASN'T DONE, AN EXAMPLE WAS
GIVEN BECAUSE IT WAS PRESKA WHEN
THOSE TRANSMISSION LINES WERE
BUILT. WELL MAYBE WE NEED TO NOT
GIVE THIS TYPE OF, RIGHT OF WAY
AND GO THROUGH SOME KIND OF
CEQA. RIGHT. BUT THAT'S NOT GOOD
ENOUGH BECAUSE THAT'S JUST
PHILOSOPHICALLY NOT IN LINE
WITH, YOU KNOW, THE SEQUEL
POLICIES AND WHAT WE'VE, YOU
KNOW, SIGNED ON TO FOR YOU KNOW,
FOREVER THAT WE WOULD NEVER
VIOLATE THE SEQUA, YOU KNOW,
BIBLE BOOK. I DON'T LOOK TO ME,
WHAT'S IMPORTANT HERE IS THAT WE
TRY TO BE AS PRAGMATIC AS WE CAN
TO TRY TO ACHIEVE THESE
OBJECTIVES, BUT ALSO MAKE SURE
THAT PEOPLE ARE PART OF THE
FOCAL POINT. YOU KNOW, I
REPRESENT AN AREA THAT I JUST
PRESENTED A BILL IN ANOTHER
COMMITTEE WHERE WE DON'T HAVE
POWER IN AN AREA THAT GETS UP TO
120 DEGREES, AND THEN I'M IN
THIS COMMITTEE TALKING ABOUT HOW
WE MIGHT BE ABLE TO BUILD
TRANSMISSION, TO MOVE POWER IN
THE MOST PRAGMATIC WAY POSSIBLE.
AND WE'RE RUNNING INTO A WALL
BECAUSE, YOU KNOW, WE'RE JUST
NOT THERE. SO THERE SHOULD BE NO
CONFUSION. AND I APOLOGIZE IF MY
PRESENTATION OF NOT ACCEPTING
THE AMENDMENTS, BECAUSE I HAVE
CONCERNS ABOUT THE ANALYSIS
CREATES THAT CONFUSION. I'M JUST
TRYING TO GET TO A PLACE WHERE
AND I THINK IT'S VERY CLEAR NOW
FOCUS ON THE SETTLEMENT
AGREEMENT. WE'RE NOT PUSHING THE
ENVELOPE HERE ON THE CEQA THING,
BECAUSE IT'S VERY CLEAR THAT
THERE ISN'T AN APPETITE TO MOVE
THERE. AND I WISH THIS
LEGISLATURE LUCK AFTER, YOU
KNOW, MY TENURE HERE IS DONE,
TO, CONTINUE TO AMBITIOUSLY AND
AGGRESSIVELY TRY TO MEET ITS
GOALS AND OBJECTIVES IN THE BEST
POSSIBLE WAY, BUT I THINK IT'S
VERY CLEAR THAT WE'RE NOT GOING
TO DO THAT. AND WE SHOULD JUST
BE HONEST WITH, YOU KNOW,
CALIFORNIA AND THE REST OF THE
WORLD WHEN WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
HOW WONDERFUL THESE POLICIES AND
THESE GOALS ARE. WELL, I JUST
LIKE TO THANK YOU, FIRST OF ALL,
AND I HOPE THAT'S CLEAR. WHAT'S
THAT? I HOPE THERE'S NO
CONFUSION ANYMORE. OKAY. WELL I
MEAN, IT'S JUST SIMPLE. YEAH. I
JUST WANT TO SAY THAT, YOU KNOW,
AS SOMEBODY WHO'S AN ADVOCATE
FOR, YOU KNOW, DON'T LET THE
PERFECT GET IN THE WAY OF THE
GOOD. AND I THINK THAT THAT I
THINK THAT I SPEND MY NEW TERM
BECAUSE WE ALWAYS HAVE TO HAVE
THE PERFECT. AND THERE'S A LOT
OF GOOD, AND WE HAVE TO HAVE
COMPROMISE. AT THE END OF THE
DAY, IF WE'RE GOING TO IF WE ARE
GOING TO, IF WE ARE GOING TO
LEAD THE WORLD AND THEY'RE
WATCHING US AND THEY ARE AND WE
I MEAN, A LOT OF PEOPLE TOUT HOW
GREAT WE ARE, BUT AT THE END OF
THE DAY, THERE'S CONFLICTS.
THERE'S THINGS THAT NEED TO BE
WORKED OUT. AND AS SOMEBODY THAT
IS PASSIONATE ABOUT THESE
ISSUES, IT'S HARD. IT'S HARD TO
BE WHERE WE'RE AT ON OUR SIDE OF
THE AISLE TO FIGURE OUT WHAT THE
HECK'S GOING ON. THAT'S THAT WAS
MY ORIGINAL STATEMENT. AND I'LL
JUST WAIT TO SEE WHAT YOU GUYS
SETTLE ON. AND THEN I GUESS I'LL
VOTE APPROPRIATELY. GREAT, WHY
DON'T WE GIVE I MEAN, I THINK
YOUR SUGGESTION OF HAVING, YOU
KNOW, WITNESSES, MAYBE. MISS
DELFINA, YOU'D LIKE TO WEIGH IN
ON. SURE. I'M GOING TO JUST GO
TO THE REBUTTABLE PRESUMPTION
ISSUE, BECAUSE I FEEL LIKE
THERE'S BEEN NO ARGUMENT THAT
THE RIGHT OF WAY EXEMPTION IS
NOT PART OF THE SETTLEMENT
AGREEMENT. IT NEVER WAS PART OF
IT. IT ISN'T PART OF IT. AND IT
SOUNDS LIKE THE AUTHOR IS
WILLING TO TAKE THAT PART OUT,
SO ON THE REBUTTAL PRESUMPTION,
WHAT THE SETTLEMENT AGREEMENT
DOES SAY, IF YOU TURN TO PAGE 97
OF THE AGREEMENT, WHICH I READ
LAST NIGHT, THAT THE PUC CAN
INCLUDE PROJECT PURPOSE AND
BENEFITS THAT ARE FOUND IN THE
RELEVANT CASE. SO TRANSMISSION
PORTFOLIO PLAN FOR A PROJECT IN
THE STATEMENT OF OVERRIDE. I
DON'T HAVE A PROBLEM WITH THAT.
I THINK IT'S FINE TO TAKE AND
THE PUC CAN DO IT NOW TO TAKE
THE BENEFITS ANALYSIS THAT'S IN
THE TPP FOR A PROJECT. AND IF
THEY'RE DOING A STATEMENT OF
OVERRIDE, THEY CAN PUT IT INTO
THE STATEMENT OF OVERRIDE.
THAT'S DIFFERENT THAN SAYING
THAT THAT THEN BECOMES THE ALL
OF THE SUBSTANTIAL EVIDENCE DE
FACTO, WE'RE MANDATING IT IN
LAW, IT MAY BE SUBSTANTIAL
EVIDENCE. IT MAY NOT. YOU MAY
NEED TO ADD ADDITIONAL THE CPUC
OR THE LEAD AGENCY MAY NEED TO
ADD MORE INFORMATION IN THERE IF
THEY'RE GOING TO BE OVERRIDING
SIGNIFICANT EFFECTS ON LOCAL
COMMUNITIES OR ON TEN, YOU KNOW,
50,000 JOSHUA TREES BEING TAKEN
OUT OR WHATEVER THE EFFECT MAY
BE. SO I JUST WANT TO BE CLEAR,
I DID A WORD SEARCH OF THE
AGREEMENT, AND I, FOR BOTH
REBUTTABLE PRESUMPTION AND
OVERRIDE CONSIDERATIONS, MAKING
SURE I WASN'T MAKING A MISTAKE.
THE TWO REBUTTABLE POSITIONS IN
THE SETTLEMENT AGREEMENT PERTAIN
TO PURPOSE AND NEED AND
PREFERRED RESOURCES. THAT'S IT.
THERE IS NO REBUTTABLE
PRESUMPTION IN THE SETTLEMENT
AGREEMENT ABOUT CREATING A
REBUTTABLE PRESUMPTION ON A
STATEMENT OF OVERRIDING
CONSIDERATIONS. AND SO IF THE
AUTHOR IS, YOU KNOW, SAYING THAT
HE WANTS TO CONFINE THE BILL TO
THE SETTLEMENT AGREEMENT, GREAT.
WE WOULD BE HAPPY TO REWRITE
SECTION SUBSECTION C IN THAT
BILL, WHICH IS, I THINK LIKE
2845 14C TO REFLECT THAT YOU CAN
USE THAT PART OF A TPP ANALYSIS
AND PUT IT INTO A STATEMENT OF
OVERRIDE. GREAT. BUT THAT'S NOT
WHAT THE BILL SAYS RIGHT NOW. SO
WHY ISN'T THAT COMMITMENT GOOD
ENOUGH FOR YOU, ASSEMBLYMEMBER?
I MEAN, WE'RE WILLING TO NARROW
THE REBUTTABLE PRESUMPTION TO
WHAT'S ACTUALLY IN THE
SETTLEMENT AGREEMENT. THAT IS
EXACTLY WHAT YOU SAID, THAT YOU
WANT TO ASK OUR OUR SPONSOR OF
THE BILL TO KIND OF SPEAK TO
SOME OF THAT? YEAH, I'D BE HAPPY
TO. I THINK THE AMENDMENT
CURRENTLY IS TO COMPLETELY
REMOVE THE PROVISION. SO THAT IS
WHAT WE'RE, THAT WE WERE I
UNDERSTAND AND WE'VE BEEN, YOU
KNOW, YOU KNOW, WE WE'VE
EXPRESSED OUR WILLINGNESS TO
WORK ON THAT. SO, THE REBUTTABLE
PRESUMPTION IS ENTIRELY
CONSISTENT WITH THE SETTLEMENT
AGREEMENT. I DON'T RESPECTFULLY,
AS THIS BILL HAS GONE THROUGH
THE PROCESS, IF YOU WERE DOING A
WORD SEARCH FOR MANY OF THE
PROVISIONS THAT ARE CURRENTLY IN
THERE, IT WOULDN'T APPEAR
EXACTLY THAT WAY BECAUSE WE HAVE
REVISED IT. IT HAS BEEN BECOME
MORE NARROWLY TAILORED. IT HAS
AS IT HAS GONE THROUGH THESE
OTHER FOUR POLICY COMMITTEES,
THE PURPOSE OF THE REBUTTABLE
PRESUMPTION IS TO APPLY THAT,
THE WEIGHT TO THE NEED OF THE
PROJECT WHEN THE SYSTEM OPERATOR
HAS DETERMINED THAT A PROJECT IS
NECESSARY, IT IS NOT A DE FACTO
APPROVAL. IT IS SOMETHING THAT
MAY BE REBUTTED BY ANY OTHER
PARTY, AS WELL AS THE AGENCY
ITSELF. IT IS SIMPLY THAT WHEN
THE SYSTEM OPERATOR HAS GONE
THROUGH YEARS OF FORECASTING AND
PLANNING AND STUDIED THE ISSUE
AND DETERMINED THAT A
TRANSMISSION SYSTEM PROJECT IS
NECESSARY, THAT THAT BECAUSE IT
ADDRESSES THE GENERAL STATE
TRANSMISSION SYSTEM, COULD
CONSTITUTE SUBSTANTIAL EVIDENCE
THAT OVERRIDES A LOCAL
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT. AND AGAIN,
THIS ONLY OCCURS WHERE THE CPUC
IS UNABLE TO FIND A LOCATION AND
A ROUTE THAT DOES NOT AVOID OR
MITIGATE SUBSTANTIAL IMPACTS.
IT'S NOT IT'S NOT A RUBBER
STAMP. SO WE CERTAINLY
RESPECTFULLY DISAGREE ABOUT THE
INTERPRETATION OF THE SETTLEMENT
AGREEMENT, BUT WE ARE OPEN TO
REMOVING THE WORDS REBUTTABLE
PRESUMPTION, IF THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT CAUSES CONCERN
THAT IT WOULD BE A RUBBER STAMP
AND INSTEAD ESTABLISH THAT THE
SYSTEM TRANSMISSION, I'M SORRY,
THE TRANSMISSION SYSTEM
AUTHORITY'S DETERMINATION SHOULD
CONSTITUTE SUBSTANTIAL EVIDENCE.
AND THAT'S A TERM OF ART IN
SEQUA. IT MEANS THAT IF SUCH
EVIDENCE EXISTS, SOMEONE CAN
MAKE A FAIR ARGUMENT IN SUPPORT
OF THOSE OVERRIDING
CONSIDERATIONS. IT DOES NOT MEAN
THAT ADDITIONAL INFORMATION,
ANALYSIS, AND EVIDENCE COULD BE
ADDED THAT WOULD OVERCOME THAT,
AND IN WHICH CASE NO AGENCY IS
BOUND TO ISSUE A STATEMENT OF
OVERRIDING CONSIDERATIONS THAT
THAT IS NOT WHAT OUR PROPOSAL
WOULD DO. I SEE MR. YEAH. CAN I
JUST RESPOND? SAYING THAT
SOMETHING IS A REBUTTABLE
PRESUMPTION AND THEN SAYING,
WELL, NO, WE'LL STRIKE THOSE
WORDS AND THEN JUST SAY THAT THE
TRANS THE, YOU KNOW, THE
INFORMATION AND THE TPP IS SHALL
CONSTITUTE SUBSTANTIAL EVIDENCE.
THAT'S THE SAME THING. IT'S THE
SAME THING. SO ALL WE'RE AND
THAT IS NOT WHAT'S IN THE
SETTLEMENT AGREEMENT. THE
SETTLEMENT AGREEMENT SIMPLY SAYS
THAT THEY WANT THE PUC TO TAKE
WHAT'S IN THE TRANSMISSION
PLANNING AND PUT IT INTO THE
STATEMENT OF OVERRIDE. BUT IT'S
NOT SAYING THAT IT WOULD
CONSTITUTE SUBSTANTIAL EVIDENCE.
IT'S NOT LIMITING THAT. SO THERE
IT FEELS A LITTLE SURREAL.
HONESTLY. THE CONVERSATION
BECAUSE THEIR THEIR PROPOSAL IS
ESSENTIALLY RESTATING THE THING
THAT WE'RE SAYING THAT WE'RE
OBJECTING TO. SO I THAT'S WHY
THIS HAS BEEN A VERY SOMEWHAT
FRUSTRATING CONVERSATION. AGAIN
I'M FINE WITH TAKING. THEY CAN
LITERALLY LIFT THE LANGUAGE OUT
OF THEIR SETTLEMENT PROPOSAL AND
PUT IT INTO THE BILL, AND WE
WOULD BE OKAY WITH THAT, BUT
THAT'S NOT WHAT THEY'RE DOING,
RIGHT? I MEAN, THAT'S THE THING.
I MEAN, YOU KEEP SAYING YOU WANT
TO CONFORM IT TO THE SETTLEMENT
AGREEMENT, BUT THERE'S NOT A
WILLING, YOU KNOW, THE
SETTLEMENT AGREEMENT. AND I'M
NOT SURE, I'M HAPPY TO GO INTO
THE DETAILS OF THE SETTLEMENT
AGREEMENT AND TALK THROUGH THE
WAY, THE WAY THAT THE, FOR
EXAMPLE, AB 1373 IS REBUTTABLE
PRESUMPTION OF THE NEED OF THE
PROJECT WAS ATTEMPTED TO BE
CARRIED THROUGHOUT THE CPUC
REVIEW AND CEQA PROCESS. THE
ENTIRE GOAL IS TO LEVERAGE THAT
FORECASTING AND PLANNING THE
APPROVAL OF THE SYSTEM OPERATOR
SO THAT THE CPUC DOESN'T REDO OR
TRY TO DUPLICATE WHERE THEY
CAN'T IN IN TAILORED PARTS OF
THE PROCESS, INCLUDING THE
POTENTIAL FOR A STATEMENT OF
OVERRIDING CONSIDERATIONS AND
THE LEGISLATURE HAS ALREADY
OBVIOUSLY PASSED AB 1373 AND
EXPRESSED THAT LEADERSHIP THAT
THE CPUC SHOULD DO THAT WHEN
CAISO HAS APPROVED A PROJECT.
BUT AS I SAID, WE HAVE PROPOSED
ALTERNATIVE LANGUAGE THAT WE
THINK DOES NOT OPERATE AS A
REBUTTABLE PRESUMPTION, BUT
STILL AFFORDS THAT IMPORTANT
WEIGHT TO THE CAISO
DETERMINATION. AND THAT'S REALLY
THE GOAL. IF THERE IS LANGUAGE
REFINEMENT THAT CAN AVOID SOME
OF THESE CONCERNS, FOR EXAMPLE,
MAKING SURE THAT THE AGENCY
STILL UNDERSTANDS THEY MUST
ISSUE A STATEMENT, THEY MUST
PROVIDE JUSTIFICATION. THEY WILL
PROVIDE TRANSPARENCY TO THE
PUBLIC AND TO STAKEHOLDERS, WHO
ARE INVOLVED IN THE PROCESS. WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT HAPPENS.
WE'RE NOT INTERESTED IN TYING
THE AGENCY'S HANDS. SO IF THERE
IS LANGUAGE THAT MAKES IT VERY
CLEAR THAT IT IS NOT A DE FACTO
RUBBER STAMP, WE'RE INTERESTED
IN DOING THAT, BUT WE WANT IT TO
BE A MEANINGFUL WEIGHT OF, OF
THE APPROVAL OF CAISO IN THAT
PROCESS. YEAH.
SO WHAT DO YOU THINK, MR. VICE
CHAIR? ARE YOU HAVING FUN? YEAH,
YEAH. WELL, LOOK, I MEAN, MY.
WELL, YEAH, WE. SYSTEM IS NOT
GOOD FOR ME, BUT. WELL, YEAH,
WHAT SYSTEM? YOU KNOW, I MEAN,
DEBATING AND DISCUSSING IT. YOU
DECIDE WHAT YOU'RE GOING TO DO
SO I CAN VOTE. I'M WAITING FOR.
THAT'S ALL I HAVE. YEAH OKAY.
LOOK, I MEAN, IF HE'S NOT
ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS, I'M
NOT GOING TO SUPPORT IT. NOW,
YOU KNOW, I WANT TO SAY. I WANT
TO SAY VERY CLEARLY AGAIN, AS I
DO OVER AND OVER AGAIN, THAT
THAT I AM I AM, YOU KNOW, VERY,
VERY WILLING TO, TO BE OPEN AND
NEGOTIATE OVER THE RECESS, YOU
KNOW, SO AS TO GET THESE ISSUES
LANDED. I JUST DON'T THINK WE'RE
GOING TO GET THIS FIGURED OUT
RIGHT NOW. I UNDERSTAND, YOU
KNOW, I UNDERSTAND THAT YOU'D
PREFER NOT TO. I GET THAT, YOU
KNOW, I'M JUST. I'LL TELL YOU,
THAT'S WHERE I AM, IT SEEMS LIKE
THIS REALLY COMES DOWN TO YOU
WANTING TO HAVE, YOU KNOW, AS
MUCH LEVERAGE AS YOU CAN IN THE
NEGOTIATION. NØ. AND THE
COMMITTEE WANTING TO HAVE AS
MUCH LEVERAGE TO. AND, YOU KNOW,
SO I'M NOT TRYING TO FAULT YOU
FOR THAT. YEAH, I UNDERSTAND
YOU'VE GOT A PERSPECTIVE. IT'S A
VALID ONE, IT'S DIFFERENT THAN
THE ONES THAT SOME OF THE ONES
THAT HAVE BEEN EXPRESSED AND,
YOU KNOW, MR. CHAIR, I. YEAH I'M
NOT HERE TO LEVERAGE ANYTHING.
NOT HERE TO PLAY GAMES AND NOT
HERE TO, EXTEND THE CONVERSATION
FAR MORE THAN IT NEEDS TO GO.
THE QUESTION IS, YOU KNOW, I'VE
SAID WE WILL STRIKE THE SEQUEL
LANGUAGE AND THAT NO LONGER
NEEDS TO BE A CONVERSATION.
WE'RE DONE THERE. SO THAT
AMENDMENT THAT YOU HAVE PUT
FORWARD IS IRRELEVANT. IF I'M
SAYING WE NO LONGER NEED TO DEAL
WITH THAT. THE QUESTION IS
FOCUSED AROUND THIS ISSUE OF THE
SETTLEMENT AGREEMENT. YOU KNOW,
I'M ASKING YOU RESPECTFULLY THAT
IF YOU TRULY ARE WANTING TO SEE
US WORK THIS THROUGH, WE'VE GOT
ANOTHER COMMITTEE COMING
FORWARD. GIVE US THE OPPORTUNITY
TO WORK, BRING US TOGETHER, HAVE
HAVE A WORK GROUP, FOR THE SIXTH
TIME, WITH STAKEHOLDERS. AND
LET'S WORK ON REFINING THIS
LANGUAGE AS OPPOSED TO JUST
TYING US DOWN TO THE LANGUAGE.
THAT'S THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT I'M
OFFERING. RIGHT? THAT'S EXACTLY
WHAT I'M OFFERING. WELL, AND IT
SOUNDS TO ME THAT THE POSITION
IS BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT THE
OPPOSITION WANTS AND NOT BECAUSE
THAT'S WHAT THE CHAIR IS WANTING
TO DO, WE JUST HEARD A BACK AND
FORTH THAT I THINK MERITS
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION. RIGHT
AND, AND THE OPTION THAT YOU'RE
GIVING US IS TAKE THAT OR YOU
DON'T HAVE A BILL. AND I THINK
EVERYONE RECOGNIZES THAT THIS IS
AN EXTREMELY IMPORTANT POLICY.
LOOK, WE DIDN'T COME IN HERE
WITH ANY OTHER INTENTION, BUT TO
HAVE THIS TYPE OF FREE FLOWING
CONVERSATION WITH THE
WILLINGNESS AND, READINESS TO
COMPROMISE ON THE CEQA PIECE
AND, AND HOPE THAT IN THE SAME
SPIRIT OF TRYING TO LEGISLATE
VIA TEXT MESSAGING, THAT WE
COULD HAVE THIS CONVERSATION
HERE AND THAT YOU WOULD BE
WILLING TO HAVE, A NEXT PHASE OF
THIS DISCUSSION, AND NOT ON THE
PREMISE OF JUST BECAUSE THE
OPPOSITION SAID NO, BUT BECAUSE
THERE IS STILL MORE WORK TO BE
DONE, AND THAT YOU ALWAYS HAVE
THE DISCRETION TO PULL THIS BILL
BACK. THE PREMISE, THE IT'S NOT
THE PREMISE IS THAT THE
COMMITTEE, IS CONCERNED THAT THE
WAY IT'S FRAMED RIGHT NOW
UNDERMINES, CEQA IN A WAY THAT
YOU DON'T BELIEVE. AND AGAIN,
IT'S A IT'S SOMETHING WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE TO NEGOTIATE. AND
BY THE WAY, SENATOR DALI, YOU'RE
WELCOME IN THE NEGOTIATION, TOO.
FOR THE FIRST TIME, YOU KNOW,
THERE YOU GO. NOW, THAT'S
LEVERAGE. YEAH. YOU KNOW, SO
THAT'S THAT'S I, YOU KNOW,
AGAIN, THAT'S THAT'S ALL. THAT'S
ALL THAT'S THAT'S ALL. IT SEEMS
LIKE WE'RE WE'RE CLOSE HERE,
BUT, WELL, LOOK, IT SEEMS LIKE
YOU'RE NOT TAKING THE. NO, NO,
IT SEEMS LIKE WE DON'T HAVE VERY
MUCH OPTION. AND SO IF WE HAVE
NO OPTION, WE'RE GOING TO ACCEPT
THE, WELCOMING OF CONTINUING THE
CONVERSATION WITH THAT, BECAUSE
IT DOESN'T SEEM LIKE WE HAVE
ANOTHER ALTERNATIVE. RIGHT, YOU
KNOW, AS I MENTIONED BEFORE, IN
MY TEN YEARS OF CHAIRING
COMMITTEES IN, IN THE SPIRIT OF
TRYING TO, LAND A GOOD POLICY,
WE'VE ALWAYS GIVEN, YOU KNOW,
OUR COLLEAGUES, THE COURTESY OF
CONTINUING TO WORK ON STUFF
WITHOUT BOGGING THEM DOWN ON,
SOMETHING THAT COULD NOT, AT THE
END OF THE DAY, BE REVERSIBLE
BECAUSE YOU'RE NOT GOING TO BE
ABLE TO GET THE OPPOSITION TO
AGREE WITH YOU IF YOU MOVE IN A
DIFFERENT POSITION BY US
ACCEPTING THIS AMENDMENT. LET ME
BE REALLY CLEAR. THE OPPOSITION,
YOU KNOW, DROPPING OPPOSITION IS
NOT A PREREQUISITE FOR AGREEMENT
WITH THE COMMITTEE. I MEAN, JUST
EARLIER, WE'VE HAD A NUMBER OF
PEOPLE IN THE, IN THE, IN HOUSE
HERE FROM THE ENVIRONMENTAL
COMMUNITY WHO HAVE OPPOSED BILLS
THAT WE'VE PUSHED, WE'VE
APPROVED. SO THIS COMMITTEE
ROUTINELY PASSES BILLS THAT HAVE
OPPOSITION FROM THE
ENVIRONMENTAL COMMUNITY. THIS
COMMITTEE HAS HAS PASSED ALL
SORTS OF CEQA FLEXIBILITY, YOU
KNOW, MUCH TO THE CHAGRIN OF
MANY PEOPLE IN THIS ROOM. SO,
YOU KNOW, I DON'T THINK THAT ONE
COULD CLAIM THAT THERE'S, IN OUR
IDEOLOGICAL PURITY TEST HERE.
CERTAINLY NOT IN THE LAST, YOU
KNOW, FIVE, SIX YEARS BEFORE
THIS COMMITTEE, AND I WILL SAY,
YOU KNOW, ASSEMBLY MEMBER, I
MEAN, YOU KNOW, LITERALLY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER THAT YOU GOT TO
REACH OUT TO ME ON THIS TOPIC
HAD DONE, YOU KNOW, EXACTLY WHAT
WE'RE DOING RIGHT HERE, WHICH IS
WHAT HE SAID. HEY, ACCEPT THE
AMENDMENTS. WE'LL HAVE FURTHER
NEGOTIATIONS. AND I DID EXACTLY
THAT. I DIDN'T CREATE A, YOU
KNOW, A YOU KNOW, I DID EXACTLY
THAT, AND WE'RE NOW ENGAGING IN
NEGOTIATIONS, SO MAYBE IT'S A,
IT'S A MATTER OF, OF. YEAH YEAH.
WHAT YOU'RE BASICALLY SAYING IS
THAT YOU'RE WILLING TO ACCEPT
THE AMENDMENT OF THE CEQA,
YOU'RE WILLING TO NÓ. WE'RE
STRIKING THE CEQA PIECE OUT OF
THE BILL, OKAY? IT'S OUT. SO
IT'S ALREADY OUT. SO THAT'S WHAT
YOU'VE CHANGED BECAUSE THE
AMENDMENT THAT THAT THAT IS
BEING PROPOSED IN THE SPIRIT OF
TRYING TO NARROW IT DOWN,
ACTUALLY DOESN'T WORK. AND IT
CREATES A LONGER PROCESS. AND,
PERIOD OF BUILDING OUT THE
TRANSMISSION. SO IT DOESN'T
WORK. SO LET'S JUST CUT THAT
PIECE OUT OF THE BILL, OKAY. SO
THEN THEN IT JUST THEN BASICALLY
IT MEANS THAT WE HAVE TO
NEGOTIATE THE REBUTTABLE
PRESUMPTION PORTION. AND IT
COMES DOWN TO THE EXTENT TO
WHICH THIS ADHERES TO THE
SETTLEMENT AGREEMENT OR NOT. AND
THERE'S JUST A DIFFERENCE OF YOU
KNOW, WE HEARD IT. THERE'S A
DIFFERENCE. CAN IT BE BRIDGED? I
I ASSUME SO I MEAN, WE'VE WE'VE
BRIDGED TOUGHER THINGS, YOU
KNOW, YOU AND I VERY RECENTLY ON
OTHER TOPICS. ASSEMBLY MEMBER,
HAVE, SO THAT'S WHERE WE ARE,
MR. VICE CHAIR. I MEAN, YOU
KNOW. I'M READY TO GO EAT
SOMETHING. YEAH I'M WILLING TO
MAKE A MOTION, GIVE IT A SHOT,
AND SEE IF WE CAN'T CONTINUE THE
BILL ON, AND MAYBE WE CAN WORK
IT OUT OVER THE BREAK OR
SOMETHING. AND, YOU KNOW, MAYBE
YOU WE CAN GET ON A ZOOM AND
TALK ABOUT THESE THINGS, BUT IF
YOU'RE WILLING TO ENTERTAIN
THAT, I'M AVAILABLE. WHAT IS
YOUR MOTION EXACTLY? WE MOVE THE
BILL. HE STARTED HE STRIKED OUT
THE PIECE THE SEQUA PIECE IS
GONE. THAT'S OUT. CORRECT. AND
THAT WE MOVE THE BILL ON TO
APPROPRIATIONS. OKAY. SO YOU'RE
NOT MOVING. THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS? NO. RIGHT OKAY.
BECAUSE WE'LL SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
HE TOOK HE DID TAKE SOME. HE
STRUCK OUT THE SECRET PART OF
IT, WHICH I THINK IS HEALTHY.
OKAY. THAT'S YOUR MOTION. WE
HAVE TO PUT IT IN WRITING FOR
FOLKS BECAUSE IT'S DIFFERENT
THAN THE AMENDMENTS WE. SO WE
HAVE TO RECESS TO DO THAT, I
WILL I WILL NOT BE SUPPORTING
THAT MOTION, BUT I'M CERTAINLY
OPEN TO SUPPORTING ANOTHER
MOTION. THAT, IS IN LINE WITH,
WITH THE AMENDMENTS, WITH THE
UNDERSTANDING THAT WE WILL WORK
ON TRYING TO LAND THE REBUTTABLE
PRESUMPTION LANGUAGE WITH THE
PROPONENTS. NOW, DO WE ACTUALLY
HAVE TO RECESS OR CAN WE HEAR
FROM ASSEMBLY MEMBER AGAR CURRY
TO PRESENT HER BILL WHILE WE
DRAW UP THE. GET A SECOND TO
THAT. I DON'T HAVE MY STAFF,
WELL, UNTIL WE FIGURE IT OUT.
OKAY.
LET'S TAKE A BRIEF RECESS.
HARA-KIRI. BILL. AS, THE FUN
CONTINUES ON THE GARCIA. BILL SO,
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHRIS HERE
PRESENTING AB 2514. THANK YOU,
SENATOR ALLEN. I APPRECIATE YOU
MOVING UP. I HAVE THINGS TO DO
TODAY LIKE YOU DO, THANK YOU,
MR. CHAIR. AND SENATORS. I WILL
BE ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS TODAY. MEMBERS, THE
ISSUE OF ORGANIC WASTE,
INCLUDING AG WASTE AND FOREST
BIOMASS, IS ONE I'VE BEEN
WORKING ON SINCE I CAME TO THE
CAPITOL IN 2016. AS I DRIVE
AROUND MY DISTRICT, I SEE FRUIT
AND NUT TREES BEING PULLED UP,
PILED AND BURNED BECAUSE THERE
WAS NOWHERE FOR THIS WASTE TO GO.
THIS ISSUE IS DEEPLY PERSONAL
BECAUSE MY FAMILY JUST MADE THE
GUT WRENCHING DECISION TO CUT
DOWN OUR WALNUT ORCHARD,
FIGURING OUT A SUSTAINABLE WAY
TO DEAL WITH THE MASSIVE AMOUNT
OF WOOD WASTE IS A LOGISTICAL
NIGHTMARE. COMMUNITIES LIKE THE
RURAL AREAS OF MY DISTRICT HAVE
BEEN STRUGGLING TO FIND WAYS TO
DIVERT THEIR ORGANIC WASTE FROM
LANDFILLS. WE NEED TO PUT THAT
WASTE TO BENEFICIAL, CLIMATE
FRIENDLY USE. THIS BILL TAKES
SEVERAL COMMON SENSE STEPS TO
HELP STREAMLINE THE PROCESS OF
PERMITTING A NARROW SET OF
BIOENERGY PROJECTS. FIRST, IT
CODIFIES FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
DEFINITION OF PYROLYSIS. IT DOES
NOT CHANGE HOW PYROLYSIS IS
PERMITTED OR REGULATED, BUT
HELPS PEOPLE KNOW WHAT PROJECTS
COUNT AS PYROLYSIS PROJECTS
HERE. SECOND, THIS BILL ALLOWS
COMMUNITIES TO GET PROCUREMENT
CREDIT FOR PROJECTS THAT USE
ONLY ORGANIC WASTE TO GENERATE
GREEN ENERGY. FINALLY, THIS BILL
ASKS, CALRECYCLE TO CONSIDER THE
LIFE CYCLE BENEFITS AND IMPACTS
OF PROJECTS WHEN IT MAKES
DECISIONS ON INCENTIVE FUNDING.
THIS IS A TECHNOLOGY NEUTRAL WAY
OF MAKING SURE THAT OUR WASTE
DISPOSAL PROCESS ARE CLIMATE
FRIENDLY. I HAVE ALREADY TAKEN
MANY AMENDMENTS TO NARROW THE
BILL AND ADDRESS OPPOSITION'S
CONCERNS, AND I WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK ON IT IF THE BILL MAKES IT
OUT OF COMMITTEE TODAY. THIS
BILL WILL HELP REDUCE FUTURE
EMISSIONS BY HELPING DIVERT
ORGANIC WASTE FROM LANDFILLS,
AND IT WILL HELP INCREASE ENERGY
RELIABILITY AND RESILIENCY TO
THOSE COMMUNITIES THAT NEED IT
THE MOST. WITH ME TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILLS ARE JULIA
LEVIN, EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
BIOENERGY ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA, AND EVAN EDGAR OF
EDGAR AND ASSOCIATES. GOOD
AFTERNOON, JULIA LEVIN, WITH THE
BIOENERGY ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA. CLIMATE SCIENTISTS
AGREE THAT THE MOST URGENT THING
WE CAN DO TO ADDRESS CLIMATE
CHANGE IS TO REDUCE SHORT LIVED
CLIMATE POLLUTANTS. AND THAT'S
WHY CALIFORNIA ENACTED SB 1383,
THE STATE'S SHORT LIVED CLIMATE
POLLUTANT REDUCTION LAW. THAT
LAW REQUIRES A 40% REDUCTION IN
METHANE AND A 75% REDUCTION IN
ORGANIC WASTE. GOING TO
LANDFILLS. UNFORTUNATELY,
CALIFORNIA IS MANY YEARS BEHIND
IN MEETING THAT WASTE DIVERSION
REQUIREMENT, AND AS A RESULT,
LAST YEAR, THE LITTLE HOOVER
COMMISSION ISSUED A REPORT ON
WHAT WHAT THE STATE COULD DO TO
ACCELERATE LANDFILL DIVERSION TO
MEET OUR METHANE REDUCTION
REQUIREMENTS. ONE OF THE CHIEF
RECOMMENDATIONS OF THE LITTLE
HOOVER COMMISSION WAS TO GIVE
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS MORE MARKET
OPPORTUNITIES, MORE OPTIONS FOR
THE DIVERTED ORGANIC WASTE. AND
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT AB 2514
WOULD DO. IT CREATES AN
ADDITIONAL PATHWAY THAT LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS CAN CHOOSE. IT
DOESN'T PUT ITS FINGERS ON THE
SCALES, IT JUST SAYS IT GIVES
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AN ADDITIONAL
OPTION, WHICH IS CONVERTING
ORGANIC WASTE TO PIPELINE
BIOMETHANE. PURSUANT TO OTHER
STATE LEGISLATION, SB 1440, THE
BILL IS FOCUSED EXCLUSIVELY ON
ORGANIC WASTE AND NON BURNING
TECHNOLOGIES. PYROLYSIS, WHICH
IS HIGH TEMPERATURE THERMAL
DECOMPOSITION AND THE CREATION
OF PIPELINE BIOMETHANE, WHICH IS
DONE THROUGH ANAEROBIC
DIGESTION. SO CONCERNS THAT THE
BILL WOULD SOMEHOW PROMOTE TRASH
BURNING ARE REALLY MISGUIDED
BASED ON THE WRONG TECHNOLOGIES,
NOT TECHNOLOGIES AT ISSUE IN
THIS BILL. AND FINALLY, ONE OF
THE OTHER REQUIREMENTS OF SB
1383, THE STATE'S SHORT LIVED
CLIMATE POLLUTANTS LAW. THERE IS
A SPECIFIC REQUIREMENT IN THAT
BILL FOR STATE AGENCIES TO ADOPT
POLICIES AND INCENTIVES TO
INCREASE THE IN-STATE PRODUCTION
OF RENEWABLE GAS FROM ORGANIC
WASTE AS A WAY TO REDUCE SHORT
LIVED CLIMATE POLLUTANTS.
SEVERAL OF THE OPPONENTS TO THE
BILL HAVE SAID THAT THIS BILL,
AB TWO 2514, CONTRADICTS THE
GOALS OF SB 1383 AND NOTHING
COULD BE FARTHER FROM THE TRUTH.
IT ACTUALLY SPECIFICALLY
IMPLEMENTS ONE OF THE
REQUIREMENTS OF SB 1383 TO
INCREASE RENEWABLE GAS FROM
ORGANIC WASTE AS A WAY TO REDUCE
SHORT LIVED CLIMATE POLLUTANTS.
SO WE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THE
COMMITTEE'S AYE VOTE ON THIS
IMPORTANT LEGISLATION. COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. MY NAME IS EVAN EDGAR
EDGAR ASSOCIATES. I'M THE PERMIT
ENGINEER FOR ANAEROBIC DIGESTION
FACILITIES STATEWIDE AND
RECOMMEND AND REPRESENT ORGANIC
WASTE HAULERS. WHAT WE DO RIGHT
NOW I PERMITTED OVER SIX
FACILITIES. WE MAKE A CARBON
NEGATIVE BIOMETHANE. WE PUT IT
RIGHT BACK INTO THE TRUCK. IT'S
A BEAUTIFUL WORLD. HOWEVER, AT
THE AIR BOARD, THERE ARE FORCING
ADVANCED CLEAN FLEET RULE THAT
WILL FORCE US INTO BATTERY
ELECTRIC. WITH THAT, WE CAN'T
PUT OUR BOTTLE METHANE IN THE
TRUCK ANYMORE. CARB IS COMMITTED
AS PART OF THE VANS CLEAN FLEET
RULE IN ORDER TO FIND A HOME FOR
BIOMETHANE FOR HARD TO
DECARBONIZE COMMUNITIES. SO WE
MAKE THE BIOMETHANE. WE GOT TO
PUT IT SOMEWHERE IN ORDER TO
DELIVER IT. WE NEED A PUC
PIPELINE SO WE WILL CONTINUE TO
MAKE BIOMETHANE FUEL FOR THE
HARD TO DECARBONIZE INDUSTRY.
AND WE NEED LOCAL GOVERNMENT AS
PART OF 1383 PROCUREMENT TO BUY
THAT BIOMETHANE. FOR THOSE
REASONS, WE URGE YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. OKAY. OTHER FOLKS WHO
WANT TO VOICE SUPPORT FOR THE
BILL, CHAIR SENATOR DEAN HELLER
WITH CAPITAL ADVOCACY HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE COUNTY OF LOS
ANGELES IN SUPPORT OF AB 2514.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. HI. GOOD
AFTERNOON, CHAIR. MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE ALFREDO ARREDONDO, ON
BEHALF OF THE GREEN HYDROGEN
COALITION AND H CYCLE, WE
SUPPORT THE BILL IN PRINT WITH
THE COMMITTEE. AMENDMENTS WILL
UNFORTUNATELY HAVE uGO
NEUTRAL. BUT LOOK FORWARD TO THE
CONTINUING CONVERSATION ON THOSE
PROVISIONS. THANK YOU. OKAY
KUDOS HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
SOLID WASTE ASSOCIATION OF NORTH
AMERICA LEGISLATIVE TASK FORCE,
THE CALIFORNIA CHAPTERS IN
SUPPORT. JENNIFER HAMILTON WITH
THE CALIFORNIA HYDROGEN BUSINESS
COUNCIL. WE SUPPORT THE BILL IN
PRINT. WE DO NOT SUPPORT THE
REMOVAL OF HYDROGEN AND DO LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING THOSE
CONVERSATIONS. THANK YOU.
CRYSTAL. WITH CALIFORNIA AGAINST
WASTE WITH THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS, WE ARE NO LONGER
OPPOSED TO THE BILL. THANK YOU.
OKAY. OPPOSITION FOLKS WHO WANT
TO RAISE CONCERNS ABOUT THE BILL.
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON. MY
NAME IS AVI CAR, AND I'M A
SENIOR ATTORNEY WITH THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL. OR
NRDC. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY TODAY. WE
UNDERSTAND THAT THE AUTHOR HAS
AGREED TO TAKE AMENDMENTS ALONG
THE LINES OF THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS. WE APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR'S AND THE COMMITTEE'S
ATTENTION TO OUR CONCERNS, AND
WE WILL REVIEW THE AMENDED
LANGUAGE AS SOON AS IT IS
AVAILABLE. AND OUR DISEASE DOES
NOT SUPPORT USING ORGANIC WASTE,
ESPECIALLY SAU SEPARATED ORGANIC
WASTE, AS FEEDSTOCKS TO PRODUCE
HYDROGEN, AS THE BILL IN PRINT
WOULD ENCOURAGE. HYDROGEN
PRODUCTION IS NOT THE MOST
ECOLOGICALLY PREFERRED WAY TO
TREAT ORGANIC WASTE BECAUSE TRUE
ORGANICS RECYCLING RETURNS
NUTRIENTS AND CARBON TO THE SOIL
BY COMPOSTING OR SIMILAR
PROCESSES, ALLOWING HYDROGEN
PRODUCED FROM ORGANIC WASTE TO
COUNT AS DIVERSION UNDERCUTS.
1383 STATED INTENT TO SUPPORT
THE ADOPTION OF POLICIES THAT
IMPROVE ORGANICS RECYCLING.
RECYCLING WOULD NOT HAPPEN UNDER
THAT SCENARIO. HYDROGEN PRODUCED
FROM ORGANIC WASTE SHOULD NOT
COUNT AS RECOVERED. ORGANIC
WASTE PRODUCT FOR PURPOSES OF
MEETING THE PROCUREMENT
REQUIREMENTS UNDER SB 1383, NRDC
IS ALSO CONCERNED THAT THE
CURRENT VERSION OF AB 21 2514
WOULD INCENTIVIZE THE USE OF
PYROLYSIS, WHICH IS A TYPE OF
INCINERATION THAT REQUIRES HIGH
TEMPERATURES AND PRESSURES AND
IS THEREFORE VERY ENERGY
INTENSIVE. WHEN PLASTIC IS USED
AS A FEEDSTOCK, PYROLYSIS
GENERATES TOXIC AIR POLLUTANTS
AND LARGE QUANTITIES OF
HAZARDOUS WASTE. THIS IS
RELEVANT TO AB 2514 AND AS IN
PRINT SINCE THE COMMITTEE SINCE
AS THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS NOTES,
EVEN SOURCE SEPARATED COMPONENTS
OF MUNICIPAL SOLID WASTE HAVE
SIGNIFICANT CONTAMINATION FROM
OTHER MATERIALS, INCLUDING
PLASTIC, POTENTIALLY AS HIGH AS
10. THANK YOU FOR CONSIDERING
OUR VIEWS. THANK YOU. I'M JANE
WILLIAMS. I'M THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITIES AGAINST TOXICS. THIS
WILL BE THE 15TH TIME I'VE
APPEARED IN FRONT OF THE STATE
LEGISLATURE ON THIS TOPIC.
DURING MY 30 YEAR CAREER.
SENATOR DALLI IS SO GREAT TO SEE
YOU HERE. AND THE GREAT REPARTEE
THAT YOU BRING TO ALL OF THESE
PROCEEDINGS. I REMEMBER WHEN IN
THE ASSEMBLY. SO FIRST OF ALL,
I'D LIKE TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
STAFF AND THE COMMITTEE, FOR
DOING A FANTASTIC JOB ON THE
AMENDMENTS, NUMBER TWO AND I
WANT TO HOPEFULLY I'LL GET A
CHANCE TO SAY THIS A NUMBER OF
TIME DURING MY TESTIMONY HERE
THAT WE CAN'T BURN OUR WAY OUT
OF THE CLIMATE CRISIS. WE JUST
CAN'T. IT'S NOT GOING TO WORK.
SO I WANT TO TALK ABOUT HOW
PYROLYSIS UNITS ARE ACTUALLY
REGULATED UNDER FEDERAL LAW IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. IT'S A
SIMPLE CONCEPT. THEY'RE NOT. SO
CURRENTLY, THE EXISTING
PYROLYSIS FACILITIES IN THE
UNITED STATES DO NOT HAVE TO
MEET A CLEAN AIR ACT STANDARD.
AND SO THOUGH WE HAVE STANDARDS
IN OUR STATE FOR MUNICIPAL WASTE
INCINERATORS, WE DO NOT HAVE OUR
OWN STANDARDS FOR PYROLYSIS
UNITS OR ANY OTHER KIND OF
INCINERATORS. WE FOLLOW THE
FEDERAL CLEAN AIR ACT. AND
THOUGH WE HAVE BEEN HAVING A
HUGE FIGHT ABOUT THE REGULATION
OF PYROLYSIS AT THE FEDERAL
LEVEL, CURRENTLY EVERY EXISTING
PYROLYSIS FACILITY IS BEING
OPERATED WITH AN EXEMPTION
THAT'S BEEN GRANTED BY EITHER
EPA REGION OR THE OFFICE OF AIR
AND RADIATION. SO THAT'S HUGELY
PROBLEMATIC, ESPECIALLY WHEN WE
KNOW WHERE THESE FACILITIES ARE
GOING TO GO. THEY'RE GOING TO GO
IN THE TOP 10. CARLEVARO SCREEN
ARE ABSOLUTELY MOST VULNERABLE
AND HIGHLY IMPACTED COMMUNITIES,
JUST LIKE THE METAL SHREDDERS
THAT YOU HEARD ABOUT LATER.
EARLIER THIS EARLIER. SO I WANT
TO TALK ABOUT ONE OF THE OTHER
SERIOUS PROBLEMS IS THAT DESPITE
AB 939, WHICH HAS NOW BEEN IN
PLACE SINCE 1989, WE REALLY DO
NOT HAVE CLEAN ORGANICS. IT IS
VERY DIFFICULT TO GET ORGANIC
WASTE. IT HAS NOT BEEN
CONTAMINATED WITH OTHER
DIFFERENT TYPES OF TRASH, I
THINK SENATOR SCHEER WOULD BE
ROLLING IN HIS GRAVE TO KNOW
THAT AB 939 REALLY HAS NOT DONE
A GOOD JOB OF ACTUALLY GETTING
ACTUAL RECYCLING HAPPENING IN
THE UNITED STATES, IN
CALIFORNIA, RATHER. SO I ALSO
WANT TO POINT OUT THAT THE IRA
GRANTS HUGE INCENTIVES FOR
HYDROGEN, AND THESE INCENTIVES
UP TO $1.25 A GALLON ARE SKEWING
ENVIRONMENTAL POLICY HERE IN
CALIFORNIA AND NATIONALLY
ALREADY. AND SO WE ARE SEEING
PROPOSALS TO JUST BURN
EVERYTHING TO MAKE HYDROGEN BY
BURNING THINGS, WHICH IS REALLY
JUST A FIG LEAF FOR, FOR
ESSENTIALLY FOSSIL FUELS TO
HYDROGEN, WHICH IS WHAT THE
EXISTING H CYCLE PROPOSAL IS IN
PITTSBURGH, WHICH PITTSBURGH,
CALIFORNIA IS ONE OF OUR MOST
HIGHLY IMPACTED COMMUNITIES. TOP
10% CALENVIROSCREEN, THEIR
FEEDSTOCK IS WITH THE PROCESS
FLOW DIAGRAMS THAT WE RECENTLY
RECEIVED FROM CALRECYCLE. IT'S
PLANNED TO BE MSW, NOT ORGANIC
WASTE. SO I ALSO WANT TO POINT
OUT TO THE COMMITTEE THAT THOSE
OF YOU WHO KNOW ME WELL KNOW I
LIVE IN THE MOJAVE DESERT, AND
IT'S GOING TO BE 117 DEGREES ON
FRIDAY. SO WE HAVE BEEN WORKING
MY ORGANIZATION AND MY PARTNERS
ACROSS THE STATE HAVE BEEN
WORKING ON CLIMATE POLICY NOW
SINCE THE EARLY 2000, WE HAVE
OPPOSED, YOU KNOW, FALSE
SOLUTIONS, COMBUSTIONS, GIVING
SUBSIDIES FOR FALSE SOLUTIONS.
AND WE SEE THAT THOSE SAME
FORCES ARE STILL, WELL, WELL
ENDOWED AND VERY MUCH ALIVE. SO,
IT HAS BEEN FASCINATING FOR ME
TO SEE MANY OF THE ISSUES I'VE
WORKED ON OVER MY CAREER ROLL
OUT IN THE COMMITTEE TODAY. AND
I WOULD JUST SAY IN A CLOSING
STATEMENT TO SAY THAT THIS
LEGISLATURE AND THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND THIS GOVERNOR
HAVE MADE PROMISES TO OUR
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
COMMUNITIES, AND WE NEED TO DO
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO MAKE SURE
THAT THOSE PROMISES ARE ANIMATED
AND ALIVE. AND ONE OF THOSE
CANNOT BE TO PUT NEW COMBUSTION
UNITS IN THOSE COMMUNITIES.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. OKAY, OTHER
FOLKS WHO WANT TO RAISE CONCERNS
ABOUT THE BILL OR OPPOSITION.
ALL RIGHT, BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE. LET ME JUST START, BY
IT SEEMS LIKE WE. YEAH LET ME
LET ME THANK THE, THE CHAIR, FOR
WORKING REALLY CLOSELY WITH THE
COMMITTEE, AND MAKING THE BILL
MORE TAILORED TO ADDRESS A LOT
OF THE CONCERNS THAT WE'VE HEARD
ADDRESSED BY THE FOLKS IN
OPPOSITION TODAY. I KNOW THAT
THE AMENDMENTS DON'T, FULLY
REMOVE OPPOSITION, BUT I
CERTAINLY I KNOW THAT THEY GO A
LONG WAY TOWARD ADDRESSING A LOT
OF THE KEY CONCERNS FROM THE
ENVIRONMENTAL COMMUNITY. YOU
KNOW, WE HEARD EARLIER, BILL,
FROM SENATOR LEE, AB 2346. AND
THE IDEA HERE IN BOTH CASES IS
THAT WERE THERE ATTEMPTS TO GIVE
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS MORE
FLEXIBILITY TO REACH THE 1383
PROCUREMENT TARGETS, WHICH WE
HEAR ABOUT ALL THE TIME FROM
FROM FOLKS IN LOCAL GOVERNMENT,
YOU KNOW WHAT? I KNOW LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS HAVE BEEN WORKING
INCREDIBLY HARD TO, TO REACH
THEIR 1383 GOALS, WE KNOW WE'RE
FALLING SHORT OF THOSE TARGETS,
ESPECIALLY FOR THE IN THE EFFORT
OF, YOU KNOW, PROCURING RECYCLED
ORGANIC MATERIAL, TO KEEP THAT
MATERIAL OUT OF LANDFILLS, YOU
KNOW, UNDER UNDER 1383, AS WE'VE
BEEN TALKING ABOUT, BIOMETHANE,
BIOMETHANE IS ELIGIBLE FOR
PROCUREMENT CREDIT, BUT ONLY IF
IT'S USED ON SITE. AND, YOU
KNOW, THERE'S BEEN THERE'S BEEN
SOME TENSION HERE OVER, YOU
KNOW, DIFFERENT OBJECTIVES OF
THE STATE. WE WANT TO SOME
ADVANCING BIOMETHANE PRODUCTION
UNDER 1383 WHILE TRANSITIONING
TO ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES. AND
MANY OF US HAVE BEEN INVOLVED IN
THAT DISCUSSION FOR A LONG TIME.
SO, YOU KNOW, WHILE EXPANDING,
PROCUREMENT CREDIT TO GO TO, TO
PIPELINE BIOMETHANE IS CERTAINLY
A BIG EXPANSION. I DO THINK
THAT, IT'S A SMART WAY TO
RESOLVE THAT CONFLICT BETWEEN
OBJECTIVES AND REACHING 1383
PROCUREMENT TARGETS AND ALSO
REACHING OUR, OUR ZEV GOALS, YOU
KNOW, ONE OF THE MAIN CONCERNS
ON THIS BILL HAS BEEN THAT
ORGANIC MATERIAL STREAMS ARE
POLLUTED SO THAT WHEN WE'RE
THINKING OF CONVERTING ORGANIC
WASTE INTO ENERGY, WE ALSO HAVE
TO THINK ABOUT WHAT ELSE IS IN
THAT WASTE STREAM. YOU KNOW,
ORGANIC WASTE STREAM IS
CONTAMINATED WITH PLASTIC, WHICH
WE KNOW IT IS. THEN HIGH
TEMPERATURE TECHNOLOGIES THAT
CAN GASIFY OR, YOU KNOW,
PARALLELIZE OR COMBUST PLASTIC
COULD THEN LEAD TO PRODUCING
ENERGY FROM PLASTIC OR OTHER
CONTAMINANTS. AND THERE'S
POLLUTION ASSOCIATED. I MEAN, OF
COURSE, THE STATE'S, YOU KNOW,
TAKING STEPS TO MOVE AWAY FROM
INCENTIVIZING WASTE TO ENERGY.
SO WE HAVE TO BE REALLY CAREFUL
ABOUT WHERE THIS FITS INTO THAT,
ALSO, OF COURSE, BECAUSE THE
ORGANIC STREAM HAS
CONTAMINATION, WE DON'T REALLY
KNOW WHAT TOXIC OR CRITERIA AIR
POLLUTANTS COULD BE EMITTED FROM
THOSE FACILITIES. IF WE'RE
CONVERTING MIXED PLASTICS AND
ORGANICS INTO ENERGY. SO I KNOW
THERE'S MORE TO FIGURE OUT HERE.
PART OF THIS IS THAT OR HYDROGEN
PRODUCTION FROM ORGANICS BIO
PYROLYSIS IS PRETTY NEW
TECHNOLOGY. SO AS WE AS WE
FIGURE OUT THE RIGHT PATH
FORWARD TO REACH OUR 1383 GOALS,
WHILE YOU KNOW AND PROTECT
COMMUNITIES FROM AIR POLLUTION,
I THINK THAT'S WHY THAT WAS THAT
WAS THE IDEA BEHIND TAKING
HYDROGEN OUT OF THE BILL. AS WE
FIGURE OUT AS A STATE, YOU KNOW,
HOW TO HOW TO BEST MOVE FORWARD
WITH HYDROGEN IN A WAY THAT'S
TRULY GREEN AND ADVANCES THE
ZERO EMISSIONS FUTURE. YOU KNOW,
THE HYDROGEN CONVERSATION
CONTINUES. WE HAVE HAD MANY
DISCUSSIONS ON SEVERAL BILLS
BEFORE THIS COMMITTEE. AND, YOU
KNOW, I THINK ONCE AGAIN, WE'RE
VERY INTERESTED IN BEING PART OF
THAT DISCUSSION. AND VERY OPEN
MINDED. I MEAN, THERE ARE A LOT
OF PEOPLE WHO ARE, YOU KNOW,
DON'T WANT ANY HYDROGEN UNDER
ANY CIRCUMSTANCES, AND THERE'S
THOSE THAT WANT IT UNDER EVERY
CIRCUMSTANCE. AND WE'RE
OBVIOUSLY NOT IN EITHER OF THOSE
CAMPS. SO I AM THANKFUL TO THE
AUTHOR FOR AGREEING TO TAKE THIS
AMENDMENT AS WE CONTINUE TO
FIGURE OUT HOW BEST TO SUPPORT
LOCALS IN REACHING THE GOALS,
ADVANCING CLEAN ENERGY,
PROTECTING HISTORICALLY
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES, BUT I
KNOW THAT THIS CONVERSATION IS
GOING TO CONTINUE. AND, SO WITH
THAT, I'D LOVE TO OPEN UP THE
FLOOR TO MEMBERS WITH QUESTIONS.
MOVE BY SENATOR AND ANY OTHER
DISCUSSION OR THOUGHTS. NO.
OKAY. MOVED BY SENATOR. SORRY
FOR BEING LONG WINDED. AND,
LET'S CALL THE ROLL, GIVE YOU AN
OPPORTUNITY TO CLOSE. I'M SORRY.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR. I WILL.
OKAY, GREAT, SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL AB 2514. THE
MOTION IS DUE. PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS. SENATORS
ALLEN I, ALLEN I, DOLLY I DALLI.
AYE. GONZALEZ HURTADO MENGIBAR
NGUYEN. NGUYEN I SKINNER.
SKINNER I OKAY SO WE'LL LEAVE
THAT OPEN FOR FOLKS TO, FOR
FOLKS TO ADD ON, SORRY. YES. BUT
I DO THINK WE SHOULD. I MEAN,
WE'VE GOT. WELL, OKAY. YEAH,
LET'S DO ITEM 15, LET'S START IN
15 BECAUSE WE WERE, WE WERE WE
LIFTED CALLS AND WE WANT TO GIVE
YOU THE OPPORTUNITY. AND THEN
EDDIE. EDDIE SHOWED UP. SO, SO
WE'RE GOING TO LIFT THE CALL ON
ITEM 15. THIS IS, AB 2450 FOR
ALEX LEE'S BILL. AB 2454. THE
MOTION IS DUE PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. THE CURRENT VOTE
IS 1 TO 0. SENATOR SALLY
GONZALEZ HURTADO MENGIBAR NGUYEN
SKINNER, THIS IS LEE. THIS IS
ALEX LEE'S 2346 2025 24 TO 2454.
YEAH HI. OKAY. I WILL ENTERTAIN
A MOTION FOR AGUIAR-CURRY. WE
JUST DID, OKAY BONTA 2851 AB
2851 THE MOTION IS DUE PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS. THE
CURRENT VOTE IS 1 TO 0. SENATORS
DALLI GONZALEZ, HURTADO,
MENGIBAR NGUYEN. SKINNER
SKINNER. AYE. 2 TO 0. OKAY. 2 TO
0. WE'LL LEAVE THAT OPEN.
CALDERON AB 2958 NEEDS A MOTION.
WHICH ONE? THIS IS CALDERON AB
2958 18. I'LL MOVE IT IF YOU
NEED A MOTION. YEAH. OKAY. MOVED
BY THE VICE CHAIR. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. AB 2958.
THE MOTION IS DUE. PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. SENATORS ALLEN I
ALLEN I, DALLI GONZALEZ HURTADO
MENGIBAR. NGUYEN. SKINNER I
SKINNER. AYE. 2 TO 0 OKAY. ALL
RIGHT. SO I'D LIKE WE. YEAH.
WE'RE BACK TO GARCIA. YEAH I
WANT TO STATE MY MOTION. THE
MOTION WOULD BE DUE PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS AS AMENDED IN THE
COMMITTEE TO REMOVE SEQUA
PROVISION OF THE BILL AND A
COMMITMENT FROM THE AUTHOR TO
CONTINUE TO WORK AND RESOLVE THE
DIFFERENCES OF OPINION ON
WHETHER THE LANGUAGE ACCURATELY
REFLECTS THE SETTLEMENT
AGREEMENT PROVISIONS. YOU HAVE
TO HAVE THAT IN WRITING FOR THE
OKAY, OKAY. APPARENTLY WE HAVE
TO HAVE THAT IN WRITING TO PASS
OUT TO EVERYONE. YEAH. UNLESS
OTHERWISE I CAN MAKE A COUNTER
MOTION. YEAH. OKAY WELL, WE'LL
HAVE TO GET IT. SOMEBODY TO
PRINT IT FOR ME, THEN. OKAY,
WELL, WE CAN LIFT CALLS ON
EVERYTHING ELSE, RIGHT? YEAH. SO
SOMEONE'S GOT TO WORK ON THAT. I
GUESS. STAFF TO DO THAT, OKAY.
AND THEN WE'LL LIFT THE CALLS ON
EVERYTHING ELSE SO THAT SENATOR
SKINNER CAN ADD ON. WE'LL START
FROM THE TOP, ITEM ONE, AB 1042,
BAUER Kò HÌNH. THE MOTION I JUST
SENT IT TO. THE MOTION IS DUE.
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. THE CURRENT VOTE
IS 1 TO 0. SENATORS. DALLI WHICH
ONE? NUMBER ONE 1042. GONZALEZ
HURTADO. MENGIBAR NGUYEN.
SKINNER. SKINNER I OKAY. WE'LL,
PRINT IT OUT AND PASS IT OUT. SO
WHO'S GOING TO DO THAT, CAN YOU
EMAIL IT TO ME AND WE'LL SEND
SOMEBODY OUT TO GO DO THAT. AND
SURE, WE'LL HAVE TO RECESS WHILE
THAT'S DONE. IT'S GOING TO TAKE
TIME AND BACK TO THE OFFICE.
THAT'S.
LET'S DO. ALL RIGHT, AB 2085
BAUER-KAHAN. AB 2085. THE MOTION
IS TO PASS, AS AMENDED, TO
APPROPRIATIONS. THE CURRENT VOTE
IS 2 TO 2, WITH THE CHAIR VOTING
AYE AND THE VICE CHAIR VOTING
NO. SENATORS GONZALEZ. MENGIBAR
SKINNER. SKINNER. AYE. AB 2085.
BAUER-KAHAN MENGIBAR. AYE 4 TO
2. 4 TO 2. WE WILL. WE'LL KEEP
THAT ROLL OPEN. ALL RIGHT, LET'S
GO TO B¢O. BAUER-KAHAN 2214. THE
MOTION IS DUE. PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. THE CURRENT VOTE
IS 1 TO 1, WITH THE CHAIR VOTING
AYE AND THE VICE CHAIR VOTING
NO. SENATORS GONZALEZ HURTADO,
HURTADO. AYE. MENGIBAR SKINNER.
OKAY. THAT IS 3 TO 3 TO ONE ONE.
WE'RE GOING TO LEAVE THAT OPEN
NOW. WE'LL GO TO B¢O.
BAUER-KAHAN 2236. THE MOTION IS
DUE. PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. THE CURRENT VOTE
IS 2 TO 2, WITH THE CHAIR VOTING
AYE AND THE VICE CHAIR VOTING
NO. SENATORS GONZALEZ MENGIBAR
SKINNER. AYE. SKINNER. AYE. 3 TO
2. THAT'S 3 TO 2. GIVE ME ONE
SECOND.
THAT BRINGS US TO, ITEM FIVE, AB
1122 BANES. THE MOTION IS DUE.
PASS, AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. THE CURRENT VOTE
IS 4 TO 0. SENATORS GONZALEZ
MENGIBAR SKINNER. AYE. OKAY,
WE'LL LEAVE THAT OPEN, ITEM SIX,
AB 1296. GRAYSON THE MOTION IS
DUE. PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS. THE
CURRENT VOTE IS 3 TO 0. SENATORS
GONZALEZ HURTADO. HURTADO. AYE.
MENGIBAR SKINNER. SKINNER. AYE.
OKAY THAT IS 5 TO 0. WE'LL LEAVE
THAT OPEN. PAPINE. AB 1359. THE
MOTION IS DUE. PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. THE CURRENT VOTE
IS 3 TO 0. SENATORS GONZALEZ
HURTADO. HURTADO. AYE MENGIBAR.
SKINNER. SKINNER AYE. OKAY.
THAT'S, 5 TO 0. AND IF I COULD
ASK YOU TO MENTION THE CHAIR AND
THE VICE CHAIRS VOTES WHEN YOU
ANNOUNCE THE. YES THE BILLS,
THAT WOULD BE FANTASTIC. OKAY.
ITEM EIGHT, THIS IS AB 1921
PAPINE AB 1921. THE MOTION IS
DUE. PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS. THE
CURRENT VOTE IS 2 TO 0, WITH THE
CHAIR VOTING AYE AND THE VICE
CHAIR VIÆT VOTING AYE. SENATORS
GONZALEZ HURTADO. HURTADO AYE.
MENGIBAR NGUYEN. SKINNER
SKINNER. AYE OKAY, DO WE DO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR FOR EVERYONE?
WE STARTED IT. YES. LET'S DO
THAT. OKAY. FILE ITEM NUMBER
NINE STARTS THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
SENATORS GONZALEZ HURTADO.
HURTADO. AYE. MENGIBAR SKINNER.
AYE OKAY, LET'S GO TO BERMAN'S,
AB 2083. THE MOTION IS TO PASS,
AS AMENDED, TO APPROPRIATIONS.
THE CURRENT VOTE IS 1 TO 2, WITH
THE CHAIR VOTING AYE AND THE
VICE CHAIR VOTING NO. SENATORS
GONZALEZ HURTADO. HURTADO. AYE.
MENGIBAR SKINNER. THIS IS ITEM
11. RIGHT. ITEM 11. YEA. AB
2083. OKAY. THAT IS 3 TO 2.
WE'LL LEAVE THAT OPEN, ITEM 12
AB 2298 HART. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS, AS AMENDED, TO
APPROPRIATIONS. CURRENT VOTE IS
3 TO 0 WITH THE CHAIR VOTING AYE
AND THE VICE CHAIR VOTING AYE.
SENATORS GONZALEZ HURTADO.
HURTADO. AYE. MENGIBAR SKINNER.
SKINNER. AYE. OKAY 5 TO 0. WE'LL
LEAVE THAT OPEN. ITEM 13 AB
2300. WILSON THE CURRENT VOTE IS
3 TO 0. THE MOTION IS DUE. PASS
WITH THE CHAIR VOTING AYE AND
THE VICE CHAIR VOTING AYE.
SENATORS GONZALEZ HURTADO.
HURTADO. AYE. MENGIBAR SKINNER.
SKINNER. AYE. 5 TO 0. WE'LL
LEAVE THAT OPEN. ITEM 14 AB 2346
LI. THE MOTION IS TO PASS, AS
AMENDED, TO APPROPRIATIONS. THE
CURRENT VOTE IS 3 TO 0, WITH THE
CHAIR VOTING AYE AND THE VICE
CHAIR VOTING AYE. SENATORS
GONZALEZ HURTADO. Ó HURTADO.
AYE MENGIBAR. SKINNER. SKINNER.
AYE JUST TO PRINT IT OUT. YES.
WHY. ARE WALKING AND OUT. YEAH.
SHE'S FROM. SHE'S TALKING ABOUT.
PASS IT OUT. OKAY I'VE BEEN
WAITING TO DO THE CLAUSE BEFORE.
IS THAT ALWAYS. I'LL JUST NOT DO
POLICY IF THAT'S THE ISSUE.
THAT'S I KNOW WE'RE NOT.
WE'RE NOW, ITEM 15 AB 2454. LEE,
THE MOTION IS DUE. PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. THE CURRENT VOTE
IS 2 TO 0 WITH THE CHAIR VOTING
AYE. SENATORS DALI GONZALEZ
HURTADO. HURTADO. AYE. MENGIBAR
NGUYEN. SKINNER. SKINNER.
SKINNER IS ALREADY NIGHT. OKAY
SO THAT'S 3 TO 2. WE'RE GOING TO
LEAVE THAT OPEN. AGUIAR-CURRY
ITEM 16 2514. THE MOTION IS DUE.
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. THE CURRENT VOTE
IS 4 TO 0, WITH THE CHAIR VOTING
AYE AND THE VICE CHAIR VOTING
AYE. SENATORS GONZALEZ HURTADO.
HURTADO I MENGIBAR OKAY, THAT'S
5 TO 0. WE'LL LEAVE THAT OPEN.
ITEM 17 BONTA AB 2851. THE
MOTION IS DUE. PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS. THE CURRENT
VOTE IS 2 TO 0, WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING AYE. SENATORS DALI
GONZALEZ HURTADO HURTADO AYE.
MENGIBAR NGUYEN. OKAY, THAT'S 3
TO 0. WE'LL LEAVE THAT OPEN,
ITEM 18 2958 CALDERON THE MOTION.
2851 YOU YEAH. YOU'RE AN AYE.
YES. WE GOT YOU ALREADY. OKAY
YEAH, YEAH. 2958 THE MOTION IS
DUE. PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS. THE
CURRENT VOTE IS 2 TO 0 WITH THE
CHAIR VOTING AYE. SENATORS DALI
GONZALEZ HURTADO. HURTADO. AYE.
MENGIBAR NGUYEN. OKAY SO THAT
LEAVES US WITH GARCIA. AND, THE
VICE CHAIR HAS MADE A MOTION
THAT, BECAUSE IT'S A DIFFERENT
MOTION THAN ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENTS. OR A CLEAN PASS. WE
HAVE TO GO PRINT IT UP. IT'S
THAT'S NOW UNDERWAY. COPIES OF
THE MOTION IN WRITING WILL BE
PROVIDED TO THE MEMBERS, AND
THEN WE WILL ENTERTAIN THAT
MOTION, THAT UNFORTUNATELY, I
WILL NOT BE SUPPORTING. BUT TAKE
A RECESS. BUT WE'RE GONNA HAVE
TO TAKE A RECESS. UNTIL THEN.
FIGURE ON THE GARCIA BILL. WE
DON'T HAVE A PIECE OF PAPER. I
UNDERSTAND, SO, BUT IT'S BEING
PRINTED UP. I THINK, IN THE
MEANTIME, SINCE THEN, I
MENTIONED I WAS HERE. WE MIGHT
AS WELL LIFT CALLS AND LET HER
ADD ON. OKAY, SO WE'LL. SO WHILE
THAT DOCUMENT IS BEING PREPARED,
IT'S GOING TO BE RUN OVER HERE
SO FOLKS CAN HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY
TO SEE IT, WE'LL LET SENATOR
MENGIBAR ADD ON. SO LET'S START
WITH AB 1042 BAUER-KAHAN. AB
1042 THE MOTION IS DUE PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS. THE
CURRENT VOTE IS 2 TO 0, WITH THE
CHAIR VOTING AYE. SENATORS DALI
GONZALEZ HURTADO, MENGIBAR
MENGIBAR. AYE NGUYEN SKINNER
OKAY, SO THAT'S 3 TO 2. WE'LL
LEAVE THAT OPEN FOR 3 TO 0, 3 TO
0. OKAY OKAY, GREAT. NEXT WE'LL
GO TO AB TEN 2085 B¢O HÌNH. THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS. THE CURRENT
VOTE IS 4 TO 2, WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING AYE. THE VICE CHAIR
VOTING NO. SENATORS GONZALEZ.
OH, YOU KNOW WHAT? YOU ALREADY
VOTED ON THIS ONE. OH I'M SORRY.
YEAH, THE MANAGER'S ALREADY
THERE. ALL RIGHT. LET'S GO TO AB
2214 BAUER-KAHAN. THE MOTION IS
Dð PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS. THE
CURRENT VOTE IS 3 TO 1 WITH THE
CHAIR VOTING AYE. THE VICE CHAIR
VOTING NO. SENATORS GONZALEZ
MENGIBAR MENGIBAR. AYE NGUYEN.
OKAY. WE'LL NEXT GO TO
BAUER-KAHAN 2236. THE MOTION IS
DUE. PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. THE CURRENT VOTE
IS 3 TO 2, WITH THE CHAIR VOTING
AYE. THE VICE CHAIR VOTING NO.
SENATORS GONZALEZ MENGIBAR
MENGIBAR. AYE OKAY. NEXT WE GO
TO AB 1122 BANES. THE MOTION IS
DUE PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. THE CURRENT VOTE
IS 5 TO 0, WITH THE CHAIR VOTING
AYE AND THE VICE CHAIR VOTING
AYE. SENATORS GONZALEZ MENGIBAR
MENGIBAR. AYE ALL RIGHT. GRAYSON
AB 1296, ITEM SIX. THE MOTION IS
DUE. PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS. THE
CURRENT VOTE IS 5 TO 0, WITH THE
CHAIR VOTING AYE. THE VICE CHAIR
OF VOTING AYE. SENATORS GONZALEZ
MENGIBAR MENGIBAR. AYE ALL
RIGHT. THAT IS 6 TO 0. LET'S NOW
GO TO 1359. THE MOTION IS DUE.
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS. THE
CURRENT VOTE IS 5 TO 0 WITH THE
CHAIR VOTING AYE. THE VICE CHAIR
VOTING AYE. SENATORS GONZALEZ
MENGIBAR MENGIBAR. AYE HAPPEN,
LEAVE THAT OPEN, PAP. AND AB
1921 MOTION IS DUE. PASS TO
APPROPRIATION. THE CURRENT VOTE
IS 4 TO 0 WITH THE CHAIR VOTING
AYE. THE VICE CHAIR VOTING AYE.
SENATORS GONZALEZ MENGIBAR
MENGIBAR. AYE NGUYEN. ALL RIGHT.
CONSENT CALENDAR. WE SHOULD DO
AS WELL. OKAY. FILE ITEM NUMBER
NINE STARTS THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. SENATORS GONZALEZ
MENGIBAR MENGIBAR. AYE OKAY. 6
TO 0, BERMAN AB 2083, THE MOTION
IS DUE. PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. THE CURRENT VOTE
IS 3 TO 2, WITH THE CHAIR VOTING
AYE. THE VICE CHAIR VOTING NO.
SENATORS GONZALEZ MENGIBAR
MENGIBAR. AYE OKAY, ASSEMBLY
MEMBER HART'S AB 20. YEAH, WE'RE
GONNA LEAVE THAT OPEN. THAT'S 4
TO 2. ASSEMBLY MEMBER HART'S
2298. THE MOTION IS DUE. PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS. THE
CURRENT VOTE IS 5 TO 0, WITH THE
CHAIR VOTING AYE. THE VICE CHAIR
VOTING AYE. SENATORS GONZALEZ
MENGIBAR MENGIBAR. AYE. ALL
RIGHT. 6 TO 0. WE'LL LEAVE THAT
OPEN FOR SENATOR GONZALEZ. AB
2300. WILSON. THE MOTION IS DUE.
PASS. THE CURRENT VOTE IS 5 TO 0
WITH THE CHAIR VOTING AYE. THE
VICE CHAIR VOTING AYE. SENATORS
GONZALEZ MENGIBAR MENGIBAR AYE,
6 TO 0. WE'LL LEAVE THAT OPEN,
AB 2346. LEE, THE MOTION IS DUE.
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. THE CURRENT VOTE
IS 5 TO 0. CHAIR VOTING AYE. THE
VICE CHAIR VOTING AYE. SENATORS
GONZALEZ MENGIBAR MENGIBAR. AYE
OKAY. THAT IS 6 TO 0. WE'LL
LEAVE THAT OPEN FOR LENA. LET'S
SEE. 2454 LEE, THE MOTION IS DUE.
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS. THE
CURRENT VOTE IS 3 TO 0, WITH THE
CHAIR VOTING AYE. SENATORS DALI
GONZALEZ MENGIBAR MENGIBAR. AYE.
NGUYEN 4 TO 0. LEAVE THAT OPEN.
2514 AGUIAR-CURRY. THE MOTION IS
DUE. PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. THE CURRENT VOTE
IS 5 TO 0, WITH THE CHAIR VOTING
AYE. THE VICE CHAIR VOTING AYE.
SENATORS GONZALEZ MENGIBAR
MENGIBAR. AYE. OKAY BONTA'S
2851. THE MOTION IS DUE. PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS. THE
CURRENT VOTE IS 3 TO 0, WITH THE
CHAIR VOTING AYE. SENATORS DALI
GONZALEZ. MENGIBAR MENGIBAR. AYE
NGUYEN. ALL RIGHT, THAT'S 4 TO
0. CALDERON 2958. THE MOTION IS
DUE. PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS. THE
CURRENT VOTE IS 3 TO 0, WITH THE
CHAIR VOTING AYE. SENATORS DALI
GONZALEZ, MENGIBAR MENGIBAR. AYE
NGUYEN 4 TO 0. ALL RIGHT. WE'LL
LEAVE THOSE OPEN. BRIEF RECESS.
OKAY IF YOU LIKE. YEAH, SURE.
I'M COMFORTABLE WITH IT. ALL
RIGHT. THANK GOD YOU'RE HERE.
ALL RIGHT. SO, WE'RE WE'RE GOING
TO ENTERTAIN A MOTION FROM THE
VICE CHAIR. WELL, I'M SO GLAD
THAT I COULD BRING SO MANY
PARTIES TOGETHER ALL AT ONCE.
THE MOTION IS DUE. PASS IS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS AND
THE AMENDMENTS WOULD BE STRIKE
TO SEEK EXEMPTION FOR RIGHT OF
WAYS. LANGUAGE IN THE BILL AS
SECTION ONE, PUBLIC RESOURCES
CODE, SECTION 21 080.60, AS
PROPOSED, PAGE TWO, LINES ONE
THROUGH FIVE AND PAGE THREE.
LINES ONE THROUGH 26 STRIKE THE
LANGUAGE IN THE BILL REGARDING
THE REBUTTABLE PRESUMPTION IN
SECTION 2840 5.14 AND REPLACE IT
WITH THE FOLLOWING TEXT
RECOGNIZING THE CALIFORNIA CAISO
TRANSMISSION PLANNING FINDINGS
AND CONSISTENT WITH LAW UNDER
SEQUA, THE COMMISSION MAY
INCLUDE HUESO FACTUAL FINDINGS
REGARDING A PROJECT'S OBJECTIVES
AND BENEFITS IN THE COMMISSION'S
STATEMENT OF OBJECTIVES AND ANY
STATEMENT OF OVERRIDING
CONSIDERATION DOING IN DOING SO
IS CONSISTENT WITH CEQA
GUIDELINES 15 124 B AND 15 093B.
NOTHING IN SECRET REQUIRES THE
COMMISSION TO IGNORE SUCH
FINDINGS AND IS REASONABLE FOR
THE COMMISSION TO RECOGNIZE THEM.
OKAY. YOU DO. THAT'S THE MOTION.
I THINK IT'S A WEDDING. I DO
RIGHT? SHOTGUN. RIGHT YEAH.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATORS ALLEN. AYE ALAN, I
DALLY DALLY, AYE. GONZALEZ.
HURTADO MENGIBAR. MENGIBAR. AYE
NGUYEN. NGUYEN. AYE SKINNER Y
SKINNER. AYE OKAY. LET ME. YEAH
LET'S GO THROUGH THEM ALL. OF
COURSE. YEAH I BELIEVE THIS IS
MY LAST EC MEETING AS BEING IN
THE SENATE. I JUST WANT TO TAKE
THIS OPPORTUNITY TO, FIRST OF
ALL, THANK THE CHAIR WHO HAS
BEEN MY CHAIR ALL ALONG. I
SERVED ON S TÌM AND THE
ASSEMBLY, LOVE THIS COMMITTEE.
HATE IT AT TIMES TOO, BUT, I
JUST WANT TO SAY THANK YOU TO
THE STAFF. BOTH SIDES. I MEAN,
SCOTT'S NOT HERE TODAY. I KNOW
THAT HE'S I DON'T KNOW HE'S WHAT
HE'S DOING. HOPEFULLY ENJOYING
HIMSELF SOMEWHERE, BUT, AND JUST
ALL THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS THAT
HAVE INDULGED ME ON THIS STAFF
AND I APPRECIATE ALL THE STAFF
AND IT'S BEEN A PLEASURE TO
SERVE WITH YOU, OVER THE LAST
FOUR YEARS. SO THANK YOU. WELL,
THANK YOU, MISS. THANK YOU, MR.
VICE CHAIR. AND WE'RE. YEAH AND
MR. CHAIR, CHAIR, SINCE I'M IN
THE SAME SITUATION AS MY FRIEND,
THE SENATOR FROM TEHAMA, I GET
THAT. NO RED BLUFF. BEAVER.
BEAVER, BEAVER. ANYWAY FROM THE
FAR NORTH, I ALSO WANT TO
EXPRESS MY APPRECIATION AND,
WOULD LOVE TO BE ABLE TO STAY ON
THE COMMITTEE, BUT DON'T GET TO.
BUT I REALLY DO APPRECIATE HIM.
WE HAVE DONE GREAT WORK. THANK
YOU. WE'VE HAD SUCH GREAT
MEMBERS AND SUCH GREAT STAFF,
AND WE'RE OBVIOUSLY GOING TO BE
MANY WELL-DESERVED ACCOLADES.
GIVEN TO OUR COLLEAGUES. SENATOR
DAWLEY AND SENATOR SKINNER,
THROUGH THE COURSE IN THE FINAL
MONTH. BUT I JUST WANT TO SAY
WHAT A PLEASURE TO SPEND TO
SERVE WITH YOU, YOU BOTH BROUGHT
SUCH GREAT INSIGHT AND WISDOM TO
THE PROCESS FROM YOUR VARYING
PERSPECTIVES. AND. YEAH IT'S
REALLY SAD TO LOSE THIS
EXPERTISE, QUITE FRANKLY. BUT
FROM BOTH OF YOU, I MEAN, AND
EVEN EVEN IN THE CONTEXT OF THIS
CONTENTIOUS BILL THAT WE JUST
WORKED ON, YOU KNOW, BOTH OF YOU
PLAYED AN IMPORTANT ROLE IN
HELPING US GET THERE, AND SO I
WANT TO THANK YOU. I WANT TO
THANK THE STAFF, OF COURSE, AS
WELL. I MEAN, WHAT A GREAT TEAM
WE HAVE. VERY DILIGENT, GOOD
CAMARADERIE. FLEXIBILITY AND
CREATIVITY THAT, YOU KNOW, JUST
ON DISPLAY LITERALLY JUST NOW,
FROM GAB. ERIC, YOU KNOW, BREN,
HOLLY, YOU KNOW, PATRICIA, AS
WELL, OF COURSE. AND SCOTT,
WHO'S, WHO'S REALLY, REALLY,
REALLY GREAT, RENE. JUST A
WONDERFUL, WONDERFUL TEAM. AND
I'VE JUST BEEN IT'S PART OF WHAT
MAKES THE WORK REALLY FUN IS
HAVING SUCH A GREAT TEAM TO WORK
WITH. AND SO AND LET ME, LET ME
JUST TAKE A MOMENT TO, TO JUST
MENTION HOLLY, WHO'S, KIND OF IN
A, YOU KNOW, HOLLY HAS BEEN OUR
SCIENCE FELLOW, AND I JUST LOVE
THE SCIENCE FELLOWSHIP. I GOT TO
SAY. I MEAN, IT IS JUST PROVIDES
CONSISTENTLY HIGH QUALITY, HIGH
CALIBER FOLKS, INCLUDING SOME
ALUMS THAT ARE NOW, YOU KNOW,
SERVING ON THE PERMANENT STAFF,
BUT IT'S JUST SUCH AN
EXTRAORDINARY PROGRAM. AND, YOU
KNOW, AT THIS MOMENT IN TIME
WHERE WE NEED, YOU KNOW, SCIENCE
IN GOVERNMENT DECISION MAKING
MORE THAN EVER, HAVING THIS
PIPELINE FOR REALLY SHARP,
TALENTED PHDS COMING UP, THE
SYSTEM TO FIND THEIR WAY ONTO
THE DAIS WITH US HELPING TO
INFORM OUR DECISIONS IS JUST
WONDERFUL, YOU KNOW, MANY OF YOU
DON'T KNOW HOW THE INCREDIBLE
CALIBER AND TALENT THAT WE HAVE
HERE ON THE DAIS, BUT BUT, YOU
KNOW, HOLLY, EARNED HER PHD FROM
YALE FOR HER WORK IN GREEN
CHEMISTRY AND WATER QUALITY LAST
FALL, SHE CAME OUT TO CALIFORNIA
BECAUSE OF THE SCIENCE
FELLOWSHIP. RIGHT. AND WANTED TO
DO THIS WORK WITH US, YOU KNOW,
REALLY GOT THE CHANCE TO APPLY
HER HER SKILLS TO, AND HER
KNOWLEDGE TO SOME REALLY
CONSEQUENTIAL LEGISLATION THAT
HAD A LOT TO DO WITH THE THINGS
YOU WORKED ON AS A AS A DOCTORAL
STUDENT, SO, YOU KNOW, WE'VE
HAD, YOU KNOW, A REAL EXPERT IN
GREEN CHEMISTRY ON OUR TEAM,
THROUGH THE COURSE OF THE YEAR,
WHICH IS REALLY BEEN HELPFUL. I
MEAN, SHE ANALYZED SOME OF THE
BIGGEST PFAS SPILLS, WATER
QUALITY, SOLID WASTE, GREEN
CHEMISTRY, YOU KNOW, REALLY
PLAYED AN IMPORTANT ROLE IN
HELPING TO SHAPE THOSE, THOSE
BILLS, SHE'S ALSO JUST A GREAT
PERSON AND SOMEONE WHO'S, YOU
KNOW, SHE'S CHEERFUL, YOU KNOW,
SHE'S SHE'S SHE'S AMENABLE.
SHE'S FRIENDLY, I KNOW EVERYONE
ON THE TEAMS REALLY ENJOYED
HAVING HER. AND SHE'S JUST.
SOMETIMES THERE'S PEOPLE WHO ARE
REALLY TALENTED, BUT THEY DON'T
ALWAYS MAKE LIFE FUN TO LIVE
WITH AND BE WITH AND WORK WITH.
AND HOLLY IS JUST THE OPPOSITE.
I MEAN, SHE'S JUST A JUST A GOT
A GREAT SMILE AND A GREAT, GREAT
ATTITUDE. SO, SO AND BY THE WAY,
YOU KNOW, A REALLY, REALLY GOOD
NEGOTIATOR. AND, YOU KNOW, I
KNOW THAT SHE WAS, YOU KNOW,
PERSONALLY INVOLVED WITH, WITH A
WHOLE SLEW OF, OF DIFFICULT,
BILLS. AND OF COURSE,
NEGOTIATIONS IS A REALLY
IMPORTANT PART OF THIS PROCESS,
BUT SHE WORKED ON BILLS RELATED
TO HOUSEHOLD PRODUCT SAFETY.
BISPHENOLS, PESTICIDES,
ANTICOAGULANTS AND PARAQUAT,
WHICH WE JUST HEARD LAST, LAST
TIME. NEONICS, PLASTIC BAGS,
MICROPLASTICS, RARE EARTH
MATERIALS. I MEAN, YOU KNOW, YOU
WERE INVOLVED WITH HELPING TO
SHEPHERD THE NEGOTIATIONS AND
THESE NEGOTIATIONS ARE NOT EASY.
YOU'RE DEALING WITH, YOU KNOW,
MASSIVE EGOS FROM THE MEMBERS,
YOU KNOW, WELL-PAID SPIN ARTISTS
FROM, YOU KNOW, FROM THE
ADVOCACY COMMUNITY. AND TO BE
ABLE TO SORT THROUGH AND FIND
THE RIGHT PATH IS REALLY
IMPORTANT. AND HOLLY'S BEEN
GREAT WITH THAT. SO ANYWAY,
ANYONE WHO'S LISTENING, HOLLY'S
TRANSITIONING AND, YOU KNOW,
LOOKING FOR HER NEXT CAREER
MOVE, YOU KNOW, FIRST OF ALL,
I'M GOING TO ASK ERIC. I'D LOVE
TO EXPAND THE SLOTS ON THIS
COMMITTEE SO WE CAN KEEP HER,
BUT YOU KNOW, THAT'S ABOVE MY
PAY GRADE, BUT BUT REALLY, THIS
YOUNG, YOUNG LADY, YOU KNOW, I'M
SURE IS GOING TO LAND SOMEWHERE
REALLY GREAT, BUT WANT TO WANT
TO HELP HER DO THAT, SO THANKS
AGAIN, HOLLY. AND, OF COURSE,
YOU KNOW, JUST THANKS AGAIN TO
THIS WONDERFUL STAFF. I MEAN, I
JUST REALLY APPRECIATE THIS
WONDERFUL EC STAFF. HOLLY. ERIC,
BRIAN. SCOTT. RENEE, GAB. OF
COURSE, OUR FEARLESS LEADER, YOU
KNOW, THIS HAS JUST BEEN A
PLEASURE TO WORK WITH YOU. SO,
WITH THAT, CONGRATULATIONS TO
ALL THE AUTHORS. CONGRATULATIONS
WE'RE GOING TO WE'RE GOING TO
WE'RE GOING TO LET EVERYONE GO,
BUT WE'RE JUST GOING TO I'M
GOING TO SIT AROUND WAITING FOR
OUR MAJORITY LEADER. SO THANK
YOU. THANK YOU EVERYONE. YEAH.
THANK YOU. YEAH I KNOW.
HERE. EVERYTHING IS IN I.
RECOMMENDATION FROM THE CHAIR.
NOW THAT WE'VE WORKED OUT SOME
TRICKY THINGS. SO LET'S REOPEN
THE ROLL. LET'S REOPEN THE ROLL
ITEM A ITEM ONE AB 1042
BARKHORN. SORRY, I DON'T NEED TO
READ THE MOTIONS FOR YOU. OKAY.
THE CURRENT VOTE IS 3 TO 0 WITH
THE CHAIR VOTING AYE. SENATORS
DOLLY GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ AYE.
HURTADO NGUYEN WAS 4 TO 0, 4 TO
0. WE WILL CLOSE THE ROLL ON
THAT. THAT PASSES OUT. LET'S SAY
ITEM TWO AB TEN AB 2085
BAUER-KAHAN. OKAY. THE CURRENT
VOTE IS 4 TO 2 WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING AYE. THE VICE CHAIR
VOTING NO. SENATORS GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ I 5 TO 2, 5 TO 2. OKAY,
ITEM THREE. THAT'S OUT.
BAUER-KAHAN AB 2214. THE CURRENT
VOTE IS 4 TO 1. THE CHAIR VOTING
AYE. VICE CHAIR VOTING NO.
SENATORS GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ I
WIN. ALL RIGHT. THAT IS A 5 TO 1
VOTE. AND THAT IS OUT NEXT. WE
GO TO AB 2236 B¢O Kò HÌNH. THE
CURRENT VOTE IS 4 TO 2 WITH THE
CHAIR VOTING AYE. THE VICE CHAIR
VOTING NO. SENATORS GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ I 5 TO 2 VOTED FOR THAT.
YES OKAY. THAT IS 5 TO 2. SO
WE'LL CLOSE THE ROLL ON THAT.
THAT'S OUT AB 1122 BANES OKAY.
THE CURRENT VOTE IS 6 TO 0.
SENATORS GONZALEZ. YES, DO PASS
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
CHAIR VOTING AYE. AND THE VICE
CHAIR VOTING AYE. YES. GONZALEZ
AYE. OKAY. 7 TO 0. ITEM SIX AB
1296. GRAYSON. OKAY. MOTION IS
DUE. PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS. THE
CURRENT VOTE IS 6 TO 0. CHAIR.
VOTING AYE. VICE CHAIR. VOTING
AYE. SENATORS GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ
AYE. THAT'S 7 TO 0. THAT IS OUT.
LET'S GO TO ITEM SEVEN. NOW,
THIS IS, PAPINES AB 1359. OKAY.
MOTION DO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. THE CURRENT VOTE
IS 6 TO 0. THE CHAIR VOTING AYE.
THE VICE CHAIR VOTING AYE.
SENATORS GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ I 77
TO 0. ALL RIGHT. AB 1921, PAPPAN
MOTION DO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. THE CURRENT VOTE
IS 5 TO 0. THE CHAIR VOTING AYE
AND THE VICE CHAIR VOTING AYE.
SENATORS GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ. I
WIN 6 TO 0. 6 TO 0. ALL RIGHT.
LET'S GO TO ITEM 11. THAT'S AB
2083. BERMAN DO YOU WANT TO. OR
YOU CAN DO CONSENT. OH, WE DO
CONSENT. LET'S DO CONSENT. WHY
NOT? FILE ITEM NUMBER NINE
STARTS CONSENT CALENDAR.
SENATORS GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I 7
TO 0, 7 TO 0. WE'LL CLOSE THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. LET'S NOW GO
TO BERMAN'S. ITEM 11 EB 2083.
THE MOTION IS DUE PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS. THE
CURRENT VOTE IS 4 TO 2, WITH THE
CHAIR VOTING AYE. THE VICE CHAIR
VOTING NO. SENATOR GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ I 5 TO 2, 5 TO 2, LET'S
GO TO ITEM 12. HEARTS AB 2298.
MOTION IS DUE. PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS. THE CURRENT
VOTE IS 6 TO 0. SENATOR WITH THE
CHAIR VOTING AYE. VICE CHAIR
VOTING AYE. SENATOR GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ. AYE. 7 TO 0. ALL
RIGHT. 7 TO 0. WE'LL CLOSE THE
ROLL ON THAT ITEM 13 WEBERS AB
2300. SORRY WILSON WILSON'S THE
MOTION IS DUE. PASS. THE CURRENT
VOTE IS 6 TO 0 WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING AYE. THE VICE CHAIR
VOTING AYE. SENATOR GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ. AYE. ALL RIGHT. SEVEN
ZERO. WE'LL CLOSE THE ROLL ON
THAT ITEM. 14. LEE'S 2346.
MOTION IS DUE. PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS. THE CURRENT
VOTE IS 6 TO 0 WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING AYE. THE VICE CHAIR
VOTING AYE. SENATOR GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ. AYE 7 TO 0 SEVEN ZERO.
WILL WE WILL WE'LL CLOSE THE
ROLL ON THAT, I LEE'S 2454
MOTION. DO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. THE CURRENT VOTE
IS 4 TO 0 WITH THE CHAIR VOTING
AYE. SENATORS DOLLY GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ. AYE. NGUYEN 5 TO 0 5
TO 0. OKAY. AGUIAR-CURRY 24
2514. THE MOTION IS DUE. PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS. THE
CURRENT VOTE IS 6 TO 0. THE
CHAIR VOTING AYE. THE VICE CHAIR
VOTING AYE. SENATOR GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ. AYE SEVEN ZERO. CLOSE
THE ROLL ON THAT BOND AS AB
2851. THE MOTION IS DUE. PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS. THE
CURRENT VOTE IS 4 TO 0, WITH THE
CHAIR VOTING AYE. SENATOR SALIH
GONZALEZ GONZALEZ. AYE. NGUYEN 5
TO 0. ALL RIGHT, 5 TO 0. WE'LL
CLOSE THE ROLL ON THAT. CALDERON
AB 2958. MOTION DO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. THE CURRENT VOTE
IS 4 TO 0 WITH THE CHAIR VOTING
AYE. SENATOR SALIH GONZALEZ
GONZALEZ. AYE NGUYEN FIVE ZERO.
ALL RIGHT, 5 TO 0. LET'S NOW GO
TO ITEM NUMBER 20. THIS IS THE
GARCIA BILL WITH THE SUBSTITUTE.
AMENDMENT. SHE DOES HAVE THE
COPY. OKAY, SO YES, WE'LL CALL
THE ROLL NOW AB 3238 THE MOTION.
DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. THE CURRENT VOTE
IS 5 TO 0 5 TO 0. SENATORS
GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ. AYE 6 TO 0 6
TO 0. WE'LL CLOSE THE ROLL. ALL
RIGHT. WELL, THAT DOES IT. THANK
YOU EVERYONE. YES, GABRIELLE,
THIS HEARING IS ADJOURNED.